WELCOME TO ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
TODAY IS TUESDAY JULY
THIRTEENTH. BEAR WITH US AS WE
DO SOME ADMINISTRATIVE. ITEMS
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT
WE WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF BILLS TO
DO TODAY SO. IF WE CAN WORK.
MEMBERS HERE ESTABLISH
CORPSMAN. GET OUR BUSINESS
STARTED THAT WOULD BE
APPRECIATED. SO BECAUSE WE ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF.
OPENING BUT YET BEING CAUTIOUS
MASTER REQUIRED. AND WE ASK
EVERYBODY TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE BEING SAFE AND
INAPPROPRIATELY. MASTAN WE DO
ENCOURAGE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
BOTH HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND AROUND THE CAPITAL WE DO
HAVE SEVERAL OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES. I GUESS WE DO HAVE
THE WITNESS THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION IS AVAILABLE.
AS WELL AS IN PERSON TESTIMONY
WHICH IS UP IN THE GALLERY AND
I SEE SOME FOLKS UP THERE
ALREADY. AND THE CALL IN NUMBER
YOU CAN SEE THE CALL THE NUMBER
ON YOUR SCREEN THAT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN AGAIN
THE PHONE NUMBER. IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE. TWO FOUR TWO SIX
TWO THREE SEVEN SO WE WILL BE I
KNOW THIS ROOM IS A BIT AWKWARD
FOR DOING COMMITTEE HEARINGS.
BUT WE'LL DO THE BEST THAT WE
CAN. SO AS A SUB COMMITTEE AS
WE COLLECT MEMBERS THAT'S GOOD.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH OUR
ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS SB
FORTY ONE SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- ONE OF
BEGIN BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
ALSO- COMMITTEE STAFFER MERRY
OF SOLOMON FOR THEIR VERY HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL- WITH THIS
BILL IS ABOUT IS ABOUT
PROTECTING YOUR GENETIC.
MATERIAL MANY OF US INCLUDING
ME HAVE SUBMITTED MATERIALS TO
FOR EXAMPLE ATTRACT CONSUMER
GENETIC TESTING COMPANY TWENTY
THREE ME ANCESTRY DOT COM THERE
ARE QUITE A NUMBER. OF MOST OF
THESE COMPANIES IT HEAR TO
ETHICAL STANDARDS IN TERMS OF
THE PRESERVATION AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THAT GENETIC
INFORMATION BUT- SOME DO NOT
AND THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
YOU. PROVIDE YOUR GENETIC
INFORMATION TO. NAME THE
COMPANY THAT YOU CAN BE ASSURED
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO BE IN
CHARGE OF THE USE OF THAT
GENETIC DATA- THIS BILL HAS A-
BROAD SUPPORT. AND WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IS MAUREEN MAHONEY FROM
CONSUMER REPORTS I BELIEVE ON
THE ON THE- LINE AND ERIC
KEITH. ANCESTORS CHIEF PRIVACY
OFFICER. RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES BOTH WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE MARIE MAHONEY AND
ERIC KEITH SO MARIE MAHONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS MAUREEN MAHONEY I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST AT
CONSUMER REPORTS WELL PROBABLY
SUPPORTING SB FORTY ONE BECAUSE
TO PROVIDE IMPORTANT PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. THIS UNIQUELY
SENSITIVE GENETIC DATA DATA CAN
PROVIDE INSIGHTS INTO WHETHER
YOU OR A FAMILY MEMBER IS
VULNERABLE TO CERTAIN DISEASES.
AND CONSUMERS STRONGLY VALUE
PRODUCTION SERVICE DATA IS EVER
SIXTY THOUSAND CONSUMERS TO
FIND OUR PETITION CALLING ON
LAWMAKERS TO ENSURE THAT IS
KEPT PRIVATE AND SECURE. THE
BILL REQUIRED CONSENT FOR THE
COLLECTION SECONDARY USE AND
DISCLOSURE OF THIS DATA IT HAS
A PROVISION TO REVOKE CONSENT
AS WELL PUTTING CONSUMER
SQUARELY IN CONTROL IMPORTANTLY
THE DEFINITION OF CONSENT IS
QUITE STRONG TO MAKE SURE THAT
CONSUMERS KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GETTING INTO. AND HAVE A REAL
CHOICE OVER HOW THIS DATA IS
USED WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ROBUST AND PRODUCTIVE
STAKEHOLDER DIALOGUE OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS IT'S
GOTTEN IS STILL INTO A GOOD
PLACE. AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AND- THANK YOU AND THEN ERIC HE-
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN STONE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIC HEAT
THEN THE CHIEF PRIVACY OFFICER.
AT ANCESTRY- INDUSTRY IS THE
WORLD'S LEADING FAMILY HISTORY
COMPANY AND ONE OF THE LARGEST
PROVIDERS OF DIRECT TO CONSUMER
GENETIC TESTING SERVICES. AND
WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY IN FULL SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY ONE. ANCESTRIES PROUD OF
THE WORK WE HAVE DONE WITH OUR
COALITION PARTNERS INCLUDING
TWENTY THREE IN ME. TO
IMPLEMENT COMMONSENSE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS THAT HELP ENSURE
CUSTOMERS REMAIN IN CONTROL OF
THEIR GENETIC DATA. TO GET A
WITH PRIVACY ADVOCATES AND
FUTURE PRIVACY FOR A LEADING
NONPROFIT THAT FOCUSES ON
PROJECT GOT LEADERSHIP. OUR
COALITION DEVELOPED WHAT WE
BELIEVE ARE THE APPROPRIATE
GUIDELINES TO HELP ENSURE
CUSTOMERS. HAVE CONTROL OVER
THEIR DATA ARE PRESENTED WITH
EASY TO UNDERSTAND PRIVACY
POLICIES ARE EMPOWERED TO MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW THEIR DATA
SHOULD BE USED. INCLUDING A
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY PROVIDE
EXPRESS CONSENT ANY TIME THAT
DATA IS SHARED WITH A THIRD
PARTY. AND THAT THEY CAN IN THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH US AND DELETE
THEIR DATA AT ANYTIME. SB FORTY
ONE PUT THESE PROTECTIONS INTO
LAW OUTLINING OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS THINK CLEARLY EXPLAIN
THEIR RIGHTS WHEN THE ENGAGE
WITH DIRECT TO CONSUMER GENETIC
TESTING SERVICES. TO LEARN
ABOUT THEIR FAMILY THEIR
ETHNICITY OR THEIR HEALTH. SB
FORTY ONE WILL ALSO HOLD EVERY
DIRECT TO CONSUMER GENETIC
TESTING SERVICES THE SAME
PRIVACY STANDARDS. IF PASSED SB
FORTY ONE WILL PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA'S TO THIS IS THE
STRONGEST PRIVACY PROTECTION
PROJECT DATA IN THE WORLD. AND
WE WANT TO THANK CENTER
pIMPORTANT ISSUE AND WHAT MANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. RIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT WELL OFFER
INDICATION OF SUPPORT FOR SB
FORTY ONE WE WILL BE TAKING
ANYMORE TESTIMONY PER SE BUT
YOU CAN GIVE US YOUR NAME YOUR
FILIATION AND YOUR SUPPORT
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
RIGHT THREE NINE PROMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR FOLKS WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB FORTY
ONE. TO SPEAK FOR AND SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH
TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME. IN
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND WE WILL CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER WHEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF YOU'RE ON SPEAKER
PHONE PICK UP YOUR HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING ANY BUTTONS.
BGMEA FEATURE WHEN YOU'RE NOT-
PLEASE CHECK IN THE FUTURE ALSO.
WE HAVE CLIENTS CHEWING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THE LINE NUMBERS. FIRST GO TO
LINE TWENTY EIGHT GO AHEAD
PLEASE. CAROLINA APPEARED ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CAL ACTION IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE ONE OF THE
LINE ON OUR IN Q. ONE THEY'RE
STILL GETTING THEIR LINE NUMBER.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. MORNING AT THE
FAIR A COUPLE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN TO THIS TIME LAST
YEAR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. LISTED SO IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FORTY WHAT. SEEING NONE OF
IT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN LIVES OR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. BEGIN IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY ONE. AND
IF IT WOULD LET WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE GIVING UP. RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE ALLIANCE
OF BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
YEAH. SHE WITH FEDERAL HAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- I HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK
AT HIS BILL TWICE IN PRIVACY
AND I SUPPORTED THE BILL TWICE
THE BILL ESSENTIALLY IS IT
PROVIDES A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
FOR A FRAMEWORK OF GOVERNING
DATA COLLECTION AND USE OF-
GENETIC DATA WHICH IS A VERY-
OF VERY SENSITIVE PIECE OF
INFORMATION NO- STILL. AN IDOL
FORTY SUPPORTING IT AGAIN AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORED
SENATOR FOR BRING IT FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. RIGHT THANK YOU
CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE. I THANK
YOU AGAIN MISTER CHAIR- THANK
YOU SOME OF THEM ARE CHAO FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL- NOW TWO
YEARS IN A ROW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH URGEN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
RIGHT LET'S SEE WE DO HAVE A-
QUORUM PRESENT SO WOULD YOU
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HERE
GALLAGHER CHAO- DAVIES.
GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND. AND THE SECOND ON
SB FORTY ONE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHAU. CHARGE YOU.
DAVIES DAVIES ARKANSAS IS.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES.
RAYSIDE TOP. OKAY THAT BILLS
OUT THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWO
ELEVEN. ALREADY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN MEMBERS- S. B.
TWO ELEVEN IS THE ANNUAL BILL
RELATING TO THE STATE BAR
TYPICALLY THIS IS A NON
CONTROVERSIAL BILL- THIS YEAR
IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT BECAUSE
OF SOME OF INSTEAD OF THAT HAVE
BASICALLY BEEN DISCOVERED IN
THE COURSE OF THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS- YOU'VE HEARD REPORTS.
OF MISTER TOM GIRARDI AND
ISSUES SURROUNDING HIS PRACTICE
AND- THE USE OF OUR LEAST
ALLEGE USE OF CLIENTS TRUST
FUNDS. SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS THIS BILL. REAUTHORIZES
STATE BAR BUT ELIMINATES THE
BAR DUES- AT LEAST UP UNTIL THE
STATE BAR- NOMINATES AND HAS
CONFIRMED CHIEF TRIAL COUNSEL
BAR HAS NOT HAD A CHIEF TRIAL
COUNSEL FOR FIVE YEARS I AM
CONFIDENT THEY ARE MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION- AND- I AM MOST
HOPEFUL THAT THAT. I WILL AMEND
THE BILL TO. PLACE THE BAR DUES
THE- PARDEW'S AMOUNT BACK IN
THE BILL WHICH WOULD BE THE
SAME AS LAST YEAR. OF THE BAR
HAS DONE AN AUDIT- WE'VE NOT
SEEN THAT AUDIT- NEED NEITHER
CHAIR STONE NOR I HAVE SEEN
THAT AUDIT AND WE THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT THAT THERE BE.
ANOTHER OUTSIDE COMPREHENSIVE
AUDITS. OF AFTER. THE BAR
NOMINATES AND WE HAVE CONFIRMED
A CHIEF TRIAL COUNSEL. I EXPECT
THAT THE- DUES WILL BE REPLACED
AND THAT THEY'LL BE A BILL
WHICH WE PASSED BY BOTH HOUSES
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. AYE
ORIGIN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND. AND A SECOND
THANK YOU I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED FROM THE STATE
BAR I KNOW THAT THE STATE BAR
IS NOT ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE A COUPLE OF THE
PROVISIONS. BUT WANTED TO SPEAK
ON THE BILL SO WE HAVE SHOWN
SELECT FROM THE STATE BAR AND
WE HAVE LIAM WILSON WHO IS ALSO
ON THE TELEPHONE. HERE FOR ON
STAND BY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. SO THE FIRST WITNESS.
HI GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS I
AM SHAUN SELAIN CHAIR OF THE
STATE BAR BOARD OF TRUSTEES I'M
HERE WITH WE WILL SEND. A POOR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- AND WE HAS
GRACIOUSLY GRANTED ME SOME OF
HER TIME. UNFORTUNATELY AS YOU
ALREADY MENTIONED THE STATE
PARKS UNABLE TO SUPPORT SB TWO
ELEVEN IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
BECAUSE THE BILL CURRENTLY
PROVIDES NO FEES AND LINKS THE
BARS OF FORTY TO COLLECT FEES
TO CONFIRMATION OF THE CHIEF
TRIAL COUNSEL. IF YOU KNOW
LICENSING FEES OR THE BARS
PRIMARY SOURCE OF FUNDING AND
THE ONLY FUNDING. FOR THE
DISCIPLINE SYSTEM. LET ME BE
CLEAR THAT THE KERN BOARD
SHARES YOUR INTO IN REFORM
UNDERSTAND THE FRUSTRATION THAT
YOU FEEL. WE LIKE QUITE CAN
FEEL FRUSTRATED THAT AT TIMES
AS WE WORK TO INVOLVE THIS
ORGANIZATION. I WANT TO ASSURE
YOU THAT THIS BOARD IS NOT
CONTENDING MISTAKES OF THE
PAST. YOUR OWN OCCASIONAL
MISSTEPS WE ARE TRYING TO
RECTIFY THEM WE ARE LISTENING
AND WANT TO WORK WITH YOU IN A
PRODUCTIVE MANNER. HOWEVER LACK
OF STABLE FUNDING GAMMAGE'S THE
INSTITUTION THAT WE ALL WANT TO
REFORM AND WILL MOVE US
BACKWARD. NOT FORWARD. THE
STATE FARM HAS BEEN DILIGENTLY
CONDUCTING A CHIEF TRIAL
COUNSEL SEARCH AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO FINDING
THE MOST QUALIFIED PERSON FOR
THAT ROLE. HOWEVER THE POSITION
IS DIFFICULT THIS BILL AND I DO
NOT ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL
HAVE TO CONFIRM CHIEF TRIAL
COUNSEL BY THE END OF THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. TWO NINE
OR DELAYING FUNDING FOR THE
ENTIRE ORGANIZATION WILL ONLY
MAKE IT HARDER TO RECRUIT FOR
THIS POSITION AND OTHERS. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WITHOUT
FUNDING IT WILL BE CONSUMERS OF
LEGAL SERVICES STATE PARK
STAFF. THEY WILL PAY THE PRICE.
LET ME MENTION THIS ARE ADDRESS
CAN THEY- REPORT. THE STAFF AND-
HIGHLY. THE AUDITORS TO TEST IN
OUR THE BACKLOG GROWTH FOR THE
PERIOD. TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY. ON THIS
ISSUE CONTACT MATTERS. ARE
FILING DURING THAT PERIOD
INCREASED BY NEARLY 20% IN
LARGE PART DUE TO AN ENHANCED
PUBLIC PROTECTION MEASURE WHICH
THE BAR SELF INITIATED. MAINLY
A REQUIREMENT THAT ALL ATTORNEY
BE REACHING FOR CREDIT FOR
CRIMINAL RECORD SCREENING.
FURTHER THE ADDITIONAL STAFF
FUNDED BY THE TWENTY TWENTY
THREE INCREASE HAVE BEGUN TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE. THE
STATUTORY BACKLOG WAS REDUCED
IN 20255% MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR
THE CASES THEY HAVE THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON PUBLIC
PROTECTION. SUCH AS THOSE THAT
INCLUDE ALLEGATIONS OF
MISCONDUCT AGAINST VULNERABLE
VICTIMS INCLUDING IMMIGRANT
SENIORS THE BACKLOG WAS REDUCED
BY 17% A FINAL POINT LET ME
ADDRESS THE RECENT ISSUES
REGARDING ATTORNEY THOMAS
GIRARDI. WE TO AT THE BOARD
WERE DISMAYED BY THE LAPSES IN
INVESTIGATION AND PROSECUTION
REVEALED BY OUR INDEPENDENT
AUDIT AND CLOSE CASES REGARDING
JORDAN AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO
ACTION EVEN THOUGH MANY OF THE
ISSUES IDENTIFIED IN THE AUDIT
EXTEND BACK TWENTY YEARS OR
MORE. SPECIFICALLY PLAN TO
IMPLEMENT A NUMBER OF REFORMS
TO TIGHTLY CONTROLLED BY CLIENT
TRUST ACCOUNT. ROOF PROACTIVE
DETECTION OF MISCONDUCT. SOME
OF THE REFORMS WE'RE LOOKING
AT. SEARCHES HIRING ACCOUNTING
EXPERTS CAN DRILL INTO SUSPECT
TRUST ACCOUNTS COST MONEY. WE
CAN'T MAKE THOSE REFORMS
WITHOUT STABLE FUNDING. THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING AND I STAND
READY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE ALONG WITH LEAH
WILSON ARE GOING TO DO AFTER
THANK YOU. CORRECT THANK YOU SO
IS THERE ANYONE HERE THE WHICH
IN THE HEARING ROOM IN THE
CHAMBERS WHO WANT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. TWO ELEVEN.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN THE ROUTE
MODE TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING
NONE HABITABLE LINES OPERATE
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO ELEVEN. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOUR FIRST
GO TO LINE THIRTY NINE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON THE HOUSE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE ONE OF THE LINE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT WILL BE ASSIGNED THE
LINE NUMBER. WE WILL OPEN UP
ONE SIXTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS ASSISTING HOP ON BEHALF
OF CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
ELEVEN THANK YOU. MR HERE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
TO MOVE TO THE PROPOSITION I DO
NOT HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
OPPOSITION WITNESSES LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THE CHAMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO ELEVEN.
SEEING NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WHICH OF THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION FOR SB TWO ELEVEN.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR
SURELY WRESTLING QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU I AM GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. MANY MEMBERS I WILL
NOTE THAT. I KNOW THE BAR IS
NOT HAPPY WITH THE MANDATE IN
HERE OR THE REMOVAL OF THE FEES
BASED ON THE. SELECTION AND
THEN THE APPROPRIATE
CONFIRMATION OF CHIEF TRUCK
COUNCIL BUT I THINK THE- WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING OUR
SENATE COLLEAGUES AS THEY MOVE
FORWARD AYE I WILL NOTE THAT OF
COURSE CONFIRMATION IS IN THE
HANDS SOLELY OF THE SENATE. SO
AS LONG AS THERE'S A PROCESS
AND THAT THE- CHAIR OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
COMFORTABLE TO PROCESS THAT. I
DO HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT IF WE
MOVE THE BILL TODAY. THAT THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WILL STILL GO ON
AND I'M HOPING THAT. WE WILL
THEN SEE THIS BILL- AMENDED BY
TIME IT COMES TO THE FLOOR TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES SO
I. I DO TAKE SERIOUSLY THE
SENATE'S CONCERNS FOR A LACK OF
CHIEF PROCK COUNCIL WE HAVE
SEEN THIS COMMITTEE. HAS BEEN
HIGHLY CRITICAL OF THE BAR OVER
THE YEARS. AND THEIR INABILITY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND
THAT'S THE ROLE OF CHIEF TRIAL
COUNSEL I'VE TALKED TO A NUMBER
OF. THE EMPLOYEES AT THE BAR
WHO ARE. EARLY RECENT HIRES
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
WHO ARE DOING THE PROSECUTION'S
AND THEY ARE DEAD SERIOUS ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND I TOLD
THEM AS I TOLD THE BAR TRUSTEES
I THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE THAT
ATTORNEYS ARE A LITTLE NERVOUS
WHEN THEY GET A CALL FROM THE
BAR AND THAT. WE UP THE
STANDARD. OF THAT LEVEL OF
PROTECTION AND THAT. THAT
CONCERN THAT ATTORNEYS SHOULD
HAVE FOR BEING HAVING THEIR
CONDUCT RVIEWED BY THE STATE
BAR THAT'S THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
WE I THINK COLLECTIVELY ALONG
WITH SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ARE TRYING TO. TO DO SO THAT IS
WHY I'M RECOMMENDING THAT WE
PASSED THE BILL HERE TODAY WE
ARE STILL PART OF THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE SENATE
WITH THE BAR AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE ARE
ALL. ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
RESPECT TO THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT'S BEEN VERY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR COMMITTEE AND
FOR OR FOR MANAGING THE
EXPECTATIONS AND THE BAR AND-
SENATOR THERE WERE SOME THERE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS WHO ARE TAKING THOSE
MOMENTS AS OFFICE ABOUT IT YES
I AM YES THANK YOU JUST TO
CLEAR THAT UP. ALL RIGHT
BUSINESS HOURS THANK YOU I'M
COMPLETELY FINE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE DOING WE'VE SEEN OVER
THE YEARS UNFORTUNATELY. THAT
THE BAR SEEMS TO ONLY. RESPOND
TO US WHEN A- BAR DUES BILL IS
UP AND UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S THE
ONLY LEVERAGE WE HAVE IT SEEMS
LIKE I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
TIMES WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
NOW- I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY I
HAVE A GENERAL RULE OF NOT.
VOTING FOR THINGS WITH BLANKS
IN THEM- AMOUNTS WE DON'T
USUALLY LET ANYTHING OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WAY IT
REALLY MAKES ME NERVOUS I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
INTENTION IS TO NOT- CHANGE THE
LEVEL THE SO IT WILL READ THREE
NINETY FIVE AND NINETY
WHATEVER. THE AMOUNT IS FOR AN
ACTIVE NINETY SEVEN FORTY THAT
WOULD BE THAT IS THE NUMBERS
THAT ARE INTENDED TO BE. PLACED
BACK IN ONCE AN AGREEMENT IS
MADE. THAT IS CORRECT OKAY. ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE. NO THANK YOU-
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE I THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN STONE- ARE YOU AND
I SHARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PROFESSION WE SHARE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BAR WE SHARE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BACKLOG WITH RESPECT
DISPLAY CASES I THINK THE
REASON AUDIT SHOWS THE LAST
FIVE YEARS IT'S INCREASED BY
EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT. BOB I
HAVE BEEN IN CLOSE CONTACT AS
YOU HAVE BEEN MISTER CHAIR WITH
THE BAR HOWEVER I WAS STUNNED
TO HEAR CHAIR SEELIG SAY THAT
THEY'RE NT GOING TO HAVE A%
NOMINEE THEY'VE ONLY HAD FIVE
YEARS TO PRODUCE A NOMINEE TO
HAVE THAT PERSON CONFIRMED BY
THE SENATE- AND SO I'M I'M
REALLY SORRY TO HEAR THAT
REALLY SORRY TO HEAR THAT- I AM
HOPEFUL I STILL REMAIN HOPEFUL
THAT THE- NUMBER WILL BE PLACED
BACK. INTO THE BILL OF I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYEES THE STATE BAR WHO ARE
PASSIONATE DEDICATED AND HARD
WORKING AND DEDICATED FOR
EXAMPLE TO MAKING SURE THAT
CONSUMERS ARE PROTECTED AND WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO. IMPACT
THEM BUT WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BAR IS A
FUNCTIONING AS WE WOULD EXPECT
TO URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED. CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAO CHOW I CHIU.
DAVIES DAVIES I'D GONZALEZ.
CONSULT I HOLDEN KALRA KALRA
AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES
REYES AYE SIX SENATOR THE BILLS
OUT. THEY NOW SHARE OUR ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB. TWO FORTY ONE-
THANK YOU AGAIN- CHAIR AND ONE
OF TO GO THANK COMMITTEE
STAFFER. NICHOLAS LIKE KEEP FOR
YOUR HARD WORK AND HIS HARD
WORKING YOUR STAFF'S HARD WORK
ON THIS BILL- THE PANDEMIC HAS
TAUGHT US A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
LESSONS ONE LESSONS THE
PANDEMIC IS TAUGHT US IS THAT
WE NEED TO BE AND WE CAN BE
MORE EFFICIENT IN THE
OPERATION. OF OUR COURTS IN THE
SYSTEM AT THIS BILL DOES
SEVERAL THINGS UP FIRST IT.
ALLOWS COURT REPORTERS BOARD TO
OVERSEE AND REGULATE SHORTHAND
REPORTING SERVICES RENDERED BY
OUT OF STATE COURT REPORTING
FIRMS OF IT IS AKIN TO HAVING
LOCAL COUNCIL HERE WHEN YOU
HAVE OUT OF STATE COUNSEL
APPEARING IN- IN OUR COURTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IT PERMITS
A WITNESS N THIS OVERSEEING TO
APPEAR GIVE TESTIMONY BY
ELECTRONIC MEANS UP IF BOTH
PARTIES STIPULATE OR UPON
MOTION AND THERE'S CERTAIN
CRITERIA THAT MET THE JUDGE
FIND CERTAIN CRITERIA THEN SHE
CAN PERMIT THAT WITNESS TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY PROVIDES A
GREAT DEAL OF EFFICIENCY NOT
JUST BECAUSE THE COURT
OPERATION BUT ALSO A COST
SAVINGS. FOR EXAMPLE A
CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS NEED NOT
APPEAR IN PERSON IT'S REALLY
MINISTERIAL WITNESS BUT
SOMETIMES THOSE WITNESSES TAKE
SOMETIME AND OFTENTIMES THEY'RE
WAITING AROUND FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD. THREE COURTS TO
ELECTRONICALLY SERVE COURT
ISSUED DOCUMENTS- ON PARTIES
HAVE CONSENTED THAT SERVICE I
KNOW IT SOUNDS AMAZING BUT SOME
COURTS TODAY IN CALIFORNIA DO
NOT. SERVE NOTICES
ELECTRONICALLY- AND- IT ALSO
REQUIRES COURTS TO SCHEDULE A
HEARING ON A PETITION FOR
COMPROMISE OF MINERS CLAIM
WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF THE DATE
OF FILING. AND INSURES THAT
ARBITRATION DEADLINES ARE
TIMELY AND PREDICTABLE. I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES WHO WERE ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY- MISTER GREG
RESULT OF WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER CONSUMER ATTORNEYS. AS
WELL AS SYLVIA ARE GADDA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LEGAL AID
FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES-
DRIVE OUT. THANK YOU SENATOR I
DO HAVE THOSE TWO WITNESSES
GREGORY CEO AND SYLVIA ARE
GOING TO. THE THREE ZERO. YES
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CRIED WITH
DEAL ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
TESTIFYING AS A CO SPONSOR OF
SB TWO FORTY ONE TODAY WILL BE
SPEAKING ON THE REMOTE LIVE
WITH THIS PORTION OF THE BILL.
SB TWO FORTY ONE IS SUPPORTED
BY BOTH PLAINTIFF AND DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS AS IT HELPS IN BOTH
QUARTERS SUFFICIENCY WHILE
PROMOTING PUBLIC SAFETY. LIKE
SO MANY OTHER PROFESSIONS THIS
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED SERIOUS
ISSUES IN OUR COURTS AND CASES
FACE HERE'S WHAT THE BACKLOG
DUE TO THE CLOSURES. SO NOW'S
THE PERFECT TIME TO INTRODUCE
MEASURES LIKE SB TWO FORTY ONE
TO HELP MAKE TRIALS MORE
EFFICIENT WHICH WILL HELP
REDUCE THE BACKLOG. IN TRIAL
MANY TIMES ATTORNEYS LIKE
MYSELF HAVE TO CALL WITNESSES
TO PROVIDE BASIC FOUNDATIONAL
TESTIMONY. FOR EXAMPLE WHEN I'M
IN TRIAL IN AN AUTOMOBILE
ACCIDENT. THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
I HAVE TO CALL. A E. AND G.
BECAUSE MY MEDICAL EXPERTS HAVE
TO RELY UPON. THEIR FINDINGS OF
MY CLIENTS LEVEL OF
CONSCIOUSNESS IN OTHER WORDS
THE GLASS CAL SCHOOL ARE. AT
THE SCENE. EVEN IF NO ONE
DISPUTES WHAT THE GLASS CAL
SCORE WAS. UNFORTUNATELY MANY
TIMES I'VE SEEN THOSE EMTS
FORCED INTO COMING TO COURT TO
TESTIFY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
WORK SHIFT TO PROVIDE AN
UNDISPUTED CLASSICAL SCORE. DNT
LIE PRESENCE MEANS THAT THEY
MIGHT BE SITTING IN THE
COURTHOUSE HALLWAY FOR THREE TO
FIVE HOURS OF THEIR SHIP WHILE
WAITING TO PROVIDE THAT
TESTIMONY. HAVING A P. AND G.
IN COURT TO PROVIDE AN
UNDISPUTED CLASSIC CAL SCORE.
IS BELOW THE WAIST OF HIS IN
HER TIME. AND A PUBLIC SAFETY
HAZARD AS HE OR SHE SHOULD BE
OUT. OUR COMMUNITIES SAVING
LIVES. THIS DILEMMA ALL OCCURS
POLICE OFFICERS TREATING. THIS
BILL THANKS TO THAT DILEMMA AND
ALLOW THE CRITICAL PUBLIC
SAFETY PROFESSIONS TO SIMPLY
TAKE THREE TO FIVE MINUTES IN
THEIR OFFICES REMOTELY. INSTEAD
OF OUR STRIVING TO IN SITTING
IN COURTROOMS. NO I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONCERN THE
JURORS MIGHT HAVE A HARD TIME
HEARING WITNESSES MAKING IT
DIFFICULT TO PRESERVE THE
RECORD FOR APPEAL. AS WELL ON
TRIAL OUR PARTY YEARS THAT DO
NOT SHARE THIS CONCERN. ALL
TRIAL LAWYERS KNOW THAT IT IS
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT
THE CLIENT THE BALLOT RIGHT AND
THE JUDGES ALSO HAVE THE SAME
OBLIGTION. SO THIS A BILL
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES THOSE
CONCERNS. BY PROVIDING THE
TRIAL JUDGE THE POWER TO SAY NO
IF THEY BELIEVE THAT THAT'S AN
ISSUE IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
COURTHOUSE. IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
A MEMBER THAT WE JUST AS THE
ATTORNEYS HAVE BEEN MAKING
TELEPHONICALLY APPEARANCES TO
THE CORE CALL SYSTEM FOR MANY
YEARS WITH NO SUCH PROBLEMS. IN
CLOSING SB TWO FORTY ONE HELPS
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFER. AND
ALSO MAKES THE TRIAL PROCESS
MORE EFFICIENT WHICH WILL HELP
US CATCH UP ON THE SIGNIFICANT
BACKLOG. THESE CASES NEED TO
GET TO TRIAL THIS IS A GREAT
WAY TO GET THEM THERE AS SUCH
WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU AND I WILL REMAIN ON THE
LINE IN CASE THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS. AND WE'LL MOVE TO
SYLVIA R. GRETA. HELLO GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SO THE IDEA
THAT I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE LEGAL AID
FOUNDATION OF LOS ANGELES
BLACKLICK CREEK A SUPPORT
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY ONE I DID
NOT- SEVERAL COURT EFFICIENCIES
THAT WOULD MAKE- URGENTLY
NEEDED REFORMS- IMPROVEMENT TO
THE CURRENT COURT SYSTEM REDUCE
COSTS TO THE COURTS AND
LITIGANTS LET THEM TRIALLING
AND QUICKEN TRIAL CASE. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY INTEGRATE.
COMMONLY USED TECHNOLOGY. WANT
TO A QUIET MUST INCLUDE GUIDED
AND SAVE. IN SHARE THAT MORE
VULNERABLE KEY ARE LEFT.
PROBABLY NOT BE MADE WITH LOW
INCOME LITIGANTS FRONT AND
CENTER. THE NORM SHOULD BE THAT
CHANGES ARE MADE WHEN THEY
BENEFIT EVERYONE ESPECIALLY LOW
INCOME AMERICANS. PORTENO
PRACTICES DURING THE PANDEMIC
THE FACT THAT FACILITATED AFTER
SUGGESTED SHOULD CONTINUE IT
WOULD BE WONDERFUL FOR ACTIVE
LOW INCOME LAWYERS- TO SEE THAT
THESE PRACTICES RPGS. SOME OF
THE REFORMS ARE NEEDED
IMMEDIATELY IN ORDER FOR THE
COURTS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MINIMIZE. NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
LOW INCOME CLIENTS ESPECIALLY
COURT CHALLENGES WITH
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES BUT WHO HAVE
MARK STONE AFTER COURT HEARING
AND THE TO SIGN DOCUMENTS. THIS
IS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
HELPED OUR CLIENTS ENSURE THAT
THEY- AFFECT THE COURTHOUSE
DOORS ARE NOT SHUT SIMPLY
BECAUSE- THEY ARE POOR. WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT TECHNOLOGICAL
FLEXIBILITY IF SOMETHING THAT
ALL COURTS. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU TO
MAKE A TO LOAN LITIGANTS AND
THE LAWYERS. FOR THE YOUTH OF
SB CHIU FORTY ONE BELIEVE IT IS
NOT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI
ARE THERE ARE OTHERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FORTY ONE ANYONE HERE IN
THE CHAMBER. SEEING NONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB
TWO FORTY ONE. TO INDICATE
SUPPORT PRESS BE TWO FORTY ONE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE AT THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE LINE'S QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM THEIR LINE NUMBERS. BACK
WE HAVE SEVERAL QUEUING UP AT
THIRTEEN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE. SIXTY
THREE. HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
LESLIE AND I AM A PROUD
FREELANCE IN THE GRAPHIC
REPORTER AND I SUPPORT SB TWO
FORTY ONE ALSO I LIVE IN ORANGE
COUNTY CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
LINE SEVENTY NINE. HI MY NAME
IS SAM I SEVEN I LIVE IN
PITTSBURGH CALIFORNIA AND I'M A
PROUD FREELANCE REPORTER NUMBER
ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN FIVE AND I
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY ONE. LINE.
FIFTY TWO. NINE FIFTY TWO
YOU'RE NOT OPEN UP HELLO HELLO
THIS GRANT AGREEMENT I'M A
PROUD COURT REPORTER IN NEVADA
CALIFORNIA AND I DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THANK
EVERYONE THAT WORKED SO HARD ON
IT. LINE. THIRTY ONE. MY NAME
IS IDEOLOGICALLY IN ANAHEIM
CALIFORNIA AND I AM A CONE OR
CO OWNER OF THE AGENCY WITH A
LICENSED AND CERTIFIED
SHORTHAND REPORTER AND I AM
STRONG SUPPORT SB. TWO FORTY
ONE. PINE. SEVENTEEN NINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE LINE
SEVENTEEN WILL TRY ONE MORE
TIME. WE SEEM TO HAVE LOST YOUR
LINE IF YOU WOULD RE QUEUE BY
PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO WE'LL GO
NEXT LINE SIXTY ONE. MISTER
CURRENT MEMBERS MIKE BELOW
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL CO
SPONSOR THE BILL AND
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA CIVIL
DEFENSE LAWYERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY
FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS MARY
PIERCE AND I'M FROM HUNTINGTON
BEACH CALIFORNIA. NINE FIVE.
FOR A MOTOR FOR TWENTY YEARS
AND I PROBABLY SUPPORT SB TWO
FORTY ONE I THANK SENATOR. LINE.
EIGHTY FOUR. I. HOLD ON HOLD ON
YOU'VE GOT NOT JUST- OKAY THERE
WAS SOME NOISE A LOSER I THINK
YOU ARE DIFFICULT HERE OKAY. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THE ASBURY
CERTIFIED SHORTHAND REPORTER
ONE THREE THREE ZERO EIGHT AND
I PROUDLY SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY
ONE AND I THINK SENATOR- BURKE
I LOVE SHE HOW CALIFORNIA. IF I
MAY TAKE THIS MOMENT TO REMIND
THE WITNESSES THAT YOUR LINES
ARE ACTIVE THROUGHOUT THE
CONFERENCE CALL PLEASE KEEP
YOUR ACKGROUND NOISE TO A
MINIMUM AND USE YOUR MUTE
FEATURE WHEN YOU WERE NOT
SPEAKING. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MOLLY COOPER I LIVE IN
FULLERTON CALIFORNIA. I'M A
PROUD FREELANCE COURT REPORTER
YES OUR NUMBER ONE FOUR THREE
ONE THREE. AND I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY ONE. LINE
SIX LINE. SIXTY SIX. I BELIEVE
THAT FOR ME THIS IS MERRY
BARTOLINI PLASTER COUNTY AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF TWO
FORTY ONE AND SEEN THE POSITIVE
EFFECTS OF REMOTE TESTIMONY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
LINE. EIGHTY ONE. HI MY NAME'S
LORI STOKES. CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED INSIGHT CERTIFIED
SHORTHAND REPORTER ONE TWO
SEVEN THREE TWO AND I AM IN
SUPPORT SB TWENTY ONE AND I
WANT TO. ASK THANK YOU. PINE.
SEVENTEEN HELLO MY NAME IS
HOLLY MILLER I WASN'T LOOKING
TO CALIFORNIA I AM A CERTIFIED
FREELANCE COURT REPORTER NUMBER
SIX FOUR THREE EIGHT PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB TWO FORTY ONE THANK
YOU. MY. NINETY TWO. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JODY GREEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB. TWO FORTY ONE.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION MICHELLE I
ONE WITNESS LISTED MICHELLE
CALDWELL OF SEIU MICHELLE
CALDWELL ARE YOU WITH US. WHAT
IT WOULD BE PHANTASM BE HALF OF
THAT YEAH YOU APOLOGIES FOR
BEING WITHOUT YOUR CARE- GOOD
MORNING WOULD BE FANTASTIC TO
HAVE ABOUT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA- THE PLAN- LAST
COMMUNICATION TO- COMMITTEE.
REGARDING OUR CONTINUED
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE A VERY POSITIVE
CONVERSATION. WITH THE AUTHOR
AND ON THURSDAY REGARDING THREE
AMENDMENT. THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO PAY WHAT WOULD GET
US TO A NEUTRAL POSITION. THOSE
A BAD MAN BERMAN NOT YET TAKEN
BUT- IT IS OUR UNDERSTANDING
WILL BE TAKE AND SHORTLY. BOTH
MEN MEN WHAT. REQUIRE THAT. A
LIFE SENTENCE. CORPORATE IN THE
STATE OF. EMPLOY BY COURT- IS.
PRESENT IN ALL JERRY- IN WHICH
A WITNESS APPEAR REMOTE. THAT
THERE A NEED LADEN FROM THE
BENCH ARTICULATING THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF A
WITNESS APPEARING REMOTELY TO
BE ABILITY TO MAINTAIN THE
SANCTITY OF THE ETHICAL
CORPORATE I'M RECORD AND THE
POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF SAME.
ONLINE THE LITIGANT'S ABILITY
TO EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT UNDER
APPEAL AND FINALLY REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS DATA COLLECTED AND
TRANSMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
REGARDING BE A FAT. OF REMOTE-
APPEARANCES ON GOING- THERE IS
ONE OUTSTANDING ISSUE THAT THE.
AUTHOR AND- SPONSORED HAVE A
GOOD YOU CAN TO HAVE COME TO.
WITH THE ARE YOU REGARDING THE
MATTER TO DO WITH THE A FACT ON
INDIGENOUS LITIGANTS WE ARE WE
CONTINUE TO BE CAN. ABOUT THIS
POPULATION MOST CURRENTLY- THE
GREATEST POTENTIAL FOR
DIFFERENT. PARTICULARLY DOES
BETTER ON REPRESENTED AS IS
MOST OFTEN THE CASE AND
UNLAWFUL DETAINER PROCEEDINGS
WHERE 90% OF- AND LANDLORDS ARE
REPRESENTED AND ONLY 3% OF
TENANTS ARE REPRESENTED WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THERE MIGHT BE
AN INTRAPARTUM CONSEQUENCE OF
LIMITING THE REQUIREMENTS. BUT
FIRST AND ONLY. IN THREE PER
AND IN. BELIEVE THAT REALLY
NEEDS APPLY BENCH OF THE WELL
PARTICULARLY THE POOR OUR
COMPLY. AS THEY NEED TO WITH
THE CHAMBERS AND BE TESTED
DECISION MANDATING THAT
INDIGENT LITIGANTS HOBBS A
COURT REPORTER SO THAT THEY CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO A TRANSCRIPT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND ON
THURSDAY. BOB ON THE AGREED
UPON AMENDMENTS AND THE
OUTSTANDING AMENDMENTS. AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I WILL
NOW MOVE TO OTHERS WHO LIKE TO
INDICATE. TO SB TWO FORTY ONE
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBER. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION SB TWO
FORTY ONE AND AGAIN WE'RE
TAKING NAMES AFFILIATION AND
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE FIFTY
SIX. BAKER BURKE. LIKE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE OPEN. MY
APOLOGIES MY POSITION IS IN
SUPPORTER I THINK THE OPERATOR
HAD A BIT OF AN ISSUE THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
NEXT TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT. LINE
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO BONTA LINE SIXTY EIGHT GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HI GOOD MORNING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIDE I. SHE YOU
GUYS TAKING THE TIME TO HEROES-
I WAS SUPPOSED TO BE THE SECOND
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION I WAS
WONDERING IF I CAN HAVE MY TWO
MINUTES AND THEN WHAT IS YOUR
NAME PLEASE. MY NAME IS JENNY.
I AM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF INTERPRETERS
WHERE THE REPRESENT
INTERPRETERS AT WORK IN THE
STATE COURTS. OKAY I WILL GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT TIME YOU DID
NOT REGISTER WITH US THAT I
HAVE WHICH IS. VERY HELPFUL FOR
US BUT- I WILL GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT LATITUDE SO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT- WELL GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY-
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS I SAY MENTION IS
THE ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS ALL THE INTERPRETERS
AND THE STATE CURTS. AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
FORTY ONE AND ITS CURRENT FORM.
AMELL AS INTERPRETERS WE ARE
THE FRONT LINE WORKERS. REALLY
KIND OF IN OR OUT WITH ALL THE
COURT USED ALMOST EVERY TIME
ALL DAY LONG WE ARE. BASICALLY
THE LINK EVEN FOR MONOLINGUALS
TO ACTUALLY. AND THE BRIDGE FOR
MONOLINGUALS TO ACTUALLY ACCESS
THE COURT EITHER BY ASKING
INFORMATION GUIDING THEM OR
PROVIDING ANY OTHER TYPE OF-
NEEDED INFORMATION AND WAY
FINDING. BUT GIVEN THE FACT
THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS OPENED THE DOORS
TO REMOTE THERE IS STILL A LOT
OF PROBLEMS AND I THINK OPENING-
OF BILLS THAT WOULD. AND
TESTIMONY IS PUTTING THE FOR OF
THAT THE CARD THE I HONEST
THINK THAT WHAT THE INFORMATION
THAT ARE INTERPRETER HAVE- ME
MYSELF FOURTEEN IN MADERA
SUPERIOR COURT IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO INTERPRET AND TO
PROVIDE SERVICES REMOTELY- NOT
ONLY IS TECHNOLOGY UNRELIABLE
BUT THE WAY IT HAS TO MONNING
IS GIVEN SOMETIMES IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO CONTROL. IT IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO DETAIN AND
STOP SOMEBODY- OFTEN TIMES-
WHAT ARE. THAT AGAIN HASTINGS
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO WE
OUGHT TO SEE IF. HELPING WITH
TESTIMONY WE ALSO SEE FAMILY
PROVIDING DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
SHOULD NOT BE LOOKED AT- AND
IT'S JUST KEEP VERY CHAOTIC- A
LOT OF THE TIMES THERE IS A
HUGE DIGITAL DIVIDE WERE WE SEE
OURSELVES REPRESENTATIVE OR
PEOPLE WHO ARE REPRESENTATIVE
BY SOME TYPE OF LEGAL AID OR
ANYTHING UP YOUR IN SUPPORT OF.
OUR OUR FIRM JOHN AND WE ARE
MEETING WE ARE. I'M SORRY HELLO
I I'M SORRY YEAH OPERATOR.
SOMEBODY'S NOT ON MUTE IT IS
VERY IT GETS DESERVE ARE TRYING
TO. WE ARE TRYING TO ISOLATE
THAT LINE. THANK YOU VERY. YOU
PUT OF. AND IF YOU HAD THANK
YOU SO ON I'M OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE- HERE IN PERSON WITH
THE SHE DIGITAL USUALLY P. THAT
ARE INDIGENT. THEY APPEAR HERE
IN PERSON WILDER DARK REMOTELY
OFF IN THE COMMENTS THAT WE GET
IS I CAN'T EVEN TALK TO MY
ATTORNEY I CAN'T TELL THEM
ANYTHING THAT ISN'T TRUE
ESPECIALLY DURING TESTIMONY
THERE IS NO WAY FOR THEM OR
MECHANISM FOR THEM TO BE
HELPING AND AIDING THEIR
ATTORNEY AND A LOT OF THE
TESTIMONY THAT IS BEING GIVEN
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE TURNING
CIRCLE APPEARING REMOTELY. I
EVEN HAD THE EXPERIENCE OF
ACTUALLY WATCHING A LITIGANT SO
FRUSTRATED WITH HIS ATTORNEY
FIRE IS ATTORNEY IN OPEN COURT
INTERESTS WAS YELLING AND
SAYING HOW FRUSTRATED HE WAS
THAT THE IN THE TURNING WAS NOT
THERE A- MA'AM I THINK IT'S
AROUND. LIKE THIS. I NEED
TWENTY THREE- I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT. I THINK THIS KIND OF
BILL MORE SUITED OMETHING IS
LOW. PATTERSON THE HIGH STATE
HIGH OF DEAL WITH FLY CAN
CHANGED DEPENDING ON THE- GIVEN
IF THERE'S NO COULD. THAN
PEOPLE WHO LIVE SHE- LIFE ARE
HAVE I NEED TO. PLACE CAN BE. I
AM WRAPPING ABSURD I UP AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS GIVE ME
THAT. BUT THIS TYPE OF- BILL IS.
BETTER SUITED FOR SOMETHING
THAT IS LOW STEAKS AND EVEN
SOME OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. COULD NOT REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO DISCUSS THIS
FURTHER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT OPERATOR WOULD YOU DO
YOU HAVE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION AND
WE WILL NOT BE TAKING FURTHER
TESTIMONY. WILL TAKE NAME
AFFILIATE GROUPS AND OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE THREE MORE LINES IN Q.
WILL GO NEXT TO LINE NINETY
SIX. HI MY NAME IS HELEN ST ONE
AT THE S. R. ONE THREE FOUR
SEVEN SIX. PROUD SUPPORTER
PROTECTOR RECORD PROJECT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOUNG.
LINE. SEVENTY TWO. I MANY SANDY
WALTON NOTHING POPS PRESIDENT'S
WITH STEVE KERR A CALIFORNIA
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EVEN WITH THE
CURRENT AMENDMENTS THE BILL
NEEDS. TO BE NARROWED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. BY. ONE OH ONE. HI
THERE MY NAME IS DEAR FROM ARE
THURGOOD CARE PROJECT AND
THERE'S NO MONEY ALLOCATED IN
THE STATE BUDGET HEY AM SORRY
FONG CAN UNDERTAKE FURTHER
DENNIS HURLEY THANK YOU. TYING
UP. THERE ARE LOWER THE LINES
INTO SIR I THINK YOU YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES THEN OPERATED
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE RETIREMENT SB TWO
FORTY ONE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MISTER KALRA
MR TO THINK- THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD AND FOR IT'S A LOT
OF WORK IN CONVERSATIONS BEEN
OCCURRING- WITH THE WITH
OPPOSITION I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF. PROGRESS NOT REGARD
AND I DID THAT THE TWO AREAS OF
CONTINUED TO CONCERNED LINE AND
I NOTICED THAT YOU CONVERSATION
THAT YOU'RE HAVING- ARE ARE
THE- ACCESS ISSUES-
PARTICULARLY AS IT APPLIES TO
INDIGENT LITIGANTS BUT ALSO-
YOU KNOW WITH HAVING SPENT ON A
LOT OF TIME IN COURT ROOMS- I
DO WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE COURT
REPORTING SYSTEM AND WHAT THEY
BRING TO THE TABLE AS RECOGNIZE
BUT- ON ON ON THAT NOTE. I'VE
HAD A JUST SOLUTION THE PAST OF
THAT- HAS GREATER BECAUSE
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY FOR OUT
OF STATE COURT REPORTERS AND SO
MY WORRY WOULD BE THAT WE WOULD
BE HELPING TO FACILITATE A
FLOOD OF OUT OF STATE REPORTERS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE OUR
BOARD DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER HOWEVER THAT
WAS PART OF BUT MY PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION BOB HAD TO AIM TO
DEAL WITH. AND SO AS THIS- A IN
A BUBBLE LEGISLATION MOVES
FORWARD- YOU KNOW THAT WOULD BE
AN AREA OF GREAT CONCERN OF
MINE IS TO MAKE SURE WE'RE NOT
OPENING THE FLOODGATES- BECAUSE
AGAIN IF IT'S ABOUT IT'S ABOUT
EFFICIENCY WHAT HAVE YOU THAT'S
ONE THING BUT IT BUT WE HAVE TO
MAINTAIN THAT INTEGRITY AND THE
REALITY IS THAT I YOU KNOW HOW
TO GET MY STUDY AND DO NOT BILL
OTHER STATES MANY OTHER STATES
DON'T HAVE THE SAME DEGREE OF
OVERSIGHT THAT WE DO AND I
THINK THAT'S- THAT WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN- MAIN TO
MAINTAIN THE ABILITY TO HAD A
VERY DIRECT OVERSIGHT. OVER
THOSE THAT ARE PROVIDING THESE
SERVICES EVEN IF AND ESPECIALLY
IF IT'S REMOTELY AND SO- THOSE.
ARE SOME OF THE ISSUES- I
WANTED TO RAISE AS AN- AS YET.
AND YOU'RE OUT YOU YOUR OFFICE
AND THEN CONTINUE-
CONVERSATIONS ON THE OTHERS A
TRAILER BILL AS WELL OF
DIFFERENT. MOVING PARTS JOURNAL-
OF OUR OUR CHAIR OF THE STATE
AND HIS TEAM ALL INVOLVED IN
WORKING. A LONG. A TO DEAL WITH
LEASES BUDGET WANTED TO REYES
ISSUE OF. STATE OF A CORE OF
THAT- ALL WORRY WHEN WE KIND OF
CREATE THAT. THANK YOU. MISTER
SHALL REST. YOU MAY NOT. THANK
YOU SO IN THE KALRA- COUPLE
THOUGHTS OF FIRST I HEARD
TESTIMONY SANCHEZ SYRTIS IS
ACCURATE AND TO OF THE STATE OF
COMMERCE STATED SCOTT- SO IN
TERMS OUT OF STATE COURT
REPORTERS IN RIGHT NOW AS WE
STAND OR SIT HERE TODAY THERE'S
PROBABLY A HUNDRED DEPOSITIONS
GOING ON OUT OF STATE CURRENTLY
BEING- TRANSCRIBED OR AT LEAST-
REPORTED BY OUT OF STATE COURT
REPORTERS. UP WITH THIS BILL
DOES IS IT ADDS SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY BY REQUIRING
THOSE OUT OF STATE FIRMS TO
ACTUALLY HAVE LOCAL OF A LOCAL
FIRM UNDER THE SUPERVISION OF A
COURT REPORTER BOARD SO I THINK
IT'S AN IMPROVEMENT IN TERMS OF
YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY- UP WITH RESPECT
TO THE ACCURACY OF THE RECORD.
THERE'S NO ONE MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ACCURACY THE RECORD
THEN THE LAWYERS WHO REPRESENT
THE LITIGANTS NO ONE UP MAYBE
THE JUDGE SHE MAY BE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RECORD BUT
BUT ALL THE PARTIES. AND WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET AN
ACCURATE RECORD- I HEARD WAS
ALSO SAID WITH RESPECT TO-
INTERPRETERS IN REPRESENTATION
OF INDIGENTS THAT IS A
CONTINUING ISSUE OF THAT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
REPRESENTATION OF INDIGENTS. AS
A- JUST A FACT IT IS DIFFICULT
FOR INDIGENCE TO RECEIVE
ADEQUATE COUNSEL- AND THEN ONCE
THEY DO HAVE COUNCIL IN TERMS
OF THE WAY TO REPRESENT THEM
EFFECTIVELY. IS A CONTINUING
CONCERN AND THOSE CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT TO- INTERPRETERS IN
TRANSLATION EXIST EVEN WHEN.
LITIGANTS APPEAR PERSONALLY IN
THE COURTROOM. THIS WILL
REQUIRE THE JUDGE YOU'LL HAVE
TO BE UP A BIT MORE OBSERVANT
PERHAPS WITH REMOTE TESTIMONY
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
SHOULDN'T DO IT AND N. AS IS
ILLUSTRATED BY THE NUMBERS IF
YOU LOOK AT THE SUPPORTERS. OF
THE BILL THOSE WHO DO REPRESENT
INDIGENTS WHETHER IT'S THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
BEAR LEGAL AID CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER DEPENDENCY LEGAL
SERVICES THE JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH. IT'S SET
TRADE CENTER AT CETERA THEY ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT THIS IS A
STEP TO HELP THEM MORE
EFFICIENTLY REPRESENT INDIGENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
MISTER TO AND THEN AS OUR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TACKLING THIS A CHALLENGING
TOPIC OF HOW WE ADDRESS
BACKLOGS PARTICULAR DURING THIS
PANDEMIC BUT IT SURE- THAT ALL
THE VALUES THAT WE CARE ABOUT
IN OUR COURT SYSTEM ARE
SUPPORTED AND AS EXPRESSED WHEN
I VOTED FOR THIS BILL IN
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS- I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH
THIS YEAR YOU AND SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION TO IT TO GET TO A
BETTER SPOT. HE PARTIALLY
ANSWERED THE QUESTION HAS BEEN
RAISED BUT I'D LIKE TO JUST
PUSH A LITTLE FARTHER- I DO
PLAN TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY-
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE STILL
CONCERNS ABOUT. HOW WE ADDRESS
THE SITUATION AROUND INDIGENT
REPRESENTATION. I'M COULD YOU
GIVE US A SENSE OF SORT OF
WHERE'S THE DISCUSSION AT THIS
POINT ON WHAT AMENDMENTS COULD
BE TAKEN- CAN WHERE WHERE WHERE
THE DIFFERENT PARTIES AND WHAT
WE TRY TO BRIDGE AT THIS POINT
I'M- I'M NOT ASKING FOR-
FINALLY ANSWERS I'M JUST ASKING
FOR A SENSE OF WHAT ARE THE
ISSUES THAT. YOU'RE STILL
TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH SO WE
CAN- CONSIDERED CONTINUED A
CONSIDERATE AND THINK ABOUT IT.
I THINK THAT. THE CONCERNS THAT
ARE RAISED WITH RESPECT TO
INDIGENCE- THERE THERE IS SOME
DISAGREEMENT AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT THIS PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
SERVICES THE GROUPS WHO
REPRESENT INDIGENTS- ALMOST
UNIVERSALLY TAKE THE POSITION
THAT. THIS IS AN ADVANTAGE SO
LET ME GIVE YOU A FEW EXAMPLES.
IF YOU'RE AN INDIGENT AND YOU
SIMPLY WANT TO CONTINUE WEEK
TRIAL DATE THE NEW LIVE A
HUNDRED MILES FROM THE
COURTHOUSE. AND YOU SHOW UP AT
LEGAL AID YOU CAN APPEAR
REMOTELY WITH COUNSEL. RATHER
THAN TAKING A DAY OFF OF WORK
AND DRIVING OF THE COURTHOUSE
OF WAITING AROUND TO YOUR CASES
CALL- AND SO I BELIEVE IT
ACTUALLY. SAVES ONE IS SAYS
INDIGENTS MONEY BUT TO A
PROVIDES A MORE EFFICIENT
REPRESENTATION REQUIRING
SOMEONE TO APPEAR PERSONALLY IN
COURT. FOR MANY PURPOSES IS
SIMPLY NOT USEFUL. THE THAT YOU
CAN APPEAR. REMOTELY AND HANDLE.
SIR PRE TRIAL PROBABLY 80% OF
WHAT IS BEING- DISPUTED AT THE
TIME SO. I'M NOT SURE- I A
HEARD AGAIN WHAT MS SANCHEZ HAD
TO SAY AND I THINK WE RESOLVED
OR WILL RESOLVE. THOSE CONCERNS
IN TERMS OF INDIGENT
REPRESENTATION WE MAY JUST HAVE
A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. THE
FOLKS THAT REPRESENT INDIGENTS
LARGELY AGREE WITH US. OTHERS
DISAGREE. I APPRECIATE THAT AND
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY I THINK FOR
MANY OF US PARTICULARLY DURING
THIS TIME PERIOD- I THINK WE
ARE EXPECTING THESE ISSUES
ENVOLVE AND LOWER INCOME-
PARTIES TO REALLY SKYROCKET-
AND- I THINK RESOLVING THIS IS
IMPORTANT. MY HOPE IS I THINK
THE EXAMPLE YOU JUST GAVE IS A-
VERY CLEAR ONE OF ONE WHERE
SOMEONE WHO'S LOWER INCOME
COULD REALLY BENEFIT FROM THAT
I'M HOPING THAT WE'RE GONNA
MAYBE PRESCRIBE TO THAT BUT-
LOOK FOR TO THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION REALLY HOPE TO. TO
GET UPDATED AS THIS BILL
CONTINUES ON THAT FRONT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS
GONZALEZ. I AS I UNDERSTAND
THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS TODAY
AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A LOT
OF MOVING PARTS BUT I JUST
WANNA TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
EXPRESSED MY CONCERNS- I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO AND I'LL- I UNDERSTAND
THERE WOULD BE. THEIR GOOD
ARGUMENTS FOR THAT BUT I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED- AND NOT SO
MUCH YOU BUT HAVING SPOKEN TO A
LOT OF SITES. HOW DID THREE
GUARDED- THE PROFESSIONALS WHO
ARE DOING THE WORK OF
INTERPRETING COURT REPORTING
ARE IN THIS CONVERSATION. SO
VERY CLOSE WITH CONSUMER
JOURNEYS I FELT LIKE THEY WERE
VERY- THIS WORKS FOR EVERYBODY
THAT'S WHAT THEY KEPT SAYING
THIS IS GREAT IT WORKS FOR
EVERYBODY WELL IF IT DOESN'T
WORK FOR THE WORKERS DOING. THE
JOB IT DOESN'T WORK FOR
EVERYBODY. AND SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE'RE
MOVING FORWARD THE INTERPRETERS
IN PARTICULAR I'M NOT SURE HOW
THIS CAN WORK. WE JUST SAW I
MEAN WITH THE TESTIMONY WHAT
HAPPENS OBVIOUSLY IN REMOTE
SETTINGS- AND I'M GOING TO
ASSUME THAT THE COURTS. ARE IN
A BETTER POSITION TO MANAGE
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE. THEM I CATCH
MAYBE. FOUR FIFTHS OF THE WORDS
THAT ARE SAID- AND I'M VERY
CONSCIENTIOUS OF THAT BECAUSE
I'M DYSLEXIC AND WHEN I READ
THAT'S ABOUT WHAT I READ AT THE
SAME TIME ABOUT FOUR FIFTHS AND
I HAVE TO GO BACK AND GO BACK
IF YOU CAN'T GO BACK IT MAKES
IT REALLY HARD TO PROCESS-
EXACT INFORMATION AND SOME OF
THE STORIES I HEARD FROM COURT
REPORTERS- IT REALLY BASED ON
GETTING PIECES IN TRYING TO
INTERRUPT AND SAY I DIDN'T HEAR
ANYTHING AND BEING DISREGARDED
AGAIN WHICH I BELIEVE GIVEN.
HOW MUCH THEY'VE BEEN
DISREGARDED BY SOME IN THIS
CONVERSATION THAT THAT PROBABLY
DOES HAPPEN TO THEM YOU KNOW I
CAN'T HEAR AND PEOPLE KEEP
GOING SOUTH I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE- TAKING THEIR
CONCERNS SERIOUSLY AND-
ADDRESSING THEM IN WHATEVER
FORM AS IT MOVES FORWARD AND
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT-
CONVENIENCE DOESN'T SUPERSEDE
AT WHAT REALLY SHOULD BE- THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN WITH IT
WHICH IS AN ACCURATE RECORD-
INTERPRETING WHICH IS MAKING
SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THEIR LANGUAGE OF
CHOICE. IN THE COURTROOM SO-
BUT I DO GIVE YOU MUCH CREDIT
TO TAKE ON SOMETHING LIKE THIS
THAT WE ALSO KNOW WE HAVE A
BACKLOG AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO GET THROUGH IT SO- KUDOS TO
YOU FOR TAKING THE PHONE I LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU SPECIFICALLY. ON THOSE ON
TWO ISSUES. I THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. ISRAEL
THANK YOU I ALSO WANT TO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK WITH
SEIU I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE VERY WORKERS FOR DOING THE
FOR. WE DO KNOW THAT THIS
PANDEMIC IS SHOWN THAT WE DO
NEED TO LOOK AT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT. TO HAVING TO TAKE
THE SUN IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THE INTERPRETERS UNFORTUNATELY
WITH THEIR TESTIMONY WAS VERY
IMPORTANT I DIDN'T SEE A LETTER
OF OPPOSITION. SO I HAD NO
CONTEXT IN THAT REGARD TO WITH
THE COMMENTS WERE VERY
IMPORTANT- I THINK THAT WITH
OUR OUR COURT REPORTERS HAVING
THEM WITH THE HEARING OFFICER
THE JUDGE. I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
IT'S GOING TO BE TAKEN. BECAUSE
THAT IS- SOMETHING THAT WOULD
BE. THE CORNERSTONE OF WHAT WE
DO IS ATTORNEYS MAKING SURE
THAT THERE IS A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE HEARING OFFICER AND
THE CORE PART OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE AN ACCURATE
RECORD. OF BUT AGAIN I AT MOST
IMPORTANTLY I THINK HAVING YOU
WORK IN THE SPACE AND ENGAGING
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS AS YOU
HAVE- I THINK. IT LENDS FOR
BETTER LEGISLATION BUT I KNOW
THAT THERE WILL BE OTHER STEPS
ALONG THE WAY. AND I AM GLAD.
AGAIN FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING AT
THIS THE COURT ORDERS AND NOW
HEARING THE INTERPRETERS OF
BLOOD BUT THEY. DID CALL AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT
SIX. THE CHAIRMAN- YOU KNOW ONE
ONE ISSUE THAT CAME UP- I THINK
FROM THE COURT RECORDS IS A
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION IS-
THE REGISTRATION IS ONE THING I
THINK THAT DOES PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT AND SUPERVISION- BUT
THEY WERE SAYING THAT THE
CURRENT STATUTE AS IT'S DRAFTED
APPLIES MOSTLY TO SITUATIONS
WHERE WE'RE A LICENSED
CERTIFIED SHORTHAND REPORTER IS
THE OWNER- OF THE BUSINESS AND
SO- THE ASSOCIATION IS
CONCERNED THERE MAY BE GAPS IN
THAT STATUTE. THAT COULD BE
USED BY KIND OF THE OUT OF
STATE CORPORATIONS TO GET
AROUND. THE CURRENT STATUTORY
STRUCTURE. AND MAYBE AND MAYBE
THEY SAY THEY'RE APPLYING OR
THEY'LL SAY THAT THAT STATUTE
DOESN'T APPLY TO THEM. BECAUSE
THE SHORT THE CERTIFIED
SHORTHAND REPORTER IS NOT THE
OWNER. AS A COULD YOU MAY
RESPOND TO SOME OF THOSE
<c.green>ONCERNS CENTER. SO WE WILL</c>
CONTINUE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
THAT THE INTENT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. IF YOU'RE AN OUT OF STATE
REPORTER REPORTING IN A
CALIFORNIA CASE THAT THERE IS A
LOCAL REPORTING FIRM THAT HAS
RESPONSIBILITY SO FOR EXAMPLE
IF. YOU DO SOMETHING THAT IS
CONTRARY TO- EITHER. OUR LAWS
ARE STANDARDS THAT THAT THERE
IS A LOCAL- THROAT TO CHOKE AS
IT WERE- AND SO THAT THE COURT
HAS THE ABILITY TO FOR EXAMPLE-
MAKE SURE THAT THE THAT. THE
RECORD IS ACCURATE NUMBER ONE
WITH RESPECT TO DEPOSITIONS
INTO THAT IF THERE'S SOMETHING
UNTOWARD THAT HAPPENS THERE'S
AN ABILITY TO YOU KNOW RAIN IN
AT LEAST IF THERE IS A GAP WE
WILL LOOK TO SEE IF WE CAN
CLOSE THAT GAP BUT THAT'S THE
INTENT. AND YOUR INTENT WITH
THIS BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY WOULD BE HELD ALL THE
SAME. STATUTORY RULES AS WOOD-
YOU KNOW THE SMALL. BUSINESS
HEARING CALIFORNIA THAT'S OWNED
BY A SHORTHAND REPORTER WELL.
THAT THAT'S A LITTLE BROAD I'M
NOT SURE THAT AN OUT OF STATE
COURT REPORTING FIRM WOULD HAVE
TO YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE DEAL
WITH WORKERS COMPENSATION SOME
OTHER CALIFORNIA REQUIREMENTS
THAT ARE APPLIED TO SMALL
BUSINESSES NOW- IN TERMS OF THE
ACCURACY OF THE RECORD YES.
YEAH BUT IN TERMS OF THE
SPECIFICS OF- I HAVE CONDUCTED.
YOUR DPOSITIONS ENSURE INTERNS
OF GUILT SWEARING THE WITNESS
IN THE OATH THAT IS
ADMINISTERED IN THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS YES. AND THEN I THINK
YOU KNOW AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
BEEN BROUGHT UP A LOT ABOUT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY- I THINK FOR A
LIMITED PERIOD OF TIME- THAT
MAKES SENSE WELL IN IT AND I
AND I WRITE THAT UNDER THE-
UNDER YOUR BILL IT'S ONLY IF
ALL PARTIES HAVE AGREED. TO DO
REMOTE THAT IS RIGHT THAT'S THE
MOST COMMON CIRCUMSTANCE OF THE
PARTIES STIPULATE- A. B. OF THE
REPRESENTATIVE CAN MAKE A
MOTION IN THE COURT CAN- PERMIT
REMOTE TESTIMONY THERE'S A
SERIES OF FACTORS THAT THE
COURT MUST CONSIDER. SO THERE'S
A STIPULATION OR IF THE COURT
ORDERS IT. YEAH THAT'S CORRECT
UPON MOTION WILL PARTY RIGHT
AND I MAY BE A MOTION THE COURT
BUT I'M SURE IT'S MOTION PARTY.
I AM FOR THAT LIMITED PERIOD OF
TIME I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW
SUPPORTABLE AND WHERE YOU HAVE
WHERE IT IS EITHER COURT ORDER
BY STIPULATION- BUT I DO FEEL
THAT IN PERSON TESTIMONY IS THE
BEST YOU KNOW BOTH. FOR THE
RECORD BUT YOU KNOW- MORE GOING
TO COURT TO RESOLVE ISSUES. YOU
KNOW PEOPLE SHOULD BE IN PERSON
AND IN YOUR FOR PROVIDING
TESTIMONY AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
I THINK THAT SHOULD BETHE CASE
SO I MEAN I DON'T WANT TO GET
TOO FAR AWAY FROM THAT BUT I
THINK FOR THESE FOR THIS
LIMITED PERIOD OF TIME IN UNDER
THOSE. CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THAT
DOES SEEM TO. BE REASONABLE
MAKE SENSE HERE. TO THAT'S ALL
I HAVE MISTER TERM THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. THANK YOU CENA
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT AND THANKS
FOR THE COMMENTS- THANK YOU- MR
IS THE- THANK YOU MISTER GET OF
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY HERE TODAY-
AND I APPRECIATE THE MISS
SANCHEZ- WE'VE HAD.
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE- ADDRESS
THE SERIOUS INTEREST OF THE
COURT REPORTERS- WE- WITH
RESPECT TO INTERPRETERS- WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE AND WE WILL
THAT INTERPRETERS HAVE THE SAME
ABILITY TO NOTIFY THE COURTS OF
THE THAT THE COURT. CAN FOR
EXAMPLE IF INTERPRETATION IS
BECOMING- SO CHALLENGING THAT
THE RECORD IS NOT ACCURATE THAT
THEY COULD PAUSE THE PROCEED
THAT THE COURT CAN THEN PAUSED
THE PROCEEDINGS SO THAT WE DO
HAVE AN ACTIVE RECORD THERE ARE
SAFETY THOUSAND IN IN THE BILL.
IF FOR EXAMPLE A TECHNOLOGY
BREAKS DOWN- THEN. OF THE COURT
NEED PAUSE- I A CONFIDENT FOR
MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
THAT. COURTHOUSE TECHNOLOGY IS
SUPERIOR OUR TECHNOLOGY HERE-
COURTROOMS ARE SMALLER IN THE
ACOUSTICS ARE TYPICALLY BETTER
THAN IN THIS ROOM- APPEARED
MANY TIMES NEVER IS A CAT
FORTUNATELY. ARE BUT THIS THIS
IS MISTER IS YOU POINT OUT THIS
IS SOMETHING WITH RESPECT TO
COURT CALLS BEEN GOING ON FOR
MANY MANY MANY YEARS. AND I
THINK ULTIMATELY IT WILL CREATE
GREATER EFFICIENCIES AND I
THINK GREATER BENEFIT TO THE
LITIGANTS WHETHER THEIR
INTENTIONS OR OR OTHERWISE-
GINGIVAL. THANK YOU I AM
LOOKING FOR A MOTION. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. DOWN BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
CHAU CHAU AYE CHU CHU AYE
DAVIES. DAVIES I CONSOLIDATE.
CONSULTA HOLDEN KALRA. KALRA
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES RESIDE
TO PICK YOU THE BILL IS OUT
THERE WE WILL NOW MOVE TO I
REMEMBER FOR SB THREE FORTY
NINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK UP
PARTICULARLY YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER MARY SOLOMON FOR HER
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. SB
THREE FORTY NINE IS ENTITLED TO
CALIFORNIA ETHICAL TREATMENT
FOR PERSONS WITH ADDICTION-
THIS BILL PROVIDES A BILL
RIGHTS FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING- SERVICES- WE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE A NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS MOST OF THEM AGAIN
ETHICAL SOME ARE NOT UP WE AN
ORANGE COUNTY UNFORTUNATELY.
HAVE HAD A QUITE A NUMBER OF
THOSE PROVIDERS WHO ARE NOT
OPERATING ETHICAL FASHION IN
THIS SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOUR TREATMENT PLAN-
PROVIDES FOR EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT TO FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS ACTUALLY
GET THAT EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
IT ALSO. REQUIRES THAT YOU
ACCURATELY MARKET YOUR SERVICES
AND IF YOU DON'T THEN FINES CAN
RANGE UP TO TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION. I THINK
ALL OF US HERE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT PATIENTS WHO SUFFER
FROM AN ADDICTION DISEASE
RECEIVE ETHICAL TREATMENT AND
THIS IS A TOOL THAT ENABLES
THEM AT LEAST MOVES THE BALL IN
TERMS OF THEM RECEIVING ETHICAL
TREATMENT- I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
ARE ON THE PHONE MICHELLE WERE
BACK FROM THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE
FOR MODEL STATE DRUG LAWS BY
THE WAY THAT'S- THIS LAW IS
BASED ON MODEL STATE DRUG LAWS.
AND SHERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS I URGE RIVAL
THANK YOU. SENATOR THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS LISTED IN THE- I'M
SORRY THERE ARE AMENDMENTS YOU
KNOW YES WE ARE WEEK WEEK SEVEN
AMENDMENTS AND WE APPRECIATE
AGAIN. THE WORK OF YOUR STAFF
YOU AND YOUR STAFF OKAY. THANK
YOU YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND SO WE DO HAVE. TWO
WITNESSES MICHELLE. WERE BIG
AND- SHERRY DALY. FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE. WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES.
YES SORRY I WAS WAITING FOR MY
SHOT PARDON ME GOOD MORNING ON
A WHEEL CHAIR MEMBER SHERRY
GAILEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS
REPRESENTING ADDICTION
COUNSELORS TREATMENT PROGRAMS
RECOVERY RESIDENCES ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE RECOVERY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'M HERE
TODAY TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE FORTY NINE AND CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE DANGERS AND
DESPICABLE PRACTICE OF EGYPTIAN
PATIENT BROKERING THAT STILL
PLAGUES OUR STATE AND MUST BE
ADDRESSED ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
SPONSORED SEVERAL SUCCESSFUL
BILL. AREA SO CALLED DEEP
ADDICTION TREATMENT REGISTRIES
ARE ONLINE SCAM WEBSITES THAT
REDIRECT PHONE BOOK NINE FAMILY
MEMBERS TRANSCRIPT OF MARKERS
TO THEN SELL THEM TO THE
HIGHEST BIDDER ARE STILL
OPERATING WITH IMPUNITY
EVERYONE JUST REMAIN DIFFICULT
IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO ADDRESS
GIVEN OUR CURRENT STATUTE YOU
MAY ASK HOW DO I KNOW THAT
THESE ENTITIES ARE STILL CRYING
UPON PEOPLE WITH ADDICTION.
WELL I ACTUALLY GOOGLED A
LEGITIMATE PROGRAM I KNOW TO
PROVIDE EXCELLENT SERVICE IN
THE MODESTO CALIFORNIA AND THE
FIRST HAD ON MY GOOGLE SEARCH
SHOWED A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE OF
THIS FACILITY ITS STAFF AND ITS
SERVICES BUT WHEN I CLICKED ON
IT I WAS SENT TO A WEBPAGE NOT
BELONG USE THAT PROGRAM AND
FOUND MYSELF IMMEDIATELY
CONNECTED TO A PATIENT RECORD
WILL GAUGE NOT HARD
SUBROUTINES. THAT INCLUDED
THREATS THAT WOULD PROTECT
YOUNG ADULT I WAS CALLING ABOUT
WOULD BE DEAD BY SUNDAY IF I
DID THAT DID NOT MORTGAGE MY
HOUSE AND DELIVER HER TO A
TREATMENT PROGRAM IN MICHIGAN
BY FRIDAY YOU NEVER WANT TO ASK
ABOUT MY PRETEND DAUGHTER'S
CONDITION IF SHE WAS IN NEED OF
DETOXIFICATION WHAT HER
SYMPTOMS WERE OR SHE MIGHT BE
SUICIDAL. HE SIMPLY WANTS TO
KNOW WHAT MY INSURANCE WAS HER
AGE AND HER DRUG OF CHOICE
SADLY WHEN I DEMANDED TO BE
CONNECTED TO TREATMENT PROGRAM
I CALLED ABOUT HE DISCREDITED
IT AND OUR STATE IN GENERAL THE
HORRIBLE OPTION MY DAUGHTER AND
THEN REFUSED TO CONNECT YOU TO
THE PROGRAM THIS BILL WILL
EXPANDABILITY OF PRIVATE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
REMOVE ARE LEGITIMATE PROVIDERS
FROM THE SCAM AND SICK ANIMALS
WHEN THEY'RE FOUND TO OCCUR. AT
UP TO CREATE THE FIRST EVER
PATIENT BILL OF RIGHTS FOR
PEOPLE WITH ADDICTION FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE AT YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND THEN
THE SECOND IS MICHELLE WORLD.
ALLY OPERATOR DO WE HAVE A. THE
STRUGGLE I'M NOT SHOWING A
MICHELLE ON THE LINE HERE OKAY
AT THIS TIME ALRIGHT THEN LET'S
MOVE TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. C. NONE THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY SAY. SEEING
NONE WOULD YOU OPERATE WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT
OF SB. THREE FORTY NINE. TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL THEN
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION LISTED IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FORTY
NINE. SEEING NONE AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE FORTY NINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. SURE WE HAVE
KNOWN QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I WILL THEN YOU MAY
CLOSE LINES OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MS DAVIS THANK
YOU SENATOR I GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I MEAN IT'S
DEFINITELY LONG OVERDUE I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE A GOOD
ACTORS WHEN IT COMES TO
TREATMENT CENTERS FOR THE LAST
NINE YEARS AND AGAIN THOSE BAD
ACTORS ARE STILL OUT THERE AND
WE HAVE SO MANY FAMILIES THAT
LITERALLY ARE MORTGAGING UP
THEIR HOMES. AND PAYING
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS HOPING
THAT THEIR YOU KNOW THEIR
CHILDREN OR TEENS ARE GOING
INTO THE RIGHT PLACE SO- I I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THIS AND I
WOULD LOVE TO CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU CENTER FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I AGREE IS
LONG OVERDUE- AS YOU KNOW WELL
AS A PUBLIC DEFENDER YOU MAY
NOT KNOW HOW TO LIVE IN YEARS.
OF THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
I SPENT ABOUT OFTEN ON FIVE AND
A HALF YEARS OF THAT TIME IN
DRUG COURT- AND TO YOUR POINT
IN YOUR INTRO MOST OF THOSE-
THE PROVIDE TREATMENT DO SO
ETHICALLY WITH COMPASSION BUT
MANY OF THOSE PROVIDING THE
TREATMENT- ARE RECOVERY
THEMSELVES AND ARE PAYING IT
FORWARD. AND IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
THING TO SEE BUT- WITH THAT
THERE ARE ALSO THAN SCRUPULOUS
ACTORS AND DOES IT TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF FAMILIES IN A VERY
VULNERABLE THE MOST VULNERABLE
MOMENT THE OTHER ALLIES IN MANY
CASES WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO-
PROTECT THEIR LOVED ONE- AND-
YOU KNOW I I'M I'M REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS BILL
GOING FORWARD AND SEEING.
MOVING FOR WHAT ELSE WE CAN DO
TO PROTECT THEM THESE FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY AS AS INDICATED WITH
THE RISE IN ADDICTION AND SO
MANY ISSUES AND ANXIETY THAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING IN OUR WORLD IN
GENERAL I THINK THAT- BUT
WHENEVER THERE'S A- WE- NEVER
THERE'S- PEOPLE THINK ABOUT. OF
THAT PAIN. AND SO I APPRECIATE
FOR. ABOUT SOME UPPER. TO PUT.
ABA INDIVIDUAL IN OUR STATE
THAT ARE GOING. THROUGH A LOT
RIGHT NOW INSIDE ALSO. OF THE
BE- WE WOULD LIKE TO GO TO JOIN
AS A PRINCIPAL AUTHOR. IF YOU
SO CHOOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS THIS
GALLAGHER. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND- CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
INTENT BEHIND THIS AND- WE'VE
HAD LEGISLATION OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS- HERE RECENTLY
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
OF THE BAD ACTORS OUT THERE AS
SOBER LIVING HOUSES FOR EXAMPLE
THAT WE'RE NOT REALLY OPERATING
WITH ANY KIND OF OVERSIGHT- YOU
KNOW COMES TO MIND- COUPLE
THING I'M THAT I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS THOUGH- WITH THIS BILL
ONE ONE ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP IS. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE PROVIDERS WHO ARE ALREADY
REGULATED- BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- AND ONE
ISSUE HAS BEEN YOU KNOW MAYBE
EXEMPTING THEM FROM THIS BILL
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY
OVERSEEN- HAVE TO FALL. YOU
KNOW THE REGULATIONS AND STATE
LAWS. THERE'S ALSO THEY ALSO
HAVE ENFORCEMENT A DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS THROUGH. DH CS AND BY
THE COUNTIES- WHICH WAS THE
WHICH WITH A CONTRACT- YOU HAVE
YOU THOUGHT ABOUT EXEMPTING NOW
THIS THIS PORTION OF THE
INDUSTRY THAT IS ALREADY PRETTY
HIGHLY REGULATED- THANK YOU
SEWER I HAVEN'T THOUGHT MUCH
ABOUT IT BUT MY INCLINATION
WOULD BE NOT TO EXEMPT THEM OUT.
OKAY AND WHY WOULD THAT BE.
WELL I IF YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
OUT THE BAD ACTORS IS WHAT I'M
TRYING WELL WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT PATIENTS
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A BILL
OF RIGHTS THAT THEY AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAVE A RIGHT TO
CERTAIN. ETHICAL STANDARDS IN
TREATMENT AND THAT. SHOULD
APPLY TO EVERYONE. ARE THERE
ARE DEFICIENCIES IN THE
REGULATIONS RIGHT NOW THAT
ALLOW FOR UNETHICAL. PRACTICES
THE OF THOSE ARE OVERSEEN BY
DCHS RIGHT NOW. THERE THERE
ARE. A PROVISIONS THAT
REGULATE. PROVIDERS I THINK
THAT. PROVIDING A PATIENTS BILL
OF RIGHTS THOUGH ADDS TO
ACCOUNTABILITY. RIGHT BUT I
THINK THE OTHER CONCERN IS THAT
THAT ALSO KIND OF LEADS TO-
WHAT COULD BE A PROLIFERATION
OF LAWSUITS SAYING HEY YOU
HAVEN'T YOU KNOW MATT. YOU KNOW
WHAT THE PERSON BELIEVES IS
THEIR THEIR BILL OF RIGHTS- AND
I AM CONCERNED ALSO BY THE
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION THIS IN
HERE THAT I THINK COULD
ENCOURAGE THAT AND CERTAINLY-
WE WANT TO DEAL WITH BAD
ACTORS. AND UNETHICAL PRACTICES
BUT WHAT I DON'T WANT TO DO IS
UNDERMINE. ACCESS AND
AVAILABILITY OF DRUG TREATMENT
BECAUSE THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE
ACROSS THE BOARD AND IF. AND IF
I GET TO A PLACE WHERE. E&OE
SOME OF THESE DRUG TREATMENT
CENTERS ARE CLOSING DOWN WHAT
ARE NOT EXPANDING INTO RURAL
AREAS OR OTHER AREAS THAT ARE
UNDERSERVED AS A RESULT OF THE
CONCERNED ABOUT LAWSUITS
LIABILITY- THAT COULD BE
PROBLEMATIC AND YOU HAVE. ANY
THOUGHTS THAT MAYBE MANY
RESPONSE TO THAT TRAVIS- I
THINK THAT'S OF- UNDERSTANDABLE
CONCERN IN TERMS OF THE FINDS
THE THAT THE FINES ARE NOT-
THEY'RE NOT OPPOSED AND PRIVATE
TERRY GENERAL ACTION- THERE'S
NOTHING THAT. BASICALLY SKILLS
IS BACK SO UNDER CURRENT LAW IF
YOU'RE A PROVIDER AND YOU DON'T
FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDE TREATMENT-
AND- THAT THAT CAUSES HARM THE
SAME STANDARD WOULD APPLY IT
DOESN'T IT IN OTHER WORDS IT
DOESN'T ROLL BACK WHAT YOUR
CURRENT RIGHTS ARE JUST SIMPLY-
IT JUST SIMPLY PROVIDES A BILL
OF RIGHTS TO PATIENTS SO THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT WHAT CAN BE
EXPECTED. YOU KNOW TO THE
EXTENT THAT MARKETING
MATERIALS- HAVE SOME
DEFICIENCIES OF NOT SURE WHAT
THE WHAT THE DAMAGE WOULD BE I
DON'T I DON'T THINK THIS IS
GOING TO INCREASE LAWSUITS AT
ALL- I SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT. THERE IS
AVAILABILITY- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAS RURAL
AREAS OR OTHERS I SURE THAT
CONCERN. OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS
COMMON THING THAT SENATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR IN YOUR STAFF-
THIS IS THE FINAL BILL OF ON
BURKE PELLUCID THIS MORNING
AND- ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE
AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER NO
CHAO. CHIU CHIU AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I GONZALEZ. HOLDEN KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES REYES AYE. NEEDS ONE THE
BILL NEEDS ONE MORE SO I'M
GOING TO PUT IT ON CALL. THANK
YOU SENATOR AMBER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I WILL KNOW THAT
OUR ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
SIXTY ONE HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
OUR AGENDA. AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT SO THAT MOVES US NOW
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX. SB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT SENATOR PAM. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS. SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
IS A DISTRICT BILL WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THE EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICT TO
MOVE UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
CHARGES TO THE JURISDICTION OF
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
BOARD OR PURPOSE. CURRENTLY THE
DISTRICT AND SIMPLY
ORGANIZATIONS MUST GO THROUGH
THE OVER BURDENED AND UNDER
RESOURCE SUPERIOR COURT SYSTEM
FOR CONFLICT RESOLUTION. THIS
EXISTING PROCESS IS TIME
CONSUMING EXPENSIVE. AND MAY
PLACE AN UNFAIR PRACTICE CHARGE
OF THE JUDGE WHO MAY HAVE
LITTLE EXPERIENCE WITH PUBLIC
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS.
MANY COURTS HAVE SEEN THEIR
BACKLOGS GROWS RESULTED CALLED
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN
COMPARISON THE PERFECT CONFLICT
RESOLUTION PROCESS MORE
STREAMLINED THE LESS EXPENSIVE.
FOR EMPLOYERS AGENTS AND
TAXPAYERS AND SPECIFIC TO THE
CONFLICT RESOLUTION WITHIN
PUBLIC SECTORS. AND THEN IT'S
TAKEN IN THIS COMMITTEE ALLOWS
PER TO FLY EXISTING PRECEDENT
TO SECULAR REGIONAL TRANSIT
WHILE DRAFTING DISTRICT
SPECIFIC REGULATIONS THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY BOTH THE-
SECOND REASON TRANSIT THE
EMPLOYER AND THE- EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
SENATOR I DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES
LISTED DAVID PHILLIPS AND TIM
CRIMMINS BOTH. WITH US ON THE
TELEPHONE DAVID PHILLIPS ARE
YOU WITH US. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- WELL FIRST
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY-
THE SPEAK THIS MORNING. GOOD
AFTERNOON BUT IT'S- GOOD
MORNING OF THE WORKING WEIRD
HOURS BUT PLEASE IF YOU CAN- I
UP PRESIDENT OF MY APPS THE
LOCAL FORTY. BUT I'M ALL- NOW
IT POINT YEAR. FOR SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL TRANSIT. YEAH WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE OUR OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM OF EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER
RELATIONS- PRESSES BROKEN THAT
THAT WOULD FALL UNDER THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE. NOT THE-
MYERS REALLY IT BROWN ACTON
PURPOSE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
JURISDICTION FOR MOST PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION HI THIS
CURRENT SYSTEM- THERE'S
ALLEGATION OF YOUR PRE BY
LEESON. WHAT THREE FILE THE
WRITTEN THE STATE SUPERIOR
COURT IT CAN TAKE UP QUITE A
WHILE- MONTHS YEARS TOGETHER
DOES MEANT. YOU AND THIS COULD
BE FROM A JUDGE THAT MAY NOT
HAVE A. VERY MUCH EXPERIENCE
LIBERAL ARTS. BOB IT'S ALSO
COPY PROCESS WE THE- CARE. ARE
UP BIG UP PICKING THE TAB
INSTEAD OF MONEY GOING TOWARDS
PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION FOR
THE- CITIZENS OF THE SACRAMENTO
REGION. IT SPENT ON COURT FEES-
THIS BILL ALSO ENSURES THAT
BOTH THE EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE DOING TO SAY.
THAT A LIMIT INTERFERENCE WITH
THE EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION
RIGHT. THAT ALSO PROTECT
EMPLOYEES FROM BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST OR LACK
OF FAIR REPRESENTATION BY THE
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS WHICH
THEY BELONG. YEAH THAT'S GOING
TO CREATE UNIFORMITY WITHIN THE
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATIONS. WHERE
TRANSIT EMPLOYEES ARE PART OF A
LARGER GROUP OF PUBLIC WORKERS
SADDAM AND- RIGHT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A YES VOTE ON THAT BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. AND THEN CARMAN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN I THAT YOU
INTERNATIONAL ABOUT ENGINEERS-
I WOULD ALIGN LIKE WITH COM AT
THE BOTH OF THE INTENT PANTS
PRESENCE AND THE GENTLEMAN FROM
ASKING- I JUST ADD THAT. THAT
CURRENTLY I DON'T WORK ROUGHLY
SEVEN FIVE. TO FIFTY THOUSAND
TO PROCESS UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICES ALL THE FUNCTIONAL
THAT THAT PARTY IS DOING THE
SAME- THIS WOULD SAVE BOTH
LABOR AND MANAGEMENT MONEY- AND
SHOULD BE NOTICED NOTIFIED
VOEPEL THAT THIS BILL SUPPORTED
BOTH BY LABOR AND MANAGEMENT
THAT THE DISTRICT- AND WE'VE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS-
FIRST CONCERNS AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHERS
WHO LIKE INDICATE SUPPORT IS
THERE. ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERS
MIKE MY- ON BEHALF OF THE MEN
AND- I BELIEVE THE I'D BE W.
LOW TOLD. FIVE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR ANYONE ELSE
HERE THE CHAMBERS. SEEING NONE
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
BUT- SEEING NONE WILL MOVE NOW
TO THE TELEPHONE OPERATOR WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT PRESS ONE
THE NEW ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE INTO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LISTED THERE ANYONE
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT. SEEING NONE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE NINETY. AND IF THERE IS
ANY CHANCE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCHTONE PHONE. MISTER
CHAIR ONCE AGAIN THERE'S NO ONE
IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I
WILL BRING IT BACK THEN TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
BUT WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. THANK YOU SEEING
NOTHING CENTER IN A CURRENT
ESPECIALLY S. WHEN I READ THANK
YOU THANK YOU DO A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. STONE HI STONE I
GALLAGHER. CHAU. CHU CHU AYE
DAVIES. GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES TWENTY FIVE THAT'S FOR.
SO THE BILL NEEDS TO MORE VOTES
PUT IT OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT I WILL TAKE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA AS WE
WAIT FOR OTHER AUTHORS. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA PLEASE. STONE
AYE STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I SHALL YOU CHUGAI
DAVIES GONZALEZ HOLDEN KALRA.
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES RECI
IT'S TWO MORE RATE I WILL PUT
THE CONSENT AGENDA I'LL CALL WE
STILL NEED TO MORE VOTES THERE
AND THAT IS SB THREE FIFTY TWO
BY SENATOR EGGMAN WHICH IS THE
MOTION IS CONSENT TO
APPROPRIATIONS. RIGHT CALLING
SENATORS WHO WANT TO HAVE A
BILL HEARD. CENTERS MCGUIRE
LIMóN LEYVA HUESO HERTZBERG.
NOW IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY.
SURE
SO WHILE WE'RE WAITING LET'S
SEE IF WE CAN ADD ON AT LEAST
TO THE BUSINESS THAT WE HAVE.
DONE SO STARTING WITH THE
CONSENT AGENDA. CONSENT CHAU
DAVIES DAVIES I CONSULT CONSULT
BY HOLDEN KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN. SO THAT IS NOW OUT
THANK YOU- THIS IS RUN THROUGH
ITEMS ONE THROUGH SIX AND I'VE
NEVER ONE SB FORTY ONE OF THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER AYE CHU. CHU I.
HOLDEN KILEY MAIENSCHEIN. THANK
YOU THAT BILL WAS ALREADY OUT
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWO ELEVEN
NUMBER IS ALSO OUT BUT YOU CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER I CHU. CHU I. HOLDEN
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN. ADAM NUMBER
THREE IS ALSO OUT SB TWO FORTY
ONE NUMBER CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SO. HOLDEN KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN OKAY- ITEM NUMBER
FOUR IS ON CALL SB THREE FORTY
NINE NUMBER A LIST TO CALL CALL
IT IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU
GONZALEZ CONSOLES I HOLDEN
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN. CORRECT THE
BILLS THAT HAVE. THE BILL IS
OUT LOVELY AND THEN ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT PAN IS
ON CALL I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL
CHAU. DAVIES DAVIES NOW
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HOLDEN
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN. THE BILL
STILL NEEDS ONE MORE SO I WILL
REPLACE THE CALL WE HAVE
SENATOR MCGUIRE SO OUR ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB. FIVE FIVE
FIVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY AT FIRST AND FOREMOST
MISTER CHAIR I WANT THAT SAY
HOW GRATEFUL I AM FOR YOUR WORK
YOUR STAF TO WORK ON THIS
BILL. IN OF COURSE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. IF IT'S
ALRIGHT WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'M JUST GONNA BOTTOM LINE THIS
BILL. QUICKLY TALK ABOUT SOME
HISTORY- AND HOW WE GOT HERE
THAT'S RIGHT MISTER CHAIR SO MY
BOTTOM LINE ON THIS BILLS THIS
IF WE COULD DO MORE. WE WOULD
AYE WE RAN A BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THAT WOULD
HAVE ADDRESSED SOME OF THE
LARGER CONCERNS THAT HAVE HEARD
FROM SOME MEMBERS- ABOUT DATA
COLLECTION AT THIS BILL THOUGH
THAT WE ADVANCE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. DIDN'T PASS THE
LEGISLATURE. THE DIDN'T WE CAME
BACK AT THIS IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WE TRIED AGAIN WITH A
DIFFERENT VERSION OF THE BILL.
ONCE AGAIN. DIDN'T PASS. I'M
WE'RE BACK HERE IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY. AFTER HITTING A PAUSE
BUTTON FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
ON THIS ISSUE. THAT WE TOLD THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND WE TOLD.
LARA JEAN WHO WERE. WHO WE WERE
WORKING WITH I WHO WERE THEN
GOING TO WORK. ON A STATE WIDE
BED TAX COLLECTIONS COLLECTION
SYSTEM SOLUTION IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. WE TOLD THEM THAT WE
WOULD GIVE THEM SPACE. SO NOW
FAST FORWARD HERE TO JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FIVE YEARS
LATER WE'RE BACK IN FRONT OF
YOU. I'M IN WERE BACK IN FRONT
F YOU BECAUSE- RURAL
COMMUNITIES DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THIS STATE. ARE
STILL AREN'T ABLE TO COLLECT
THE BED TAX THAT THEIR OWN.
FIVE YEARS LATER OUT OF THE
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY ONE CITIES
IN FIFTY FOUR COUNTIES AT LEVY
OF THE TAX. PROXIMALLY EIGHTY
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS HAVE BEEN
SIGNED. AND TO TOP ALL OF THIS
OFF. IN BETWEEN THIS POLITICAL
FIGHT. RURAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES STILL AREN'T ABLE TO
SEE THE BED TAX IT THEY
DESERVE. I'LL BE CANDID. I
DON'T LIKE BEING ON THE
OPPOSITE SIDE OF UNITE HERE.
LOCAL CITIES AND WITH A LARGE-
BUT THE TRUTH IS THIS. WE'VE
ALL BEEN HERE IN OUR CAREER IN
THE LEGISLATURE. RATHER THAN
LOOKING AT A WHOLESALE CHANGE
THAT WE HAVE. I SINCERELY TRIED
TO DO. BUT THERE ARE TIMES IN
THE LEGISLATURE WHERE WE NEED
TO MOVE AN ISSUE FOR WORK. ON A
STEP BY STEP. AT BASIS. WE NEED
TO MAKE PROGRESS. AND THAT'S
WHAT FIVE FIVE FIVE DOES. IT
MAKES IMPORTANT PROGRESS DOES
IT SOLVE THE ISSUE. CANDIDLY
NOW. BUT WE'VE TRIED TO DO THAT
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
THIS ISSUE. WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IT COMPENSATE CITIES AND
COUNTIES. WITH THE REVENUE THAT
THEY ARE- AND THAT'S ONLY THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AT THIS
PROGRAM. IS 1100% VOLUNTARY. A
100% BALL FROM EIGHTEEN. AND
LOCAL AGENCIES WE NEED TO AN
ACTING ORDINANCE TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THIS PROGRAM.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPACT
VOLUNTARY COLLECTION AGREEMENTS
WITH PLATFORMS. THOSE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS ARE GRANDFATHERED IN
ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE GIVES JURISDICTIONS
WHO HAVE NOT FOUND SUCCESS IN
ENTERING INTO ONE OF THESE VC
AZ'S VOLUNTARY. COLLECTION
AGREEMENTS WITH HOSTING
PLATFORMS THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT THE VITAL UNTAPPED
REVENUE THAT THEY DESERVE- AND
AGAIN THERE ARE A FEW HUNDRED
CITIES IN THE STATE. THAT WANT
TO DO THIS BUT CAN'T BECAUSE WE
CAN'T STRIKE THAT B. C. A. AT
FIVE FIVE FIVE WILL PROVIDE
CITIES AND COUNTIES. THAT WITH
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS THIS ONLY
IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO.
FURTHER IT'S GOING TO ENSURE
THAT ALL HOSTING PLATFORMS DO
THEIR PART. NOT ALL HOSTING
PLATFORMS ARE TREATING THE BED
TAX COLLECTION PIECE EQUALLY IN
THIS IS WHAT THIS WOULD ADVANCE
ON A STATEWIDE. LEVEL AND
FINALLY TODAY AT HONORED TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A COUPLE FOLKS WHO
WILL BE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. FIRST AND FOREMOST
WE HAVE- JEANINE CANTEEN HE'S
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND THEN WILL HAVE
JEAN HURST MISTER CHAIR. ON
BEHALF OF RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIR AGAIN. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR MAKING YOURSELF
AVAILABLE ESPECIALLY OVER YOUR
WEEKEND AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DILIGENCE ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU SENATOR I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED BOTH WITH US
ON THE TELEPHONE BILLION CAN
YET THAT. AREYOU WITH US.
ABOUT JEAN HURST. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU- I THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOINT
COMMITTEE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
CALIFORNIANS SPENDING A
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE THERE ARE
OVER A HUNDRED FIVE MEMBER
CHAMBERS AND ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT INTEREST CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC AND A BURST OF
BUSINESS OWNERS AND COMMUNITIES
THE CQC IS A STRONG SUPPORTER
CENTER REQUIRES SB FIVE BY
FIVE. SB FIVE FIVE FIVE OFFERS
OUR STATE AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
A QUICK AND EFFECTIVE SOLUTION
FOR COLLECTING AND DISPENSING
TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY TAXES. A
TAX REVENUE FROM SHORT TERM
MENTAL HEALTH IMPACT. AS A
RESULT THE CO NINETY THIRTY
EIGHT CALIBER ARE PROJECTED TO
A BILL CUTS BUDGET SHORTFALLS
I'M SURE THAT WE TRIED
CALIFORNIA. TLT WILL SERVE AS
AN IMPORTANT AND NOBLE TOOL
THAT WILL ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO TAP
INTO VISITOR DOLLARS AND WE
HAVE BEST. THOSE TAX DOCUMENTS
BACK INTO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. ARE CHAMBER TOO
MANY LEADERS KNOW THE BIBLE
THAT D. O. G. PLAYS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THEY REALIZE THE
POTENTIAL FOR THOSE DOLLARS TO
BE REINVESTED AND FIRE AND
POLICE SERVICES LOCAL SCHOOLS
LIBRARY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS PROMOTING HEALTHY
ECONOMY AND SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND WHAT IS GOOD FOR
COMMUNITIES TO SUPPORT OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S BACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE URGES WHAT TAX PACKAGE
SB BYE BYE BYE. SB FIVE BY FIVE
EIGHT CALIFORNIA'S COAST
CONDEMNING ECONOMIC RECOVERY TO
SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SMALL
BUSINESSES AND VITAL PUBLIC
SERVICES THAT LACK RELY ON P.
O. T. REVENUE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY ADDRESS IT THIS
MORNING AND CONSIDERATION OF
OUR COMMENTS AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SEEN HER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR A MEMBER OF THE K.
EIGHTEEN HER- CALLING THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF THE ROLE CAN
REP. OF FIRST RC. IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE FIVE.
WHICH WOULD ASSIST THE LOCAL
AGENCIES COLLECT TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY TAXES FROM. OUR USERS
ARE SHORT TERM RENTAL UNITS
THAT OPERATE THROUGH AN ONLINE
FACILITATOR AND AS YOU KNOW.
OUR HERE SEASON ASSOCIATION OF
THIRTY SEVEN RURAL CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES MANY OF WHICH ARE
PARTICULARLY DEPENDENT ON
TOURISM AND HAVE ESTABLISHED
TRANSIT OCCUPANCY TAXES AS A
KEY COMPONENT OF THEIR COUNTIES
REVENUE STREAM. AMONG OTHER
THINGS IT- THESE TAXES HELP
DEFRAY THE COST OF PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THOSE WHO
TEMPORARILY RESIDE IN THE
LOCALITY INCLUDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT ROAD IMPROVEMENTS-
AND EMERGENCY. HEALTH CARE-
RURAL COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
CHALLENGED- IN ADDRESSING THAT
DISPARATE TREATMENT OF SHORT
TERM RENTALS- IN TERMS OF
COLLECTING THAT TRANSIT
OCCUPANCY TAX. AND IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF STRENGTHENING THE
LAWN TO ENSURE T. OF C.
COLLECTION AND COMPLIANCE BY
THESE ONLINE SHORT TERM RENTAL
FACILITATORS- PARTICULARLY AS
TOURISM BEGINS TO OPEN BACK UP
IN OUR COUNTIES. IT IS CRITICAL
TO PROVIDE LOCAL AGENCIES WITH
THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO ENSURE A
FAIR AND EFFECTIVE COLLECTION
OF THESE IMPORTANT LOCAL
REVENUES. AS A RESULT THE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB FIVE FIVE FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE HERE THE CHAMBERS WHO
LIKED INDICATES. SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE. SEEING NONE
HAVE THE REMOTE TESTIMONY.
SEEING NONE OPERATE WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE AND WE WILL NOT
TAKE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY BUT
NAME. AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT.
AND WE DO HAVE. LINE ONE TWENTY
FIVE CUED UP. MORNING DAVID
NELSON DIRECTOR POLICY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE CALLING IN
TO SUPPORT SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
BY FIVE. AND WE DO HAVE LINE
ONE THIRTY. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JUST THE HIGHER WE CAN TALK
ABOUT LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE LINES.
FORTY SEVEN QUEUED UP. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD MORNING
PAUL YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE
CINEMA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND WE HAVE LINE ONE THIRTEEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR STONE IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JULIE HALSTON AND I'M HOMEOWNER
IN HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING AT THE PORT SB
FIVE CONTRACT THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE LINE FORTY ONE GET UP. THE
MORNING CARE CELLS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CAPTAIN LOBBYIST FOR CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HUNTINGTON BEACH
SHORT TERM RENTAL ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE BY
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE LINE
FORTY THREE CUED UP. YES MY
NAME IS JUDY DO YOU ON THE
WHOLE NO HOMEOWNER IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA AND
I SUPPORT SB FIVE FIVE BY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND WE
HAVE LINE ONE FORTY GET UP.
ADAM THOMPSON WROTE ON BEHALF
AIRBNB IN STRONG SUPPORT. AND
WE I ALSO HAVE A LINE. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS YOUR POLLS ARE
PERMITTED IN BEACH I AM CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE FIVE
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINE'S
QUEUED UP FOR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU OPERATOR AND WE WILL THEN
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE
OPPOSITION LISTED. JOHN
CALDWELL. MISTER MCKINNEY
HEARING YES GO AHEAD PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN- THE- PRIMARY
WITNESSES NICK ROMO FROM LEAD
CALIFORNIA'S CITIES HE WAS
UNABLE TO GET ON THE WITNESS
LIST AND I'D ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE ALLOW HIM TO MAKE HIS
COMMENTS AT THE PUBLIC ACCESS
TIME- DO I JOHN CALDWELL- WELL
THAT CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION. FIRST LET ME SAY
THAT SENATOR MCGUIRE IS A GREAT
FRIEND OF THE LODGING INDUSTRY-
OPPOSING THIS AUTHOR IS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US NEVERTHELESS
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL. HERE'S HOW TRANSIENT
OCCUPANCY TAXES ARE COLLECTED
FROM HOTELS AND B. AND B.'S
EACH HOTEL MUST FILE QUARTERLY
HOTEL ROOM TAX RETURNS UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY. EACH CITY
CAN AUDIT ANY HOTEL ANY TIME
GOING BACK UP TO THREE YEARS
BUT UNDER THIS BILL SHORT TERM
RENTALS IN THE CITY WOULD NOT
HAVE TO SUBMIT ANYTHING TO THE
CITY INSTEAD PLATFORMS LIKE
AIRBNB WOULD PAY THE T. O. T.
FOR THEIR HOST TO THE CD TFA.
ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS REQUESTED
BY THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES WHICH WE SUPPORTED
SIMPLY CLARIFIED THAT THE
PLATFORMS SHOULD PROVIDE TO THE
CD TFA QUOTE INFORMATION NEEDED
TO VALIDATE THE LOCATION. OF
EACH SHORT TERM RENTAL FROM
WHICH LOCAL CHARGES WERE
COLLECTED AND- DECORATION
PERIOD OF EACH SHORT TERM
RENTAL BOOKING. THE NIGHTLY
RATE FOR EACH SHORT TERM RENTAL
BOOKING FUND QUOTE. THOSE
COMMONSENSE AMENDMENTS WERE
REJECTED PRESUMABLY BY THE
PLATFORMS. WITHOUT THAT
INFORMATION IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW
THE TAX AGENCY CAN ADEQUATELY
AUDIT THESE TAX RETURNS.
BELIEVES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
ALSO ASKED THAT THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
NEEDED INFORMATION THAT
AMENDMENT WAS ALSO REJECTED. SO
THE CITIES WILL NEVER KNOW
WHICH SHORT TERM RENTALS PAID
THE TO YOUR TEAM WHICH ONCE DID
NOT. AS TO THE ARGUMENT THAT
THIS IS BETTER THAN THE
EXISTING SITUATION AND WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT PASSAGE OF THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW THE PLATFORMS
TO CLAIM. THAT THE PROBLEM OF
SHORT TERM RENTALS NOT BEING
THE DOT HAS BEEN SOLVED WHEN IN
FACT A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER. OF
SHORT TERM RENTALS WILL STILL
BE ABLE TO AVOID PAYING THE
DOT. ITALY'S AMENDMENTS ARE
TAKEN CHLA WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL. IF NOT WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A NOBLE. I THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE. C. NOT HAVE A
THERMO TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NOT I PRETTY WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE FIVE.
WE DO HAVE LINE ONE OF FOUR IN
Q. I MEDICARE MEMBERS NICK GROH
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES IF I MAY HAVE A COUPLE
MORE SECONDS. I'D LIKE. TO
THAT'S OKAY I LIKE THAT THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND LAWS
THAT SENATE MCGUIRE FOR THE
YEAR HE SPENT ON THIS ISSUE ALL
ACTOR ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
THE SENATOR THAT NOW WE
CERTAINLY ARE AT IMPACT ON THIS
ISSUE- BUT WE STILL BELIEVE
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE THE
LEGISLATURE TO SHIELD THE SHORT
TERM RENTAL PLATFORMS FROM
HAVING PROVIDE THE INFORMATION
THAT THE CITY'S THE TAX
DEPARTMENT- ALL TAX
PROFESSIONALS COLLECT FROM
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE
REGARDLESS. OF THEIR INDUSTRY
SO ARE WE STILL LOOKING FOR THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE SPELLED OUT
THAT WAS SPELLED OUT BY THE
HOTEL LODGING ASSOCIATION I'M
HOPING TO HAVE SOME
ACCOMMODATION WITH THE DOCTOR
AND SEE WHAT WE CAN TELL JUST
BY I APPRECIATE YOU APPRECIATE.
HOW CAN ACQUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. OTHER THAN WE
DO HAVE LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF
OF UNITED HERE A POST THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINE SECURED UP. THANK
YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THE
LINES I'M GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THANK YOU FOR
TALKING TO ME OVER THE WEEKEND
I AM ACTUALLY VERY DISAPPOINTED
THAT WE CANNOT BREAK THROUGH.
AND GET INFORMATION. ON SHORT
TERM RENTALS TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND IT IS NOT
JUST ABOUT TOT IT IS ABOUT
NEIGHBORHOODS AND IS ABOUT
MANAGING SHORT TERM RENTALS. IN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE AND SO YES THE
JURISDICTIONS NEED THAT
INFORMATION AND YOU'VE BUILT IN
SOME AUDIT PROVISIONS. SO THAT
THE- WE CAN HAVE SOME
CONFIDENCE THAT. THE CORRECT
AMOUNT OF TOT IS BEING
COLLECTED BUT WITHOUT BEING
ABLE TO KNOW THE EXACT
LOCATIONS THAT MAKES IT MUCH
HARDER FOR LOCAL JURISDCTIONS
TO ENACT SOME OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT THEY HAVE UP AND DOWN. IN
THE AREAS WHERE IN MY INSTANCE
FOR EXAMPLE DOWN THE COAST BUT
IN OTHER AREAS WHERE THERE'S
HIGH TOURIST TRAFFIC IN AND OUT
AND AHIGH DESIRE TO. TAKE
HOMES AND TURNED THEM INTO
SHORT TERM RENTALS WHICH DOES
MULTIPLE THINGS INCLUDING
TAKING HOUSING OFF OF THE
MARKET IN IN AREAS WHERE IT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED. I THINK
THIS BILL IS WORTHY OF MOVING
FORWARD JUST BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME JURISDICTIONS THAT WILL
NOT DON'T HAVE THE CLOUT OF
SOME OF THE OTHERS TO BE ABLE
TO NEGOTIATE THESE VOLUNTARY
COLLECTION AGREEMENTS. THIS
WILL ENSURE AT LEAST THE TOT IS
MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION BUT I
THINK WE CANNOT. OVERLOOK THE
FACT THAT THE INFORMATION THAT
IS SOUGHT BY THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES ABOUT WHERE THIS.
DECATUR RENTALS ARE LOCATED. IS
VERY KEY NOT JUST IN THE
COLLECTION OF TOT BUT IN THE
MANAGEMENT OF. THE ISSUES THAT
THEY HAVE HAD WITH WITH SHORT
TERM RENTALS TO FREE TO STEP
FORWARD BUT IT IS A BIT LACKING
I ACTUALLY KNOW YOU AGREE WITH
ME ON THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. SO I APPRECIATE
THAT BUT I WANTED TO FRAME THAT
FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BUT WITH
SOME CONCERNS THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO BE COGNIZANT- RIGHT
TWELVE- THIS GONZALEZ AND THEN
MISTER TO IN THE MISTER
GALLAGHER. AND I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS BILL MOVING FOR
TODAY BUT I HAVE TO SAY I'M
REALLY DISAPPOINTED- IN
PARTICULAR WITH MY MEETING WITH
AIRBNB I STILL I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW WE ARE ALLOWING
A COMPANY TO HELP. IT'S I GUESS
YOU COULD SAY CLIENTS AVOID
LOCAL LAWS I MEAN THAT'S THE
ONLY AYE AYE. A HEARD NOTHING I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY YEAR
WITNESSES CAN EXPLAIN. WHY THEY
WON'T ACCEPT THIS AMENDMENT
WHICH TO ME IS VITAL TO THE
PROPER COLLECTION OF TOT SO I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
IT WAS IT WAS QUITE- SHOCKING.
THE ANSWERS WERE PATHETIC I
MEAN THEY THE RESPONSES BY AT
LEAST THAT COMPANY- AND I DON'T
KNOW WHY WE AS A LEGISLATURE
CONTINUED ALLOWED A PLATFORM TO
WORK IN A WAY THAT THEY ARE.
OBVIOUSLY SHIELDING- THEY
THEY'RE THEY'RE HELPING
PERPETRATE THE RENTAL OF THESE
IN SOMETIMES THE ILLEGAL RENTAL
OF HOMES WITHOUT PROVIDING THE
DATA NECESSARY FOR CITY TO
FOLLOW UP ON ITSELF I DON'T
KNOW IF YOUR WITNESSES ARE-
FOUR TO THAT AMENDMENT CAN
SPEAK TO IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH THE SIMMERING TO THROUGH
THE CHAIR JUST TO RESPOND ABOUT
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT THE
CHAMBER OR RC RC WE ARE SPEAK
TO THOSE ARE TO ME WITNESSES
BUT HERE'S WHAT I CAN SAY IS
THAT. I HEAR YOUR FRUSTRATION I
HEAR THE CHEERS FRUSTRATION.
AND THATPREVIOUS BILL THAT WE
HAD WOULD DO WHAT YOU WANT TO
DO BOTH ASSEMBLY WOMAN AT
GONZALEZ AS WELL AS CHAIR
STONE- IN SO. JUST BEING CANDID
AND TRANSPARENT- WE WOULD LOVE
TO BE ABLE TO GO FURTHER WE'VE
TRIED WE TRIED TWICE ON AND- IT
DIDN'T WORK COULDN'T GET IT
PASSED SO I'M GONNA HARKEN BACK
TO SENATOR MARK LENO. SEVEN
YEARS SENATOR MARK LENO TRIED
TO BE ABLE TO- GET- THE
CARCINOGEN WITHIN FLAME
RETARDANT IN FURNITURE- BAND.
THEY TOOK SEVEN YEARS TO BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE- THIS IS ALMOST ON
THE SAME TRAJECTORY- AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE. TO FIGHT AND- PUSH
FORWARD- AND I'M SURE YOU'RE
GONNA SEE IS BACK HERE- IN THE
COMING MONTHS AND
BECAUSE- AT THE MOMENT I I'M
NOT GONNA. ARGUE WITH YOU I
THINK WERE VERY MUCH IN THE
SIMILAR SIZE. THANK YOU VISIT
TO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK- I WILL ALSO SHARE IN OUR
COLLEAGUES- AND I THINK YOUR
PERSPECTIVE THAT- THIS IS A
COMPLICATED AREA AND THERE'S
MORE THAT WE WISH WE COULD DO-
AND I APPRECIATE TO FOR MANY
YEARS I THINK OUR VERY FIRST
MEETING YEARS AGO WE WERE
DISCUSSING THIS VERY ISSUE- SO
I WANTED TO STATE A FEW THINGS
ABOUT WHAT I THINK THIS BILL IS
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT I
UNDERSTAND IS CORRECT AND I
NEED A QUESTION WHICH IS. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS YOUR BILL
ESTABLISHES AN OPTIONAL AND
VOLUNTARY STRUCTURE ONLY FOR
THOSE JURISDICTIONS THAT CHOOSE
TO DO SO THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
BE ABLE TO COLLECT MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IT'S NOT MANDATORY SO
ANY JURISDICTION THAT WISHES TO
ENACT THEIR OWN ORDINANCE OR DO
SOMETHING ELSE CAN DO SO. THAT
ANY CITY CAN ADJUSTED TAX RATE
OR EXIT THE PROGRAM AT THE
TIME- THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
WHERE THE BILL IS THAT CORRECT
SEPTEMBER YOU'RE A 100% CORRECT
THAT NUMBER ONE THIS IS 1100%
OPTIONAL NUMBER TWO CITIES HAVE
TO OPT IN NUMBER THREE THERE'S
A PROCESS IN WHICH CITIES IF
THEY WANT TO REMOVE THEMSELVES
CAN DO SO- WITHIN A SPECIFIC
TIME PERIOD. ANOTHER QUESTION I
HAVE IS- AS WE DISCUSSED- I
AUTHORED THE LOCAL ORDINANCE IN
SAN FRANCISCO- NOW SEVEN YEARS
AGO WITH THAT ESTABLISHED THE
FIRST REGULATORY REGIME. OF
HOME SHARING IN THE STATE.
TODAY IT'S VIEWED AS THE
STRONGEST REGULATORY STRUCTURE
IN CALIFORNIA. WITH THE
STRONGEST DATA COLLECTION
REQUIREMENTS IN THE STATE. JUST
ONE MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL. THAT
UNDERMINES OUR LOCAL REGULATORY
STRUCTURE. AND SAN FRANCISCO OR
ANY OTHER CITY. THAT HAS
ENFORCEABLE AGREEMENTS- WITH
THE HOME SHARING COMPANY IS
THAT RIGHT. IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION YOU ARE A 100% CORRECT
NUMBER ONE. THIS BILL
GRANDFATHERS IN. ALL VOLUNTARY
COUNTRY BACK COLLECTION
AGREEMENTS- IN EACH OF THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES WHERE THEY
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED. NUMBER
TWO. I HEARD THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION- THIS LEGISLATURE
CAN'T IMPOSE. ADDITIONAL ITEMS
ON TO THOSE ALREADY ESTABLISHED
CONTRACTS BETWEEN THE
MUNICIPALITY IN A THIRD PARTY
VENDOR. THREE THAT MEANS. THAT
THE PLATFORM IN THE CITY. ARE
BOUND BY THE CONTRACT THE DAY
OF AGREED UPON. MEANING THAT
PLATFORMS CAN. EXIT OR CITIES
CAN EXIT. ACCORDING TO THE
CONTRACT THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED FURTHER LOCAL LAW-
IN THIS. BILL DOES NOT ALTER
THAT FACT. IF THE CITY HAS. A
VOLUNTARY- VCA IN PLACE. IT
STAYS IN PLACE. GRANDFATHERED
IN THE LAST PIECE I'LL SAY- AS
WE SEEN IN. THE LETTER FROM
AIRBNB AND I'LL JUST READ FROM
IT. IF THIS BILL WERE TO PASS.
THAT WE WOULD NOT PULL OUT OF
OUR EXISTING VC ACE. WE TAKE
OUR COMMITMENT TO PARTNER WITH
LOCAL COMMUNITY SERIOUSLY. AND
WOULD NOT ENDANGER OUR EXISTING
VCA AGREEMENTS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND THAT WAS FROM
AIRBNB IS. LETTER AT THAT POINT
YOU'RE COMMITTING TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU WELL- I
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND WITH THOSE
UNDERSTANDINGS. I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
KNOW- ANTICIPATE THIS PROBABLY
NOT THE LAST CONVERSATION ON
THIS TOPIC BUT- APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS AND-
WITH THAT'LL TURN BACK TO THE
CHURCH. IN A RESEARCH IS
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU SENATOR-
AND- FIRST OF ALL I DO
APPRECIATE I THINK THIS
APPROACH IN TERMS OF MAKING
THIS SORT OF AN OPT IN SYSTEM
THAT YOU KNOW FOR. YOU KNOW
WHERE LOCALS DETERMINE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF AND
UTILIZE- YOU KNOW CD TFA- TO
COLLECT- COLLECT THE TAXES AND
PROVIDE THAT THAT YOU KNOW
WHERE IT MAKES SENSE FOR THEM
THEY CAN THEY CAN UTILIZE THAT
I THINK THAT IS A GOOD
APPROACH. ONE I GUESS TO
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE- ONE. YOU
KNOW IT'S REALLY EASY WITH YOUR
REGULAR HOTEL MOTEL. AND A LOT
OF OUR YOU KNOW RURAL AREAS YOU
KNOW THAT WE REPRESENT. WE KNOW
FOR SURE THAT DAY- YOU ARE
GIVING US THE T. O. T. THAT WE-
THAT THEY OWE TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY- AND I THINK THE
CONCERN HERE AND I SHARE THAT
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
IS. I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY. YOU
KNOW THOSE WHO ARE DOING SHORT
TERM RENTALS CAN'T PROVIDE THE
SAME DATA. YOU KNOW THE SAME
WAY AND SO THAT CAN BE VERIFIED
RIGHT I MEAN IT. SO I MEAN IS
THERE A WAY THAT WE CAN ADOPT
HER MAKING A MEMO HERE THAT
REQUIRES THEM. TO PROVIDE
VERIFIABLE. DATA SO THAT YOU
KNOW IF SOMEBODY IS OPTING FOR
THIS- THAT THEY CAN THEN GO AN
AUDIT AND ENSURE. THAT THEY'RE
GETTING THE T. O. T. AT THE
ROAD BECAUSE I JUST WANT
EVERYBODY TO BE TREATED THE
SAME WAY RIGHT I MEAN THE- YOU
KNOW THE- THIS THE SMALL HOTEL
OWNER MOTEL OWNER THE IN THE A
THOSE WHO USUALLY USING AIRBNB.
WHOEVER BE TO DO SHORTER
RENTALS THEY SHOULD ALL BE
PAYING THE SAME TAX- TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SO THE I MEAN
IS THERE. I THINK THAT'S ONE OF
THE BIG CONCERN IS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT STE THAT THAT CAN
BE ENFORCEABLE AGAINST THESE
SHORT TERM RENTALS NO THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS A VICE CHAIR-
SUGGEST. AGAIN WILL ALWAYS BE
CANDID AND- IN PLEASE MISTER
CHAIR PLEASE. CLICK BACK TO ME
IF YOU THINK I. DID NOT PHRASE
OUR CONVERSATION- CORRECTLY
WHEN I'M ABOUT TO SAY. I IT
THIS IS A CONVERSATION THAT
YOU'RE AND I TALKED ABOUT OVER
A THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT THAT
THE WEEKEND. I THINK THE- THE
BOTTOM LINE OF THIS BILL IS
THIS. WE'VE ATTEMPTED IT. I
YOU'RE GONNA SEE ME BACK I'M
SURE IN FRONT OF YOU IN THE
COMING YEARS ON THIS VERY
SPECIFIC ISSUE- I DO NOT THINK
AT THIS TIME. WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO GET A BILL WITH THAT WITH
THOSE PROVISIONS THROUGH. BASED
SOLELY OFF OF POLITICS- AND
WHERE WE NEED TO MOVE IS ON A
STEP BY STEP BASIS TO MAKE
PROGRESS. SO RIGHT NOW THERE
ARE LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ESPECIALLY
IN RURAL COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITIES. I THEY'RE BEING
LEFT ON THE TABLE. THIS MAKES
PROGRESS IN THAT IN THE OTHER
ISSUE IS IT CREATES PARITY SO
RIGHT NOW YOU LITERALLY HAVE
THOUSANDS OF HOMES THAT ARE NOT
PAYING THE TAX THAT
JURISDICTION'S ARE RIGHTFULLY
DO. WHICH MEANS THIS BILL WILL
PUT THOSE VACATION RENTALS ON
THE SAME- RUNWAY AS SMALL
HOTELS AS WELL IN OUR
JURISDICTIONS SO ON THEY HAVE
TO PAY THE SAME TAX RATE AS
THOSE HOTELS AND- MISTER VICE
YEAR I'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU. OUT HERE IN THE FUTURE ON
A BILL THAT WOULD DO WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT- HERE IN
THE A AND I TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO RIGHT IF YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE
A FURTHER CONVERSATION A SAUCY
THINKING VICE CHAIR WE WORKED
ON. SEVERAL ISSUES IN REGARDS
TO RESOURCES A WILDFIRE AND BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ON THIS.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU
SENATOR IN THEM ONE OTHER ISSUE
THAT CAME UP- IS AND GUESTS
COME FROM LIKE GROUPS LIKE
BOOKING DOT COM WHERE THEY'RE
NOT ACTUALLY THE- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE NOT TAKING THE PAYMENT.
THEY DON'T ACCEPT PAYMENT FROM
THE PURCHASER- YOU KNOW COULD
THEY BE CONSIDERED YOU KNOW
TAKEN OU OF THE DEFINITION OF
A SHORT TERM RENTAL FACILITATOR
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU'VE BEEN-TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE I COULD
SEE THAT ARGUMENT WHERE THEY'RE
NOT ACTUALLY THE ONE THAT'S
RENTING THE- THE OFFICIALLY OUT
TAKING PET- PAYMENT FROM
CONSUMERS SO SHOULD THEY BE
REALLY THE ONES REPORTING THIS
DATA. YOU REALLY SHOULD BE THE
PERSON THAT IS ACTUALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR DOING THAT. YES
SO. THE WAY BOOKING WORKS IS
THEY HAVE A THIRD PARTY VENDOR
THAT ACTUALLY COLLECTS SO-
THERE IS A VENDOR THAT TAKES
THE PAYMENT- AND BOOKING IS
CORRECT THAT THEY DON'T SEE
THAT TRANSACTION THROUGH THEIR
SYSTEM HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AT THIS TIME. NOW THERE
IS LITIGATION PENDING IN ITALY.
WITH BOOKING DOT COM- AND- TO
ENSURE THAT THEY PAY. THEIR
TAXES- IN THERE IS A AND THEN.
THAT I BELIEVE COULD. WHERE WE
WERE HAVE THIRD VENN. FOR BOOK.
COLLECT THE TAX. ARE AT TIME OF
PAIN. I DO WANT TO SPEAK FOR A
THIS TIME BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE
THERE OT ON THAT AN INMATE-
BUT- YES IT COULD BE DONE- AND
IT WOULD CREATE PARITY AND IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT- YOU KNOW ONCE A THANK
YOU TO CHAIRMAN BURKE. IN
REDDING TAX ABOUT THAT
POTENTIAL IMPACT. YEAH THAT'LL
HAVE ISSUE DAVID. A QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO THE AUDIT HOW OFTEN
CAN A CITY- REQUEST AN AUDIT. I
BELIEVE EIGHT QUARTERLY BUT I
DON'T HAVE THAT IN FRONT OF ME
BUT I BELIEVE ITS QUARTERLY AT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
TEXAN TEAM MINISTRATION X. I. I
BELIEVE THAT'S- THAT'S WHEN
THEY COLLECTED EVERY QUARTER AS
WELL CORRECT. YES MA'AM RIGHT-
YOU KNOW LEXUS I UNDERSTAND
LEAGUE CITY AND I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN VERY STRONG WITH LOCAL
CONTROL AND THE FACT THAT YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE THAT YOU CAN OPT
INTO THIS PROGRAM IS NOT
MANDATORY- IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME. AND SO YOU KNOW IF WE KEEP
THAT- I CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM N. F. SAN ROMAN
I PROMISE YOU THAT THIS IS
GONNA REMAIN. VOLUNTARY AND IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE AN OFTEN BASED
OFF OF LOCAL ORDINANCE- IN I
WANNA GET BACK TO YOU IN
REGARDS TO THE AUDIT. WE DON'T
SPECIFY THE TIMELINE- IN
REGARDS TO IF IT'S AUDIT OR- ON
A ANNUAL BASIS SAID THERE IS NO
LIMITATION. IN REGARDS TO WIN A
CITY- WOULD BE ABLE TO REQUEST
AN AUDIT SO I WANTED TO CORRECT
THAT FOR THE RECORD TRADE TO
MAKE SURE I ANSWER-
SPECIFICALLY FOR YOU. GREATLY
APPRECIATED THINKING THANK YOU
SONORA. THANK YOU ISRAEL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. SENATOR I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
WE'VE HAD REGARDING THIS IT'S
CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO COLLECT
THIS. I WOULD BE THE DATA. THE
DATA IS NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR
PROPER COLLECTION AND AUDITING.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOU GAVE
THE HISTORY OF THIS SO THAT WE
KNOW THAT THIS ISN'T YOUR FIRST
TRY. TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO TRY TO FIND
THE BEST WAY. AND I AGREE WITH
THE CHAIRMAN AND I APPRECIATE
HIS COMMENTS ABOUT THIS BEING
AN IMPORTANT STEP- BUT I HOPE
THAT YOU HEAR FROM ALL OF US.
THAT WERE WITH YOU ON THIS AND
WE WANT TO CONTINUE WITH THE
OTHER ASPECTS OF IT THAT ARE
GOING TO MAKE THIS AND EVEN
SPEAKING. MAKE FUTURE
LEGISLATION EVEN STRONGER TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS WE'RE TRYING
TO DO AND THAT'S THE PROPER
COLLECTIONS THE PROPER
COLLECTION DATA. SO THAT YOU
CAN COLLECT THE ATTACKS CANDID.
PAPARAZZI WITH THAT NO THANK
YOU MANAGER LEADER NINETY WANNA
SAY I IT IS HEARTENING I JUST
CANDID THIS BEEN US LOG. IN
POOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU- S.
FELT THE LOCALLY WHEN HE WAS A
PRESENT THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. THERE ARE VERY FEW
ISSUES THAT HAVE CREATED SUCH
CONTROVERSY INTENTION. DAN THIS
SPECIFIC ONE ON HOME SHARING-
AND IT'S HEARTENING TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR YOU SPEAK AND OTHER
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK. AT A DIFFERENT
MODELING I WOULD LOVE TO BE A
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU IF YOU'D BE
WILLING TO TALK ABOUT THAT HERE
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR- YOUR
WILLING TO HAVE A CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU AND I WILL NOTE THAT
ALONG THIS LINE A WHITE WHY
THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
MOVE TODAY. I THINK WE WILL
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES AND IN THE
FUTURE. BECAUSE THE COURTS HAVE
BEEN WRESTLING WITH IS THAT ARE
FINALLY STARTING TO CATCH UP
AND THERE WAS A RECENT
DECISION. WITH RESPECT TO
ONLINE MARKETPLACES. BECAUSE A
LOT OF THE ONLINE MARKETPLACES
HAVE LONG BEEN SAYING WE'RE
JUST A FACILITATOR WE HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
TRANSACTION. AND THE COURT WAS
VERY CLEAR IF YOU MAKE MONEY ON
THE TRANSACTION. YOU'RE
POTENTIALLY LIABLE. TO THE
COURTS ARE STARTED TO CATCH UP
IN THE FACT THAT THESE
PLATFORMS. HAVE LONG BEEN
PERPETUATING THE FICTION. THAT
THEY'RE NOT. OR SHOULD NOT BE
VIABLE OR SHOULD NOT BE
CONNECTED IN THIS WAY. EVEN
WHEN THEY ARE FACILITATING
ESSENTIALLY ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
BY ALLOWING SOMEONE TO RENT OUT
THEIR HOME. AND IN NOT COLLECT
TOT AND THE WATER ABSOLVE
THEMSELVES OF RESPONSIBILITY
AGAIN THE COURTS ARE CATCHING
UP SO FOR THOSE PLATFORMS THAT
THE WATER HOLD THEMSELVES OUT
DIFFERENTLY MERELY BECAUSE
THEIR TECHNOLOGY BASED. THEY'RE
LOSING THOSE ARGUMENTS SO THE
WORLD IS CHANGING AND CATCHING
UP WITH THEM THIS IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE TAKE THIS STEP BY THE
FOR THE FACT THAT THEY WANT TO
HIDE AND OBFUSCATE INFORMATION
TO PERPETUATE THE APPLICATION
OF INFORMATION. IS NOT GOING TO
LAST LONG IT EITHER THIS
LEGISLATURE WILL FINALLY FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO IT FOR THE COURTS
ARE GOING TO CATCH UP AND IN
REQUIRE. THOSE PLATFORMS TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR HOW
THEY'RE INTERACTING AND IN THE
SERVICE THAT SAYS THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING SO I THINK THERE IS.
BETTER HOPE ON THE RIGHT
HORIZON TO GET. WHAT WE ALL
AGREE NEEDS TO BE DONE DONE. SO
I. APPRECIATE THIS STEP AND I
THINK IT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
THAT WE- MOVE FORWARD ALL RIGHT
SENATOR. YOU MAY CLOSE THIS IS
YOUR AGAIN I WANNA. YOU'RE A
GYM TO WORK WITH AND I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU- AND HOW
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR STYLE.
OF ENGAGEMENT NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER. TWO I KNOW THAT THERE'S
MORE MUCH MORE WORK TO DO ON
THIS THAT YOU ARE MY CA. THAT
GONNA CAN. I AND TO FOR ON THIS
BILL BUT I I'LL SAY ALL INDEED
HERE IS A OF IMAGE LEADER. IT'S
HEARTENING TO HEAR- WHAT EACH
YOU HAVE SAID- AND IF THEY IS
SPACE HERE IN TWO TWENTY TWO
FOR THE LIKE TO SAY TO BE A TO
MOVE. A SOMETHING MORAL. I CAN
SAN AT WOULD RISK ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR I
AM LOOKING FOR MOTION. THANK
YOU YOUR MOTION IS THEIR SECOND.
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU THIS
GONZALEZ MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE HI STONE
AYE GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU. CHU
AYE DAVIES DAVEY SECOND SALAS.
OKAY HOLDEN OUR KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES REYES AYE
IT'S. FOR SO THAT MEANS. THAT
BILL I'M GONNA PUT ON CALL IT
NEEDS TO MORE. IT WILL TAKE
THAT UP WHEN WE GET MORE FOLKS
IN HERE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RIGHT OUT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
SEVEN OH TWO SENATOR LAMAR.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS ADMIT SINCE WE HAVE A
MOTION AND SECOND I WILL GO TO
MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT DANIEL
I GIVE ME ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR IS SPANISH ORGANIZE FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY AND BEEN
NESSA'S BAGNOLI ALSO FROM HOPE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SO I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED BOTH ON THE
TELEPHONE. THEN YOU HAVE AG
HEARING. AND FINANCES BUT
NORMALLY. DANNIELLA GARY. GOOD
MORNING CARE STONING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANNE AND I
USE IT I THINK ABOUT THE POLICY
INTERN FOR HOPE WHICH STANDS
VERY FAST ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY. OUR MISSION
IS TO FIGHT FOR POLITICAL AND
ECONOMIC PARITY FOR LONG ENOUGH
TO COMPRISE NEARLY 20% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
EQUALING SEVEN POINT SEVENTEEN
MILLION WOMEN. I HOPE WE ARE
PROUD TO SPONSOR SB SEVEN OF
TWO WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE
OFFICE OF THE GOVERNOR TO
RELEASE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS A
DEMOGRAPHIC REPORT OF ALL
APPOINTMENTS MADE THE PREVIOUS
YEAR. ADDITIONALLY SB SEVEN OH
TWO WILL CREATE A WORKING GROUP
THAT IS TASKED WITH DISCUSSING
INFORMING RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE'S
LEADERSHIP ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY IN RACE. GENDER
IDENTITY ETHNICITY DISABILITY
STATUS VETERAN STATUS AMONG
OTHER THINGS. HOPE IS TO SEE
PROGRESS ON THE FRONT AT EVERY
DAY MORE AND MORE DIVERSE
APPOINTMENTS ARE MADE BOTH ON
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS BUT ALSO
ON THE BENCH YOU THAT JUDICIAL
PATHWAYS TO DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE. THAT RELEASES A
SIMILAR REPORT ON AN ANNUAL
<c.green>ASIS. TO TRACK ANALYZE WE</c>
CELEBRATE THAT PROGRESS THE
ANNUAL REPORT IN SB SEVEN OH
TWO IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA FACILITY ITS
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT
DIVERSITY IS CELEBRATED AND
VISIBLE. THE REASON I RISK. ASK
FOR YOUR A VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH THIS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS VANESSA
PSYCHOLOGY POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
HOPE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
TODAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN
OH TWO THIRTY ONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. SEEING NONE AT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
ELECTED TO GET SUPPORT FOR SB.
SEVEN OH TWO. ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. BUT WOULD LIKE TO
PRESS EXPRESSED SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO.
WE DO HAVE LINE SIXTY ERA THIS
GOD. GOODMORNING RIGHT SAID
JOHNSON WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN OH TWO. AND WE DO
HAVE LINE TWENTY EIGHT CUED UP.
CAROLINA ABBOUD ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CAL ACTION IN SUPPORT. AND
WE DO HAVE LINE ONE FORTY NINE
QUEUED UP. HI MY NAME IS ALEXIS
CASTANEDA FROM HOPE CAN I SCORE
SB SEVEN OH TWO THANK YOU. AND
LINE TWENTY EIGHT CUED UP. I
THINK I ALREADY WENT. I
PARTISAN. AND THOSE ROB LIGHT
GET UP AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE PRETTY WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE
NO OPPOSITION LISTED ANYONE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
SEVEN OH TWO. C. NONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. SEE
NON OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO ELECTED TO
GET OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN OH
TWO. AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO- PLANT
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU WE
OPERATE YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES
AND I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NEWMAN RIGHT SEEING
NONE CENTER ELECTED THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN HELD
HEARINGS ARE WORKING HARD ON
DIVERSITY IN THE APPOINTMENTS
IN THE BENCH AND THE BAR SO
THAT IS A SUBCOMPONENT REALLY
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR AND THE
GETTING THIS INFORMATION ACROSS
THE BOARD WOULD BE VERY
ELIMINATING AND HELP US ENSURE
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DIVERSITY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO THANK
YOU AND WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT
COLLECTING THIS INFORMATION IS
VERY NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
OUR APPOINTMENTS LOOK LIKE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE
A MOST IN A SECOND OKAY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAO TO. JULY DAVIES.
DAVIES LIKE AND SALAS INSULTS I
HOLDEN KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
REYES REZAI. SO THAT IS ONE
MORE VOTE SO WE WILL PUT IT ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU SENATOR. RIGHT STILL
LOOKING FOR SENATORS CENTERS
LEYVA HUESO HERTZBERG GONZALEZ.
GLAZER TERRAZZO L. CENTER LEYVA
HERE WE GO. SO OUR ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB THREE SIXTY THREE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND EVEN BEFORE THE
SENATOR CAN REACH THE
MICROPHONE AWESOME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
RESEARCHER MORNING MORNING
MEMBERS. I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS WHICH CLARIFIED THAT
TRANSGENDER STUDENTS CAN ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM A
BED IN A FIGHT WITH THEM WE
JUST SAY THAT WAS A GREAT IDEA.
THANK YOU. SENATE ILL THREE
SIXTY THREE WILL ENSURE THAT
THE AMERICAN LEGION AND THE
AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL
STUDENTS. AS WELL AS NON NOT
DISCRIMINATE BASED ON GENDER.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL FOR
OTHERS CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF
PROVIDING EQUITABLE EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL STUDENTS
BY REPLYING BOTH GIRLS STATE
AND BOYS SEATS PROGRAMS TO
OFFER. SUBSTANTIALLY SUMMER
CLICK CURRICULUM SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR ACCESS TO GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AND FACILITIES AN
EQUAL NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GIRLS TO PARTICIPATE. AS
THERE ARE FOR BOYS. ANY
LIMITATIONS ON THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS NOMINATED PER SCHOOLS
HAVE PLAYED A FULL PROGRAMS AND
ALLOW NON BINARY STUDENTS TO
APPLY TO EITHER PROGRAM.
MEMBERS I HAVE WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE AMERICAN
LEGION AND AMERICAN LEGION
AUXILIARY AND THEY BOTH HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION SO I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE HAVE A JUST CAUSE
CENTER FROM EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND SHELBY KENDALL
WITH US IS A WHO IS A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN GIRL STATE
ALUMNI RESPECT THAT FOR APPLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR I DO HAVE
THOSE TWO WITNESSES LISTED BOTH
ON THE TELEPHONE JESSICA
STENDER AND SHALL BE AND GO.
JUST THE STANDARD. THANK YOU A
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JESSICA BENDER AND I'M
IN YOUR COUNCIL POLITICALLY
JUSTICE AND PUBLIC POLICY EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING AND EXPANDING ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITY TO WOMEN AND
GIRLS AND WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THREE SIX THREE. THIS
BILL ADDRESSES THE GENDER BASED
INEQUITY THIS CONGRATULATED BY
OUTDATED EXCEPTION TO THE FACT
DISCRIMINATION PROHIBITION. IN
OUR STATE EDUCATION CODE. THE
EXCEPTION WITH INCLUDED CAN
MIRROR SIMILAR EXCEPTION AND
HELPLINE FEDERAL LEVEL WHICH
ITSELF IS THE RESULT OF A
POLITICAL COMPROMISE. WHAT
MIGHT HAVE ARGUABLY BEEN
INTENDED TO USE CERTAIN
ORGANIZATIONS INTO A NEW ERA OF
LEGALLY MANDATED EQUITY FOR
WOMEN AND GIRLS. ANY SUCH
RATIONALE DEVOID OF LEGITIMACY
AND FAR OUTLIVED TWENTY
JUSTIFICATION. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN IT HAS
RESULTED IN GENDER BASED
INEQUITIES CONTRAE THE INTENT
AND PURPOSE OF OUR CIVIL RIGHTS
LAWS. PROHIBITING SEX
DISCRIMINATION IN EDUCATION.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
PROGRAMMING AND EQUAL ACCESS TO
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AT THE
FACILITIES. AS WELL AS WELL AS
FULL ACCESS TO NON BINARY OUR
STUDENTS. THE GOAL HERE IS TO
BRING THE GIRLS PROGRAM UP TO
PAR WITH THE BOYS PROGRAM IN
THE GIRLS AND BOYS. PROGRAMS
PARTICIPATING IN LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS IS VITAL FOR STUDENTS
TO DEVELOP AN INFORM THE
TECHNICAL. ENGAGEMENT BOYS AND
GIRLS STATE IS DESIGNED TO
CULTIVATE LEADERSHIP AND YOUNG
PEOPLE AND GRANT THEM ARE WE
EXPERIENCE WITH OUR DEMOCRATIC.
LAWMAKING REPRESENTATIVE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PROGRAMS
PROVIDE A MORE ACT ACCESSIBLE
PATH IS THAT YOU. SHOULD
EXPERIENCE IS FOR BOYS AND DO
NOT PROVIDE SUBSTANTIALLY EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO GIRL WITH NO
JUSTIFIABLE BASIS PRETTY
DIFFERENTLY THAN OPPORTUNITY.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A PATH TO
CREATING A MUCH NEEDED CHANGES
PROGRAM AND ENSURE THAT OUR
EDUCATION EQUITY LAWS. WITH UP
TO THEIR PURPOSE OF PREVENTING
SEX BASED DISCRIMINATION IN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES IN OUR STATE. FOR
THESE REASONS. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TRIED THAT. THANK YOU
AND SHALL BE UNDER PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS SO AND I
GIRLS STATE AND THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND RETURN TO THE CAL
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. WHY
FIRST ATTENDED STATE I FOUND
THE PROGRAM TO BE INCREDIBLY
EMPOWERING AND I WAS SO EXCITED
TO BE SELECTED TO REPRESENT MY
SCHOOL IN SUCH A PRESTIGIOUS
PROGRAM I LOVE LEARNING ABOUT
GOVERNMENT AND SUCH A GREAT
COMMUNITY OF AMBITIOUS YOUNG
WOMEN. FROM ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT THEN I CAME BACK FROM
GROWTH STATE AND LEARN ABOUT
WHAT MY MALE COUNTERPART. AT
BOISE STATE. NOT ONLY WAS IT A
LARGER PROGRAM WITH YOU BOYS
FROM MY SCHOOL ATTENDING
REGULARLY COMPARED TO THE ONE
ATTENDING GIRLS STATE. BUT THEY
VISITED THE CAPITAL PHASES OF
THE REPRESENTATIVES OFFICES.
THAT STAFFERS AND
REPRESENTATIVES THEY
PARTICIPATED IN A CAREER NIGHT
WITH. COLLEGE REPRESENTATIVES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY WERE
EVEN AWARDED CERTIFICATES
RECOGNIZING THEIR ACHIEVEMENT.
NONE OF THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES
WERE AFFORDED TO US AND IT FELT
LIKE WE WERE DEFENSE TEAM TO
BLESSED BY BOTH LEADERS UNLESS
DESERVING OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES SURELY BECAUSE OF
OUR GENDER. WITHOUT THE
EXPOSURE NETWORKING
OPPORTUNITIES THE BOYS RECEIVED
SO MANY DOORS OPEN TO THEM OUT
WERE LEFT BLOCKS TO ASK. I
THOUGHT ACTUALLY TOTALLY
INAPPROPRIATE SONGS THE GIRL
STATE ABOUT BOY CRAZINESS. AND
TALKING AT A GIRL STATE GIRL
WALKING DOWN THE STREET.
TRADITIONS OF THE PROGRAM'S
OUTDATED STRUCTURE. MY ACROSS
THE LOCATION ISSUE WITH
DIFFERENT STAFF MEMBERS I'D
BEEN TOLD MANY COMPETING
ANSWERS THAT HAVE ALL SIGNALED
THAT THEY DIDN'T WANT TO CHANGE
BECAUSE IT WAS INCONVENIENT.
AND DOCTORS OUTRAGEOUS EVEN
WHEN I PUT IN THE EFFORT ADMIN
TURNOUT THE CAPITAL TO GET
CERTIFICATES FOR GIRLS CREATORS
NEVER PROVIDED ME WITH THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO FIGHT
THING THEY WOULD WITH MULTIPLE
CHECK AND FOR ME. THIS NEEDS TO
CHANGE THE MILLIONS OF YOUNG
WOMEN IN THE STATE THAT THEY'RE
BETTER AND NEED YOU TO VOTE YES
ON THE STYLE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TRYING TO APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU SO. RIGHT WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WOULD LIKE TO DECADE
SUPPORT. FOR SB THREE SIXTY
THREE. RIGHT SIGNAL THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OAK ALLIANCE
FOR FOLKS WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
SIXTY THREE. IF YOU LIKE A
TICKET SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND AT THIS TIME IT DOES
APPEAR THERE ARE NO LINES
INDICATING SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LISTED SIR ANYONE
HERE THE CHAMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
SIXTY THREE. SEEING NON ABOUT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
LIKED INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE SIXTY THREE. AND IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE IN Q. THANK YOU PROPERTY
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINE SO WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
BECAUSE OF. WHAT I THINK YOU
YOU KNOW WHEN I FIRST SAW THIS
BILL I THINK THROUGH WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I. DOUBTED YOU AND I
FEEL I'M SO GLAD YOU FIGURED I
THOUGHT HOW CAN WE FIX THIS MY
DAUGHTER ATTENDING GIRLS STATE.
I WAS NOT ABLE TO WHEN I WAS
REGION I MADE HER DO IT AND SHE
LOVES IT. INTEL AGAIN SHE WAS
UP HERE WHEN THE BOYS WERE UP
HERE AND HAVE THE SAME
QUESTIONS OF WHY. IT WAS A
DIFFERENT TREATMENT AND I'M I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
AMERICAN LEGION AUXILIARY FOR
WORKING WITH YOU AND- I JUST
HAVE TO SAY IT'S A VERY
GRACEFUL SOLUTION AND- DOES TO
YOU I'D LOVE TO COME ON AS A CO
AUTHOR. WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SING DANCE ENERGY MAY
CLOSE. TO TELL A QUICK STORY I
RECEIVED A PHONE CALL TWO WEEKS
AGO ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO FROM
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- AT CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY. WHO LET ME KNOW
THAT HER TWIN NIECE AND NEPHEW.
WERE ACCEPTED TWO GIRLS STATE
INVOICE STATE RESPECTIVELY. AND
SHE SAID SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU
SAID ASSEMBLY WOMAN- GONZALEZ.
I WASN'T SURE ABOUT THIS BILL
AND WHATNOT SHE SAID BUT OH MY
GOODNESS. EVERYTHING THAT THE
YOUNG MAN GOT. AND THE YOUNG
WOMAN GOT NOTHING HE GOT SWAGG
HE GOT T. SHIRTS HE GOT. BOOKS
TO READ. THEY WERE ALREADY
PLANNING WHEN THEY WERE GOING
TO MEET. ALL SHE WAS TOLD HER
ACCEPTED AND NOTHING HAD
HAPPENED. SO WE DO KNOW THAT
EVEN RIGHT NOW TODAY THESE
INEQUITIES REALLY DO EXIST SO I
JUST WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
AND I VOTE. AND THIS IS JUST
ABOUT EQUITY. SLX SALLY RIDE
SAID YOU CANNOT BE WHAT YOU
CANNOT SEE SO ON OUR YOUNG
WOMEN TO SEE THAT THEY CAN BE
LEGISLATORS AS WELL. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SENATOR WE
DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND THAT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE AYE
STONE. AYE GALLAGHER. CHAO CHIU.
DAVIES. THANK DAVIS. I AM SORRY.
DAVIES NOW GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA POHER I
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES RAZAK
THE BILL HAS FIVE VOTES STILL
NEEDS ONE MORE I WILL PUT THAT
ON CALL GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU SENATOR I THINK I SAW
CENTER WITH SO THERE IS SO THAT
TAKE THIS ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B.
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN. SENATOR
WELCOME. THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M REALLY PROUD OF
PERCENT S. B. SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE TRAUMA KITS TO BE
PLACED IN. CERTAIN PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE BUILDINGS IN ORDER TO
HELP TREAT INDIVIDUALS IN THE
EVENT THAT THE REQUIRE
MERCHANTS TO MEDICAL CARE
BEFORE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS.
CAN ARRIVE ON SITE THIS BILL
MAHER SOME PREVIOUS WORK WE
HAVE DONE- HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING EIGHTY
DAYS IT'S BEEN A HUGE SUCCESS.
MANY HUNDREDS OF LOST LIVES
HAVE BEEN SAVED IN CALIFORNIA
HAS AS OUR STATE- SEES MORE
MORE EVENTS THAT'S OFTEN
INVOLVE. VIOLENCE SADLY- OFTEN
RESULTING IN. THE DEATH OF
DRAMATIC EVENTS. IT'SIMPORTANT
THAT'S THE STATE MAKE- VERY
SMALL EFFORT THAT COULD HAVE
HUGE RESULTS IN PERPETUITY WHAT
IS A VERY LOW COST- LOW COST
KIDS THAT CAN. BE LIFE CHANGING
LIFE SAVING. AND THESE KIDS
OFTEN HAVE VERY SIMPLE- THE
SIMPLE- COMPONENTS TO THEM THEY
BASICALLY ARE BECAUSE- THEY ARE
TOURNIQUETS THEY ARE. AT VERY
SPECIFIC TOOLS THAT COULD HELP.
STOP BLEEDING. TWENTY TWELVE
HIS RESPONSE TO THE HORRIFIC
HORRIFIC MASS SHOOTING AT SANDY
HOOK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL A GROUP
OF DOCTORS DECIDED TO CREATE
THE NATIONAL STOP THE BLEED
CAMPAIGN TO WHERE IT WILL RAISE
AWARENESS AND INCREASED
TRAINING FOR BYSTANDERS IN THE
EMERGENCY. DRAMATIC EVENTS I'VE
MYSELF BEEN A- RECEIVER OF THIS
TRAINING IT'S VERY SIMPLE IT'S
VERY QUICK AND IT TEACHES YOU
ESSENTIAL SKILLS IN THIS OF
MOVEMENT AS- IS SPREADING
ACROSS THE NATION IT'S
IMPORTANT WHICH SUPPORT THIS
MOVEMENT. AND DO EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN IN EIGHTEEN AT TO
BE MORE EFFECTIVE SO I HAVE I
HAVE SOME EXPERT TESTIMONY
TODAY FROM BY DOCTOR AMY LEE
BURCH'S ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
CLINICAL SEARCHES SURGERY AT UC
SAN DIEGO HEALTH. AND SHOES ON
LOAN ON THE PHONE LINE NOW A
MISS SHERMAN IF YOU WILL WITH A
FEW WOULD ALLOW HER TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOUS.
SENATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESS I DO HAVE DOCTOR AMY
LEE BURKE LISTED ACTUALLY VERY
WITH US. YES I AM GOOD MORNING-
THIS IS I REMEMBER I AM NOT A
TRAUMA SURGEON AT UC SAN DIEGO
HEALTH- AND I'M HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
REPRESENTING MYSELF YOU CAN%
CALL THE SURGEON ALL THREE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS
AND THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
SURGEONS OMMITTEE ON TRAUMA. I
LIKE TO THANK ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR A HEARING MY
TESTIMONY TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. LIFE
THREATENING BLEEDING CAN HAPPEN
ANYWHERE. AT HOME AT THE
WORKPLACE IN TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS
AND YES. EVEN MATH PROBLEM-
THEN. THEY CAN BE ACCIDENTAL.
INTENTIONAL OR THE RESULT OF A
NATURAL DISASTER SUCH AS AN
EARTHQUAKE. ASSEMBLY CONTROL
TECHNIQUES AND PARTICULARLY THE
USE OF TOURNIQUETS HAS EXPANDED
IN RECENT YEARS. DUE TO THE
MILITARY'S REVIEW A FAIR USE IN
THE COMBAT STUDYING. AND HAS
LED DIRECTLY TO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A BLEEDING CONTROL COURSE
MEANT FOR THE PUBLIC.
UNTHINKABLE TRAUMA THE MASS
SHOOTING AT SANDY HOOK
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL RELATED
TRAUMA SURGEON AND MY COLLEAGUE
DR LET MARC JACOBS TO CONVENE A
NATIONAL PANEL TO ADDRESS. THE
POTENTIALLY SURVIVABLE INJURIES
THAT HE THOUGHT IN EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF THOSE CHILDREN
THAT DIED THAT TERRIBLE DAY.
ALL OF THIS THE PANEL TEAM THE
NATIONAL STOP THE BLEED
CAMPAIGN. A PROGRAM DEVELOPED
BY THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
SURGEONS COMMITTEE ON TRAUMA
AND ADOPTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE AND SUPPORTED BY
HOMELAND SECURITY. AND
ENCOURAGING YOU TO FIND MORE
INFORMATION AT THE WEBSITE STOP
THE BLEED .ORG. THE WHOLE POINT
OF THE COURTS TO TEACH MEMBERS
OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC TO
STATEWIDE WITH MINIMAL AND
RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVE
EQUIPMENT THAT ONE AVAILABLE
WILL SAVE LIVES. ASSEMBLY
APPOINTMENT INCLUDE GOD RECORD
LOVE TOURNIQUET AND SIMPLE
INSTRUCTIONS TO USE THEM.
COLOCAMOS QUICKNESS WITH AT AND
PUBLIC BUILDINGS ASK PASSED
PEACEFULLY IT BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND OUR TWENTY
FIFTEEN MAKE LOGICAL SENSE THE
TIME ABOUT LIFE THREATENING
BLEEDING OF THAT. SHOULD
SOMEONE PRESENT WANTED
INTERVENE THAT EQUIPMENT IS
AVAILABLE FOR THEM MORE THAN A
MILLION PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
BEEN TRAINING CLASSES ARE HELD
EVERY DAY SPREADING
MISINFORMATION HAVING BY THE
FESTIVAL IS A CRITICAL STEP
JEFF AND ATVS ARE AT THE TIME
OF CARDIAC ARREST. IT'S A
ACROSS THE COUNTRY NOW
PRACTICES WE SAN DIEGO I MEAN
EACH TIME I AM ON CALL
LIFESAVING BY BLEEDING CONTROL
TECHNIQUES THAT ALLOW PATIENTS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO
THE HOSPITAL. PREVENTATIVE
TREATMENT AND FOR OTHERS TO
ARRIVE WITH MUCH LESS BLOOD
LOSS. I HAVE ALSO SEEN PATIENTS
WITH THE OPPOSITE HAS HAPPENED
HE CAN BUT I EXPECTED TO COME
INTO THE HOSPITAL BUT HAVE THAT
HAVE BLIGHTED OUT BEFORE THEY
CAN ARRIVE. ARRIVES MY HANDS
MUCH SICKER THAN THEY OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE BEEN HAD THE
BLEEDING BUT CONTROLLED. A
TRAUMA VICTIM COMPLETED WITHIN
FIVE MINUTES. FOR MINIMAL COST
LIFE CAN AND WILL BE SAFE. THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD THIS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURE
AND JOIN OTHER STATES SUCH AS
GEORGIA. WHO'VE ALREADY PASSED
LEGISLATION WERE LATE AT THE
STOP THE BLEED. THE COMBINED
LEADERSHIP EFFORTS OF EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES TRAUMA SURGEON
EMERGENCY MEDICINE DOCTORS
NURSING AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
BUILDING A PROPERTY INDUSTRIES.
WILL RESULT IN LIFE SAY THAT
COULD BE YOUR LIFE. YOUR FAMILY
MEMBER'S LIFE YOUR COLLEAGUE.
OR YOUR FRIENDS. TOGETHER WE
CAN STOP THE BLEED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES LISTED SO WE
WILL GO TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS
THERE ANYONE HERE THE CHAMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN. SEEING
NONE AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN. IT TO INDICATE
YOUR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE LINES IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE ASSIGNED THEM
THEIR LINE NUMBERS. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE WILL FIRST GO TO
LINE SEVENTY ONE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATTHEW
HART OF THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING A COALITION OF
FOLKS- THAT REPRESENT- THAT
HAVE HAD THE PLACES WHERE THESE
TRAUMA KITS ARE BEING MANDATED
UNDER THIS BILL. WE DON'T
DISPUTE THAT TRAUMA KITS COULD
BE HELPFUL- BUT WE VERY MUCH
AGREE. MANY OF THE WERE AND I'M
I'M SORRY COMMITTEE AND- WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO ADDITIONAL TEN AT
THIS POINT IF YOU COULD JUST
INDICATE YOUR- I'M SORRY I'M
NOT- WE'RE TAKING SOME THIS.
WILL MOVE TO LINE FIFTY A
BECAUSE PLEASE. BETTER HEARING
MEMBERS NOT APPLY ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN RED CROSS IN A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. I
KNOW WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
I DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
LISTED BUT I DO UNDERSTAND
THERE IS SOMEBODY WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION BUT
FIRST WE'LL GO TO ANYONE HERE
IN CHAMBERS. SIGNAL ONE THE
ROWBOAT TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NO ONE ARE RIGHT IN
OPERATOR OF THE LINE FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN I DON'T HAVE ANYBODY
FORMALLY HERE BUT WILL TAKE A
FEW MINUTES TO LISTEN TO. THE
GENTLEMAN'S OPPOSITION. AND IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WE WILL GO TO
LINE SEVENTY ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT-
THAT I CAME ON TOO EARLY- THIS
IS AGAIN MATTHEW HARPER THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
ASSOCIATION- YOU SHOULD ALL BE
IN RECEIPT OF A LETTER THAT WE
SENT. OUT WE DON'T DISPUTE-
THAT FROM THE KIDS CAN BE
HELPFUL- IN EXTREME CASES- BUT
WE DO AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF LEGAL ISSUES AND THERE'S A
LOT OF ISSUES WITHIN THIS BILL-
THAT. DON'T CONFORM WITH HOW
CALIFORNIA HAVE CREATED- THIS
AREA IT IN OTHER AREAS AS YOU
HEARD THE TESTIMONY TODAY- THIS
BILL IS SUPPOSEDLY- FOLLOWING
THE STATE OF GEORGIA AND WHAT
THEY'VE DONE IN THIS AREA
THEY'VE BEEN THE ONLY STATE
THAT HAS LEGISLATED IN THIS
AREA. BUT THE STATE OF GEORGIA
LAW THAT CITED. AIM ONLY TO PAY
SCHOOL. IT ALSO PROVIDES PROPER
MEDICAL TRAINING THIS BILL IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY REQUIRES
PROPERTY MANAGERS TO PROVIDE
SOME TRAINING PAMPHLET DOESN'T
REQUIRE ANY PROPER TRAINING
WHATSOEVER AND TO PUT THE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ON
PROPERTY MANAGERS- TO TRAIN IN
COMPLICATED MEDICAL PROCEDURES
I KNOW THE AUTHOR SAYS THIS IS
SIMPLE BUT BELIEVE ME I'M I'M-
I. DON'T THINK APPLYING A
TOURNIQUET IN AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION THAT THE SIMPLE
MEDICAL PROCEDURE IT'S NOT LIKE
AN EASY WORDS FULL PROOF YOU
CAN ACTUALLY HURT THE PATIENT
APPLYING A TOURNIQUET- GEORGIA
LAW ALSO PROVIDES FUNDING AND
IT ALSO OVERSEEN BY STATE
AGENCIES. THIS BILL IN FRONT OF
YOU HAS NONE OF THAT IT ALSO
HAS A LOT OF LIABILITY ISSUES
THAT I THINK THAT THE COMEDIAN
OUT THIS REALLY GOES INTO IN
DETAIL. AND WILL PUT A LOT OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS. IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE NOT
COVERED BY LIABILITY PROTECTION
UNDER THE BILL. SO WITH ALL OF
THAT WE HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR
WILL CONSIDER- MAKING SOME
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
CHANGING THE LIABILITY ISSUES.
MAKING THAT THERE BE SOME
ACTUAL TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ON
THIS THAT ARE PUT ON FOLKS THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE MEDICAL TRAINING
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING
UNDER THE EIGHTY BUILT THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION THAT
PROVIDES THE TRAINING IT'S NOT.
PROPERTY MANAGERS. WE RESPECT.
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT HERE BUT
YOU HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS THE
LACK OF TRAINING THE LACK OF
FUNDING. THE FACT THAT IT'S A
MANDATE ON ALL BUILDINGS ACROSS
THE STATE AND NOT JUST FOCUS ON
AND MANY OF THE BUILDINGS THAT
WERE REFERENCED TODAY IN THIS
TESTIMONY. AND IN FACT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY THINGS LIKE
MILITARY COMBAT DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE- THESE ARE ALL- AREAS
WHERE THIS BILL IS NOW
MANDATING THAT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
THAT THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY FOR
TRAINING THEM ARE PROPERTY
MANAGERS WE DON'T THINK THAT
THAT IS AN APPROPRIATE.
RESPONSIBILITY FOR US SO WE
URGE. YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
AND OR GET SOME AGREEMENTS. TO
AMEND THIS BILL IN A PROPER
MANNER THANK. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITE. AND AFTER
THERE ARE- VOICE IS NOT THE
PLEASE PRAY ONE ZERO AT THIS.
MISTER SHARE WE HAVE KNOWN
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME RIGHT
THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES OVER IN THE
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M SORRY
I'M SORRY TO HEAR THERE'S
OPPOSITION TO AND I'M SORRY
THAT THERE'S BEEN A HUGE
DISTORTION. OF WHAT THE SEXUAL
THIS BILL ACTUALLY REQUIRES
BUT- THE VET BILL REQUIRES NONE
OF THAT IT DOESN'T EVEN REQUIRE
THAT PEOPLE USE THE KIDS IT
DOESN'T EVEN HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR NOT USING THE
KIDS SO- SIMPLY PUT I MEAN THIS
THIS WILL. PUT A TOOL IMPORTANT
TOOL ON THE SHELF FOR SOMEBODY
WILLING- TO USES TO SAVE A
LIFE. AND TO PROTECT SOMEBODY
WHO INTENSE ON SAVING A LIFE IN
CASE THEY- FAIL IN THAT EFFORT
SO- I- THIS BILL HAS- MOVE
REALLY TO MOVE THROUGH THE
ENTIRE SENATE WITHOUT ANY
OPPOSITION IT WAS. THE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND GOT- BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE LAST COMMITTEE AND I WOULD.
URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND
APPRECIATE. ANY SUPPORT HAVEN'T
HELP SAVING LIVES IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU. DAVIES
DAVIES I GONZALEZ HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. REYES I
THINK HE'S ONE THAT BILL HAS
FIVE VOTES WE NEED ONE MORE SO
I PLACE IT ON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENT AND- RIGHT
SENATOR HERTZBERG. ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB. SIX FORTY SIX. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- SHERMAN. YOUR
STAFF WORKED CLOSELY WITH US-
IN CREATING A SERIES OF
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS OVER THE
NOT LAST NUMBER OF DAYS TO
EXPRESSED CERTAIN CONCERNS
INVOLVING THIS ISSUE THE
TURNING POINT THE VILLAGE.
BASICALLY THERE ARE FOUR
ELEMENTS OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
WHICH I ACCEPT YOUR TODAY'S
RESULT OF THAT EFFORT AND I
THINK YOUR TEAM FOR HELPING IN
THAT REGARD FIRST CLARIFIES AN
EXEMPTION REFECTORY ARE USED
TALK ABOUT SB SEVEN SEVENTY
FOUR SIX FORTY SIX SIX THERE'S
A LOT OF OUR NUMBER ELEVEN SIX
FORTY SIX. OKAY I GOT A MEMBERS
AND THE OTHER ONE TOO AS WELL.
YEAH AS YOU MENTIONED BUT YOUR
STAFF TO WORK ON YEAH. YEAH
THIS DOES ONE EXIT CLARIFIES
THE EXEMPTIONS OF PAGA THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT HERE ALL
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS RIGHT IN EFFORT
BETWEEN JANUARY ONE AND JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR BASICALLY A SUNSET
TO. REQUIRES THE GENERAL
CONTRACTORS ENDING INTO THIS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS SHARE INFORMATION
PLAY BRIDGE THE THREE DOESN'T
APPLY TO PREVIOUS CASES ALREADY
FILED AND FOR. CLARIFIES THAT
THE DOESN'T PREVENT EMPLOYEES
FROM PURSUING- THEIR OWN ACTION
THAT REGARD AND BASICALLY THE
REASON FOR THIS MEASURE IS THAT
UNLIKE OTHER AREAS OF. ON
BUSINESS IN THE AREA OF- LOW
INCOME SUBCONTRACTING OF
JANITORS IT'S BASICALLY A RACE
TO THE BOTTOM. SURVEYS THE
BOTTOM THAT WAS ACTUALLY THE
NAME OF A REPORT BY UC BERKELEY
THAT I HAVE HERE AND SO IN
ORDER TO TRY TO CREATE A
BUSINESS INCENTIVE. FOR THE
PROTECTION OF EMPLOYEES THAT
ARE ALWAYSPUSHED TO THE
BOTTOM. WE'VE GIVEN THE ABILITY
UNDER THESE RESTRICTIVE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR AN EXEMPTION
FROM PAGA THAT HELPED NEGOTIATE
THAT AND FOR THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS AND- THE- MY
UNDERSTANDING. WE HAVE A
WITNESS AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND I
GOT A TEXT FROM CELERY CHIU IT
LIKE TO BE ADDED ON TO BELIEVE
AS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE.
AND- THE- THE WITNESS YOU HAVE
HERE- DEAN. THE FELLOW
REPRESENTING ABM INDUSTRIES.
THANK YOU SENATOR I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED DINGER FELLOW
FROM ABM WHO IS WITH US IN
PERSON AND CHRISTOPHER BOVEE A
WHO IS WITH US ON THE TELEPHONE
WHO WAS ON STANDBY FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
FIRST WITNESS HERE THE
TERRORISTS GO AHEAD PLEASE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSUS GINGRICH HALO BEHALF OF
ABM INDUSTRIES INCORPORATED AND
SPONSOR FOR SB SIX FOUR SIX
THANK YOU SENATORS PREFER
OFFERING AND I'M SORRY IS THAT
MICROPHONE ON I THINK. WE CAN
BARELY HEAR YOU. MIKE FROM-
PERFECT THERE'S SORT OF BEGIN
FROM GETTING CHAIR MEMBERS.
DINNER FOR YOU ON BEHALF OF ABM
INDUSTRIES INCORPORATED. AND
SPONSOR FOR SB SIX FOUR SIX
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG FOR
OFFERING THIS MEASURE. SURE
STONING COMMITTEE STAFF
PARTICULARLY MISTER TOM CLARK
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU SPENT
SPEAKING WITH US ON THIS M.
THOUGHTFUL WORK PUT INTO THIS
BILL. I DO NOT HAVE MUCH MORE
DATA THAN WHAT SENATOR
HERTZBERG HAS ALREADY SHARED.
FUNDAMENTALLY SB SIX FOUR SIX.
WILL HELP PROTECT THE INTEGRITY
OF WHAT WITH A MUTUALLY AGREED
UPON VIA COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
FOR DECADES WE HAVE BARGAIN IN
GOOD FAITH. THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
RECOGNIZE THE SUPPORTED THE
SANCTITY OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING FOR UNIONS AND
EMPLOYERS. SIMILAR TO AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW. BUT IN AN EVEN MORE NARROW
WAY. SB SIX FOUR SIX WILL ALLOW
THE CBA TO BEFORE WE REALIZED.
THIS BILL WILL ONLY IMPACT
APPROX APPROXIMATELY 11% OF
JANITORS IN CALIFORNIA. TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WHO
WERE PREDOMINANTLY LATINO
IMMIGRANTS. FIVE BY NIGHT
JANITORIAL CONTRACTORS TO OFTEN
MAKE A FAST BUCK OFF THE BACKS
OF THESE LATINOS THREATENING
THE STABLE AND STRONG WAGES AND
BENEFITS WE PROVIDE. AS WE
CONTINUE TO STRIVE TO BE A GOOD
CORPORATE CITIZEN. BY VOTING IN
FAVOR SB SIX FOUR SIX. YOUR
VOTE WILL HELP ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM OF SCOFFLAW
SUBCONTRACTORS THAT USE OTHER
SCOFFLAWS THAT SKIRT THE LAW.
HAS ARTICULATED IN THE UC
BERKELEY'S RACE TO THE BOTTOM
REPORT. YOUR VOTE WILL HELP
STRENGTHEN OUR CPA'S AND
DECADES LONG RELATIONSHIP WE'VE
HAD WITH US YEAH YOU. IN
CLOSING THIS BILL RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BY PORTER'S
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT HIM ASSEMBLY
LABOUR COMMITTEE. AVAILABLE
TECH TELEPHONICALLY IS CRISP VA
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AND
DEPUTY GENERAL COUNSEL FOR ABM
TO ANSWERING TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS PLEASE VOTE
AYE ON SB SIX FOUR SIX THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU THAT SO WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FORTY SIX IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN CHAMBERS.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RENEE BAYARDO WITH THIS YOU
KNOW YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THERE ANYONE IN THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB SIX FORTY SIX. TO
INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
SIX FORTY SIX PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR SURELY
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. WE WILL THEN
MOVE TO OPPOSITION I DO NOT
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION WITH THIS
INFORMATION SO IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX FORTY SIX. SEEING NONE OF
THE ROBUST TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FORTY SIX.
IT TO INDICATE YOUR OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX FORTY SIX PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIRMAN HAVE LONG LINES IN Q.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES AND I
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MISS DAVIES. SENATOR.
I JUST THANK YOU- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL TO US TODAY I'M I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE IT'S LONG OVERDUE FOR
LEGISLATION PASSED FOR SOME
TYPE OF PAGA REFORM HOWEVER I
DO WANT TO COURAGE THAT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE EITHER
OPPOSED OR SUPPORTING THIS THAT
INDIVIDUAL CARVILLE'S ARE NOT
THE ONLY ANSWER AND I THINK
THAT WE WOULD MAKE SURE THAT IS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHERS- SO I'M
HERE TO HELP- I'M WILLING TO
WORK WITH ANYONE NEXT YEAR TO
SEE THAT THIS HAPPENS. AGAIN I
WANNA THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL- GREATLY APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU SIR KERN. THANK
YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. RIGHT
SEEING NONE SENATOR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK AS WE DID SPEND
SOME TIME ON IT I AM A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNED AND I'VE SPOKEN
WITH. THEM SOME OF THE SPONSORS
ON THIS THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ACT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
PROVIDES A REAL. ROAD FOR
REMEDIES FOR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
MISTREATED AND I THINK WE
SHOULD BE CONCERNED BY ANY
SIGNIFICANT DILUTION FOR
REMOVAL OF AN EMPLOYEE'S
ABILITY. TO SEEK THOSE REMEDIES
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF NEGATIVE
MYTHOLOGY THAT'S BEEN BUILT UP
AROUND PAGA EVEN THOUGH IT'S-
NOT EVEN TWENTY YEARS OLD NOW.
BUT THE LIMITATIONS BUILT INTO
THAT LAW ARE STILL APPROPRIATE
AND WE JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT PAGA STILL REPRESENTS AN
APPROPRIATE BACKSTOPS. TO THE
BENEFIT OF THOSE EMPLOYEES AND
THAT WAS THE HEART OF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IT'S EXACTLY WHAT
YOU DID AND WITH RESPECT TO THE
STAFF WORK THAT YOU ADHERE TO
PUT THAT BACKSTOP IN I THINK
THE ISSUE IS HAVE BEEN DEALING
WITH FOR A PERIOD OF TIME IS.
TWO THINGS ONE THE UNIQUE
NATURE OF THIS INDUSTRY AND HOW
IT REALLY IS A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM. AND THAT THERE IS A
BASIS FOR THAT A RATIONAL BASIS
IN THE SECOND OF COURSE IS THAT
CERTAINLY- THE LABOR
ORGANIZATION CAN PROTECT FOLKS
UNDERLYING ARCHITECTURE JUST
POTENTIAL ARCHITECTURE WHICH I
HAVE OBSERVED IN. THE LABOR
CODE IN WHAT WE DO IS THAT WE
AS THE GOVERNMENT SAY WE'RE
GOING TO PROTECT INDIVIDUAL
WORKERS AT WHAT DATES BOY BACK
TO THE INDUSTRIAL DAYS OF.
CHILD PROTECTION ALIKE HOWEVER
IF YOU HAVE A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT YOU KNOW
HAVE DON'T HAVE THIS DISTRICT
POWER BUT I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
IT'S A SENSITIVE ISSUE AND I
THINK THAT WHAT YOU'VE DONE
WITH RESPECT TO AMENDMENTS TO
PUT THE NECESSARY BORDERS
AROUND IT. AND TO ASK FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR I'M LOOKING FOR A-
PROMOTION- NTN WE TALK ABOUT
AMENDMENTS FOR YOUR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS ADVOWSONS AS OFFICE
ABSOLUTELY ONES ARE SET FORTH
IN THE- HOUSE YET. R. YES HE
DID SAY THAT ALRIGHT SO LOOKING
FOR A MOTION. AND THE SECOND
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND THE SECOND BY THE
RACE. THE MOST IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE STONE
AYE GALLAGHER. CHAO CHIU DAVIES
DAVEY SIDE GONZALEZ HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN
REYES. RECI IT'S ONE MORE SO
THAT BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT
NEEDS WHEN ADDITIONAL SO WE
WILL PUT IT OFF CALL. THANK YOU
NOW ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB.
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. THERE IS
CHAIR AGAIN I WANT TO- EXPRESS
I APOLOGIZE FOR YOUR STAFF I
PUT HIM TO WORK ON ALL THESE
TICKLISH ISSUES BUT I WANT TO
THANK ALISON MERRILEES SUTTER
CHIEF FOR HER TIRELESS EFFORTS
IN TRYING TO DEAL WITH ALL OF
THE VARIOUS BALANCING ACT THAT
IT TOOK. TO DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE NOW. BOTTOM LINE IN THE
REASON WHY DO WE BRING THIS AND
WHAT'S IT ALL ABOUT. CALIFORNIA
HAS THE LARGEST- CIVIL RIGHTS
AGENCY IN THE COUNTRY I STARTED
IN NINETEEN FIFTY NINE BY
WILLIAM BRADFORD AND GUS
HAWKINS WHO AUTHORED THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES ACT. IN
THE IN THE- THAT SIMPLEMENT AND
HOUSING ACT THE FIAT- BACK IN
THOSE DAYS WHICH MIRRORS WHAT
WE DO WITH THE EEOC. AT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS YOU HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT WHO IS STANDING ON
BEHALF OF INDIVIDUALS TO
PROTECT THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS IN
ADDITION YOU HAVE THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO OFTEN HIRES
LAWYERS TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
RIGHTS WOULD HAVE BEEN A
VIOLATION. THERE WAS A COURT
CASE THAT CAME DOWN FROM THE-
CERTIFIED FOR PUBLICATION ON
THE FOURTH APPELLATE DISTRICT.
ON APRIL EIGHTH AND THIS
MEASURE HAS BEEN A PLATE OF
TWENTY. ONE TWENTY AND THIS
MEASURE IT'S CALLED THE- THE-
WHICH WOULD VERSUS PARACORD SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND THE REASON I'M
CARRYING THIS BILL IS PRECISELY
AS A RESULT OF THE HOLDING IN
THAT CASE. THE HOLDING IN THAT
CASE IN SOME NARROW CONSTRAINTS
LIKE TO SPECIFICS BUT BROADLY
SPEAKING SAID. THAT THE AGENCY
HAS NO ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE. ARM MOVES RELATED TO
THE INDIVIDUAL AND SORT CREATED
THIS THIS UNCERTAINTY WHERE THE
AGENCIES TRYING TO PROTECT
PEOPLE CIVIL RIGHTS THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO GET INFORMATION.
AND HAVE THE INFORMATION IS
GIVEN TO THEM IN THIS CASE IT
WAS AN EMAIL. TO BE PROTECTED
SO WITH THE HELP OF YOUR STAFF
AND AT THE ADVOCATES- WE HAVE
NARROWLY CRAFTED A SERIES OF
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY. WELL THE
F. B. H. IS THE HOLDER OF THE
PRIVILEGE. IT IS ASSERTED BY IF
IT IS ASSERTED BY THE COMPLAINT
ON THE DEPARTMENT'S BEHALF. BUT
NOT NOT OVER THE OBJECTION OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND FURTHER THE
PRIVILEGE COULD NOT BE WAVE
WITHOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S
CONSENT- THE PURPOSE OF THAT
AMENDMENT IS I THINK YOU WERE
SHOOTING STAFF IS AWARE. SERVE
TO CLARIFY THE PROCEDURE BY
WHICH PRIVILEGE WILL BE
ASSERTED. IT ALSO CLARIFIES THE
SCOPE OF THE PRIVILEGE IN ORDER
TO CREATE SOME GUIDELINES FOR
WHAT IT IS A SORT OF IS A QUITE
CHALLENGING ISSUE. IT'S GOT A
LOT OF ATTENTION AS YOUR STAFF
KNOWS FROM THE WORK THEY PUT
INTO IT. WE JUST GOT A
OPPOSITION LETTER LATE
YESTERDAY WHICH WE HADN'T SEEN.
AGAIN UNTIL YESTERDAY THAT SOME
OF THE GROUPS THAT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH STILL
HAVE SOME CONCERNS. HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM IN
TERMS OF HOW TO FURTHER DEFINE
THIS. ISSUE BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
OVERTURN THE WITH YOUR HOLDING.
IN WOOD VERSUS SUPERIOR COURT
AND GIVE SOME AUTHORITY TO THE-
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN APPROPRIATELY.
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF IN A
CONFIDENTIAL MANNER- THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE- DIFFERENT FILING
THEIR CASES ON BEHALF OF. SO
WITH THAT WE HAVE- A WITNESS I
BELIEVE HERE- IS RODNEY LIKE
GET AN ATTORNEY AT THE HOUSING
RIGHTS CENTER. AND ADAM ROMERO
FROM DFG H. FOR TECHNICAL
SUPPORT WHICH- THANK YOU CENTER
YOU MENTION THE- AND TAKING
THOSE IS OFFICE. THEM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
TO SUPPORT WITNESSES I HAVE
RODNEY LEGATE. ON THE TELEPHONE
AND ALSO ADAM ROMERO FROM DFG
H. WHO WAS ON THE PHONE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. READY LIKE
IT ARE YOU WITH US. I AM. GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS RODNEY
LIKE IT I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY AT
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HOUSING
RIGHTS CENTER I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING RIGHTS CENTER
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR- HRC OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST NONPROFIT CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
SECURING THE PROMOTING FAIR
HOUSING. HRC WORKS TO ENSURE
EQUAL HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ALL PEOPLE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND ENGAGES IN EFFORTS TO END
SEGREGATION HOUSING. FOR
VIGOROUS ENFORCEMENT OF THE
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT THE
END RESULT I TYPED IN OTHER
FAIR HOUSING LAWS. HRC
REGULARLY EDUCATE THE HOUSING
LENDING AND INSURANCE INDUSTRY
TO COMPLYWITH THE FAIR HOUSING
I CAN PARTICIPATE THE
PLAINTIFFS VERY SEX.
DISCRIMINATION LITIGATION
HOWEVER HRC HAVE UNLIMITED
RESOURCES AND RELIES ON
GOVERNMENT CIVIL RIGHTS
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE AT THE AGE
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
FOR PEOPLE HARMED BY HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION. AND SEGREGATION
EACH YEAR. HRC REFER THE SIX
NUMBER VICTIMS THE STORM TO BE
AT THE AGE FROM THE- FOR SPENT
ON THEIR HOUSE FROM THE COME.
ACCORDINGLY IT IS BECAUSE- TO
ENSURE STUDENTS. AT THE AT THE
AGE THE TWO NOTHING FROM.
ENFORCE CURRENT ONE HOUSING I
BE ON THE RESERVE OR ACT IN
OTHER FAIR HOUSING LAWS TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF VICTIMS
OF HOUSING DISCRIMINATION. WHEN
I DISCRIMINATION VICTIM FILED
WITH THE FTA THEY'RE OFTEN TIME
HEARING CHORE. IN THE- SO AND-
ACCORDINGLY COMPANIES. IS
ESSENTIAL FOR VICTIMS OF
DISCRIMINATION TO FREELY
DISCUSS THEIR EXPERIENCES
WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION.
HOWEVER RECENT COURT RULINGS
HAVE CREATED A LOOPHOLE IN THE
LAW DEPARTMENT ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE FROM FLYING TO
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN DEFENSE LAWYERS IN THE
INDIVIDUALS IS A BRIGHT CLEAR
AND SENDING. THE VICTIMS OF SO
HAVE LOST THE RIGHT TO
CONFIDENTIAL. WITH YOU AT THE
AGE BECOMES WILL BE THE LAST
LIKELY THE COMPLAINT IF YOU
LESS LIKELY TO DISCUSS THE FACT
OF THE CASE BILLION ALONG WITH
THE S. C. H. AND THEREFORE LESS
LIKELY TO RECEIVE THE RELEASE
PORTION THEY ARE LEGALLY
ENTITLED. ADDITIONALLY THE
OFFICIAL BEGIN TO DISCOVER TO
FILE COMPLAINT HAVE TO COMPLETE
INVESTIGATING. SUFFERING IS
FREE SERVICES ENSURE THAT
VICTIMS OF DISCRIMINATION WITH
LIMITED FINANCIAL RESOURCES
STILL HAVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
PROTECTING THE COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN THE LAWYERS AND VICTIMS
OF DISCRIMINATION ASK
CONFIDENTIAL WILL ALLOW THOSE
WITH LIMITED FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO RECEIVE THE SAME
ACCESS TO JUSTICE. OF THOSE
WITH THE FINANCIAL MEANS
LITIGATE THEIR CASES IN COURT.
AS SEVEN SEVEN HELPS ENSURE
THAT EVERY. HAS EAGER ACCESS
JUSTICE AND THE FBI AGENT
MANDATED TO PROVIDE. FOR THESE
REASONS HRC SUPPORT SB SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR IN ACTS THAT YOU
SUPPORTED AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO WE WILL NOW GO TO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN CHAMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. SEEING NONE
ABOUT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE LINE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB.
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR. DID YOU GET
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WELL FIRST GO TO
LINE ONE SIXTY GO AHEAD PLEASE.
ONE ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE ONE SIXTY
ONE GO AHEAD PLEASE. I THINK I
THINK ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE SIXTY
FOUR. SCHLITT SANTOS ON BEHALF
OF ANTI ARE YOU CALIFORNIA AND
THE POOR. LINE. THIRTY NINE.
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
THANK YOU. NORTHERN LIGHTS IN
CUBA'S TEACHER. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LISTED JEANNIE
HARRISON AND KEVIN BAKER
JEANNIE HARRISON ARE YOU ON THE
LINE. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M JEANNIE HARRISON
AND I'M TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
THE- CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. I'VE BEEN
PRACTICING LAW FOR TWENTY NINE
YEARS AND HAVE LITIGATED
NUMEROUS THE HIGH CASES
INCLUDING HIGH PROFILE CASES
AGAINST HARVEY WEINSTEIN AND
OTHER CHANGE MAKING LITIGATION.
OUR ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS HAVE WOKED
DILIGENTLY WITH THE SB SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR AUTHORED OFFICE. AND
TO BE A PH TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND AVOID THE
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION WE'RE IN
TODAY WHICH IS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL UNLESS AMENDMENTS ARE
MADE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
GOAL OF THE BILL WHICH IS TO
PREVENT DISCLOSURE OF
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
WITH THE F. H. AND LITIGATION
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS OFTEN TRY TO
ACCESS CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN WORKERS
AND THE AT THE AGE TO USE
AGAINST THE WORKERS. THIS MUST
BE STOPPED HOWEVER THE BILL
GOES ONE STEP TOO FAR. THE BILL
UPENDS THE STANDARD ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE DYNAMIC AND
INSTEAD GIVES COMPLETE CONTROL
TO THE F. B. H. OVER THIRTY A
PRIVILEGE SB SEVEN SEVENTY
COURTS BERKELEY DISCLAIMED KEY
ELEMENTS OF AN ATTORNEY CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP. IT STATES THAT
QUOTE THIS SECTION DOES NOT
ESTABLISH TO BE SHARIA TRYING
QUITE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN AND
THE F. B. H. LAWYER AND THE
COMPLAINANT OR GRIEVED PERSON
AND QUOTE. WORKERS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE
APPRECIATION TOURNEY TRUST WITH
THE ATTORNEYS ARE OPERATING IN
THEIR BEST INTEREST YET UNDER
THE BILL THERE'S NO FIDUCIARY
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE F. B. H.
ATTORNEY AND MORE CONCERNING
THE BILL RESTRICTS EMPLOYEES
ABILITY TO GET RELIEF WHEN THEY
RELY ON THOSE COMMUNICATIONS TO
THEIR DETRIMENT. THIS CAN BE A
PROBLEM IT WOULD BE A FREE
AGENT TURNING ACT
UNPROFESSIONALLY ARE
UNINTENTIONALLY GIVE MISLEADING
INFORMATION FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT
THE STATUTORY DEADLINE THE
OUTCOME OF AN INVESTIGATION OR
ANY DEPOSIT BACK. IT'S A
WORKABLE LIVES ON THAT.
INFORMATION TO HER DETRIMENT
THE CORK COULD CURTAIL HER
RIGHT WILL PREVENT HER PUSHING
HER. WHAT HAPPENS OF COMMUNITY%
GROUP. COUNSEL THE WORKER CAN
ALLOW. WAIT THE ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE TO EXPLAIN PROBLEM
MEDICATION AND FREQUENTLY.
INCOME THE BILL WRIST WORKER
ABILITY GET RELIEF WOULDN'T BE
FTTH ATTORNEY PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACT WORKERS RIGHTS. UNDER
THE BELT THE COMPLAINT WOULD
FIRST HAVE TO GET THE WRITTEN
CONSENT OF THE DLPH IN ORDER TO
DISCLOSE THE PROBLEMATIC
COMMUNICATION. AND IT WOULD BE
AT THE AGE OF JACK THE
COMPLAINANT WOULD HAVE NO
RECOURSE. NO OTHER RECOURSE AT
ALL. THE NARAL AMANDA WE SEEK
WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW THE
COMPLAINANT OR AGREED TO WORK
TO WAIVE THE PRIVILEGE IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS A CLAIM. ONE DOING
BY THE DEPARTMENT FOR ERROR
CAUSED BY THE DEPARTMENT. THIS
AMENDMENT WOULD SHIP STOLEN SHE
THE GOAL OF THE BILL WHAT ABOUT
WORKERS WHO DISCLOSED. TO A
DRASTICALLY UPON. OR AIR BY THE
DEPARTMENT INFERRED NEED
REASONS. WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL ONLINE IT IS
AMENDED TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THEN ALSO HAVE KEVIN DE.
YES MORNING MISTER TURNER KEVIN
DE DIDN'T CAR A FOR IF YOU CAL
ACTION ALSO GOING TO BE OF
UNLESS AMENDED AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL BE CHRISTIAN WOULD THE
CASE TECH DATA PRICE THIS BILL
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
PROTECTING THE CONFIDENTIALITY
OF COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN EACH
COMPLAINANT AND DEPARTMENT
LAWYERS. HIS COMMUNICATIONS ARE
PROTECTED BY THE ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE IN THE NL
ANALOGOUS CONTEXT DEDICATION
BODY YOUR C. AS CENTER
HERTZBERG MENTIONED. WE BELIEVE
THE RULE SHOULD BE THE SAME
UNDER STATE LAW. THE COURT OF
APPEAL IN THE WORST CASE
BELIEVE THAT IT DOES NOT HAVE
THE POWER TO RECOGNIZE THAT
RULE WITHOUT EXPLICIT STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO THE LEGISLATURE.
HE WAS PUTTING IT UNDER COULD
SPARK INTRODUCED A BILL. TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. WHICH
ONLY THE TIP BETWEEN THE
FEDERAL. AND THIS CASE. UNDER
THIS BILL. COMPLAINANTS WOULD
NOT BE TO HOLD OF THE PRIVILEGE
AND THEREFORE WOULD NOT HAVE A
CHOICE TO WAIVE THE PRIVILEGE
HE KNOWS WHERE BUT IMPORTANT
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN THEY MAY
NEED TO. UNLIKE FEDERAL LAW
DEPARTMENT WOULD CONTROL WHAT
COMPLAINTS CAN SAY OR WHAT THEY
CAN SAY ANYTHING AT ALL. WE
THERE SHOULD BE A LIMITED. THAT
ALLOWS COMPLAINANTS FREEDOM TO
BRING TO LIGHT POTENTIAL
PROBLEMS THAT AFFECT THEIR
LEGAL RIGHTS. THAT MAY BE
RELEVANT TO GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT ONE REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES. SUCH AS THIS
COMMITTEE. WHEN THINGS GO WRONG
AS THEY INEVITABLY MAY. THAT'S
NOT TO DIMINISH IN ANY WAY THE
SKILLS ARE INTEGRITY AT THE DMV
IT'S HARD WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT FOR TWENTY YEARS
BOTH AS AN FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS BOTH AS AN ADVOCATE. END
OF THE LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY AND
THIS DIRECTOR AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION IS FAR AND AWAY
THE BEST I'VE SEEN. THERE'S A
GREAT DEAL OF COMMON GROUND
BETWEEN THE ADVOCATES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE I'M
SORRY IN CONFLICT IF THERE IS A
WILLINGNESS TO DO SO WE CAN
SETTLE ON LANGUAGE. THAT WE
NEED TO LEGITIMATE NEEDS OF THE
CARPET WITHOUT UNNECESSARILY
SILENCING VICTIMSOF
DISCRIMINATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO
TO OTHERS IN OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN CHAMBERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. SEEING NONE ABOUT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE ARE PRETTY WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR. THANK YOU TO INDICATE
YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. BY ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN NOW.
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE FUTURE
PICK UP YOUR HANDSET I'M UNABLE
TO HEAR YOU ONLINE ONE SIXTY.
WE WILL MOVE ON. WE ARE NEXT IN
QUEUE A ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
SIGN ON THE LINE NUMBER. WE'LL
GO BACK TO LINE ONE SIXTY GO
AHEAD PLEASE. MONOMERIC YOUNG
WE HAVE EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY THE WITNESSES FOR
SELAH CONSUMERS ATTORNEYS AND
ACLU THANK YOU. WELL LET'S GO
TO LINE. ONE FIFTY SIX. HELLO
THIS IS RACHEL RANKED IN ABOUT
THE MIDDLE IT WORK ALTHOUGH SO
VALUE THE IMPORTANCE WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT DOES HE CERTAINLY
SHARED MACINNES CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS REGRETTABLY MUST
ALSO OPPOSE THE CURRENT VERSION
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WE HAVE ONE ELSE IN.
ALL RIGHT YOU OVER IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER CAR- THANK YOU
THANK YOU SURE THANK YOU
SENATOR- I ALSO ENOUGH AND I
APPRECIATE THE MISSION WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE. I THINK THAT
EVEN THOUGH THIS BOOK IN
OPPOSITION APPRECIATE. OF THE
MISSION AND THE GOAL- BUT I
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS IN
TERMS OF. COMPLAINTS ABILITY-
TO ALSO- YOU KNOW IT. THE
OFTENTIMES THE- A LAWYER CLIENT
THE TYPE. SO YOU RUN WITH
COMPLAINANTS ARE VICTIMS WHAT
WHATEVER MIGHT BE AND THIS
CASE- I RECOGNIZE THAT ALTHOUGH
THE OPPOSITION. MAY COME LATER
THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO COME TO
AN AGREEMENT FOR SOME TIME AND
SO. JUST ONE YOU KNOW. YOUR
YOUR HOPEFULLY A COMMITMENT-
THE CONTINUE TO TRY TO FIND-
THAT- FIND AGREEMENT WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY TO GIVE SOME.
ABILITY FOR COMPLAINANTS TO
ALSO- VERY ESPECIALLY IN IN
SOME OF THE MORE EGREGIOUS
SITUATIONS ANYTHING WE
RECOGNIZE YOUR PH THE GREAT
WORK THEY DO BUT THERE MAY BE
SITUATIONS WHERE- A COMPLAINANT
MAY WANT TO ALSO- REYES ISSUES
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T RESTRICT THAT NIGHT I
KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT THE ISSUE IS
BUT- IT'S ONE OF YOUR THOUGHTS
ON. OTHER THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND IF THERE WILL BE
A PROP FOR BECAUSE THAT DOESN'T
MELMASON. MISTER. ROGERS OKAY
CAN I JUST AT MY CLOTHES. SURE
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS GALLAGHER. YEAH I
THINK WITH THIS BILL AS- WHAT
WE HEARD FROM SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION I THINK IT SHOWS
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS WHEN YOU-
WHEN WE KIND OF EXPAND THIS
CONCEPT OF ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE TO NOW STATE AGENCIES
ARE STATE ACTORS WHO ARE REALLY
NOT. THEY'RE REALLY NOT THE
PERSON'S ATTORNEY. YOU KNOW I
MEAN TRADITIONALLY THIS IS A
WHEN I WHEN I. DECIDE TO
CONTRACT FOR LEGAL SERVICES
WITH SOMEONE THAT'S WHEN
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE. YOU
KNOW GOES INTO A FACT BECAUSE
I'VE- YOU KNOW WOOLEY SAID YOU
ARE NOW MY ADVOCATE- YOU ARE
THE PERSON I WANT TO ACT ON MY
BEHALF AND THEN THERE FOR THIS
PRIVILEGE NOW ATTACH IS- WHEN
WE START. YOU KNOW PUTTING THAT
IN TERMS OF AGENCIES WHO ARE
REALLY SUPPOSED TO BE AN
INDEPENDENT. INVESTIGATORS ARE
REALLY NOT SUPPOSED TO BE ON
ANYONE'S SIDE PER SE- BUT TO
INVESTIGATE WHETHER OR NOT
SOMETHING IS. YOUR RUN AFOUL OF
REGULATIONS AND THE APPLICABLE
LAW- THAT BECOMES PROBLEMATIC
AND NOW WE GET IN THE SITUATION
WE'RE IN OUR- THE OPPOSITION IS
SAYING CONCERNS IT WILL NOW
IT'S ONLY IF THE DEPARTMENT
AGREES TO WAIVE THE ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE WELL. I THINK
THAT IS SOMEWHAT PROBLEMATIC
AND MAYBE THAT'S WHY I MEAN
ULTIMATELY I JUST AND WE MAY
DISAGREE ON THIS- AND THEN
THAT'S FINE I KNOW. WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM AND TRYING
TO- PROPOSE THIS- BUT THE JUST
ALTERNATELY- WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
THE STATE AGENCY BECOME INTO
THE PLACE OF AN ATTORNEY IF
SOMEONE TO GET AN ATTORNEY THEY
CAN GET ONE- ENDING IN SUCH
CASESTHOSE WOULD BE PRIVILEGED
COMMUNICATIONS. BUT I DON'T
THINK WE WANT TO GET THE PLACE
WE HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIVE BODY THEN ALL OF
A SUDDEN BECOMING IN THE PLACE
OF AN ATTORNEY AND AN ATTORNEY
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
ATTACHING. AND THEN THE ADDED
PROBLEM THAT WAS BROUGHT UP OF
WELL THEN MAYBE. THE AGREED
PARTY WANTS TO BE ABLE TO-
WAIVE THAT PRIVILEGE AND HAVING
TO GET THE DEPARTMENT TO WAIVE
THAT IN ORDER TO MOVE FORWARD.
YEAH YOU CAN SEE HOW THAT'S
GOING TO BE THAT CAN BE VERY
PROBLEMATIC GOING FORWARD SO
ALL TO ME I JUST THINK THAT WE
SHOULD. YOU KNOW EXPAND THIS
CONCEPT INTO THE AGENCY- THAT
WORLD. THANK YOU HAVE A FAIR
ENOUGH THAT WE HAVE A JUST A
METAL AS WELL. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. GREAT
SEEING NINE BECAUSE- THIS
ROMERO FROM THE THEATER YOU
STILL ON THE LINE. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU BECAUSE MY COMMENTS
ARE REALLY BEING ADDRESSED YOU
SO THIS ISSUE AND I THINK THIS
BILL SHOULD MOVE FORWARD TODAY
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE TO ADDRESS
IS A CENTER TALKED ABOUT THE
WOULD. DECISION AND CLEAR UP
THE FACT MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT. THE IF THE AGE WHEN THEY
TAKE A CASE AND THEIR LAWYERS
GET INVOLVED. THAT THEY HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE OF BECAUSE THEY
HAVE EXPERIENCED. PROBLEMS
WHERE A- A COMPLAINANT'S. IS
DISCLOSING LITIGATION STRATEGY
OF THE F. T. H. INAPPROPRIATELY
AND THAT IS WHAT THE F. T. H.
IS REALLY TRYING TO PROTECT
HERE AND WHEN THEIR LAWYERS GET
INVOLVED. AND THEY ARE ACTING
AS ATTORNEYS THEIR CLIENTS IS
THE F. E. H. AND B. COMPLAIN IT
AT THAT POINT IS A WITNESS. BUT
FOR D. F. E. H. A. N. D.
OPPOSITION RAISES SOME VERY
VALID CONCERNS ADD I WOULD LIKE
TO STRESS VERY VERY STRONGLY
THAT I EXPECT. EVEN THOUGH I
THINK WE SHOULD MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD. I EXPECT THE FDA TO
CONTINUE TO BE AT THE TABLE
BECAUSE- THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
THAT COMPLAIN IT BECOMES A
PLAINTIFF. AND THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN RIGHTS TO CARRY CASE
FORWARD AND WHAT I DO NOT WANT
TO SEE IT AND NOT THAT THE
CURRENT. DFG H. OR THE
ATTITUDES THERE OR ANYTHING
THAT I AM CURRENTLY WORRIED
ABOUT. BUT THIS IS A STATUTE
FOR MOVING FORWARD INTO THE
FUTURE AND WHAT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE. IS THAT THERE ARE
CONSTRUCTIVE. OPPORTUNITIES
HERE TO ADDRESS IN THIS
LEGISLATION THE CONCERN THAT WE
DO NOT WANT THIS AGENCY OR ANY
AGENCY TO HIDE BEHIND THAT
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE. WHEN
IN FACT THE THINGS THAT THEY
HAVE DONE POTENTIALLY PREJUDICE
THE CASE OF THAT COMPLAINANT
WHO HAS NOW OR INTENDS TO
BECOME A PLAINTIFF. SO I THINK
THAT IS A LEGITIMATE ISSUE SO
D. F. E. H. I WOULD. REALLY
LIKE YOU TO CONTINUE TO BE THE
TABLE AND HELP US ADDRESS THAT
PARTICULAR ISSUE IF YOU WOULD.
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT. IN THIS
BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD TO
SENATOR THAT'STHAT IS KIND OF
THE CAPSULE OF MY- CONCERN AND
I THINK THE IF YOU TO SPEND AT
THE TABLE AND TALKING ABOUT
THIS BUT UNFORTUNATELY HASN'T
REALLY MADE PROGRESS. SO I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN IT'S NOT ENOUGH
JUST TO I DON'T WANT TO SLOW
DOWN THIS BILL BUT I WANT TO
SEE WE'VE GOT SOME TIME OVER
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS. TO SEE IF
WE CAN ADDRESS THAT SO D. F. E.
H. I'M- ASKING FOR YOUR HELP
HERE. IN SEEING IF WE CAN
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE. MR ROMERO.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND OF COURSE WE ARE-
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
ON THIS- I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT- POINTED A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT THAT YOU MADE CHARACTERS
DOWN WHICH IS THAT UNDER SB
SEVEN SEVEN FOUR IF SOMEONE WHO
FILED A COMPLAINT WITH THE AT
THE AGE IS NOT STEPPING INTO
THE SHOES OF DLPH IS QUIET.
THAT IS BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ALREADY CRAFTED A STATUTORY
SCHEME IN WHICH COMPLAINANTS
ARE NOT YET THE AGES CLIENT
INSTEAD WITH THE HAPPY AGE
EXERCISE OF ITS DISCRETION TO
FILE A CIVIL ACTION HE AT THE
AGE OF THE PUBLIC PROSECUTOR
THAT REPRESENTS THE STATE AND
THE PUBLIC INTEREST THAT UNDER
EXISTING LAW DLPH IS LAWYERS
CLIENT IS THE DEPARTMENT AND
EXISTING LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
THE CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATIONS
WITH NON CLIENTS ARE PROTECTED
BY THE LAWYER CLIENT PRIVILEGE
WINDOWS COMMUNICATIONS ARE
REASONABLY NECESSARY FOR THE
LAWYER TO REPRESENT THE CLIENT
SO. SB SEVEN SEVEN BOARD SIMPLY
CLARIFIES AGAINST THE CONFUSION
BROUGHT BY THE COURT OF APPEALS
BOARD DECISION THAT FOR DLPH
LAWYERS TO REPRESENT THEIR
CLIENT AGAIN THE DEPARTMENT DHS
LAWYERS MUST BE ABLE TO SPEAK
CONFIDENTIALLY WITH COMPLAINTS
AND IN THIS REGARD IDEA PH
COMPLAINANT IS LIKE A
CONSULTING EXPERT WITNESS SAYS
THE CHARGES RECOGNIZED EXISTING
LAW AND MAKES CLEAR THAT THE
LAWYER CLIENT PRIVILEGE COVERED
LAWYERS CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THIRD PARTY
CONSULTING EXPERTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE REASONABLY NECESSARY TO
THE LAWYER'S REPRESENTATION OF
THEIR OWN CLIENTS. BUT THE
EXPERT IS NOT THE CLIENT AND
THE EXPERT CANNOT WAIVE THE
CLIENT'S PRIVILEGE THE SAME IS
TRUE FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR WE
ARE NOT AWARE OF ANY PROVISION
IN CALIFORNIA LAW THAT ALLOWS A
THIRDPARTY LIKE AN EXPERT
WITNESS. BRIDGET PH COMPLAINER
TO WAIVE THE LAWYER CLIENT.
I'VE GOT FORCING AGENCY LIKE
THE FBI. AND OTHER JUST MAKE
ONE MORE POINT WHICH IS THE
AUTOMATIC. REQUEST BY THE AD.
ARE NOT BE ON OF OR CALL BY ANY
N. PH LAWYER. AND THE
HYPOTHETICAL. THEY MAKE YOU NOT
FOR THREE. FOR EXAMPLE THE
ADVOCATE ASK WHAT IS THE DMV
LAWYER. THE FILING DEADLINE TO
A COMPLAINANT THAT MAY SEEM
LIKE A FAIR QUESTION BUT IT
DOES NOT REFLECT HOW DLPH
ACTUALLY OPERATES OR OUR
GOVERNING STATUTE IN PRACTICE
HE AT THE AGE OF LAWYERS ARE
NOT INVOLVED IN MOST COMPLAINTS
INVESTIGATED BY KEY AT THE AGE.
OF COMPLAINTS ARE INVESTIGATED
BY OUR NON LAWYER INVESTIGATORS
SECOND WHEN HE SB IT'S CLOSES
EMPLOYMENT COMPLAINT EVEN WHEN
A LAWYER HAS BECOME INVOLVED WE
MUST ISSUE A RIGHT TO SUE
LETTER ARE GOVERNING STATUTE.
UNDER OUR GOVERNING STATUTE THE
COMPLAINANT HAS ONE YEAR FROM
THE RIGHT TO SUE LETTER TO FILE
THEIR OWN CIVIL ACTION THE
BOILERPLATE LANGUAGE AND YET BE
AGES RIGHT TO SUE LETTER
EXPLAINS THAT. EXPLAINED TO THE
COMPLAINANT THAT THEY SHOULD
SPEAK WITH THEIR OWN LAWYER
ABOUT DEADLINES. SO THE IDEA
THAT A GOP H. LAWYER COULD LEAD
TO COMPLAIN ABOUT THEIR STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS IT'S NOT A SOUND
BASIS TO WRITE UNPRECEDENTED
EXCEPTION TO BE AT THE AGES OWN
PERCOLATES INTO LAW. WITH THAT
SAID WE ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT AND THAT IS
WHAT I'M ASKING I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THE FIRST HALF OF
WHAT YOU SAID. BUT BECAUSE
THESE COMPLAINANTS AND THE
DISCONNECT HERE IS YOU ARE
LOOKING AT THE COMPLAINANT ONLY
AS AN EXPERT WITNESS AND WE
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT HAPPENS.
THE COMPLAINT IN THIS CASE
HOWEVER CAN BECOME A PLAINTIVE
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
DFG H. CANNOT HIDE BEHIND THIS.
PRIVILEGE AND REFUSAL TO GIVE.
PERMISSION TO THIS. WHEN IN
THAT ACTION IS TO PRINT. DFV H.
N. WHAT N. ATA CURRENTS OF
MALFEASANCE AND I THINK THAT
THERE. ARE OPPORTUNITIES TO
ADDRESS THIS WHICH IS WHY I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. CAN STILL HAPPEN
BECAUSE I THINK THERE ARE
PROBABLY WAYS. TO ADDRESS IT
THAT'S THAT IS MY CONCERN. ALL
RIGHT SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- DEEP ATTENTION TO DETAIL
IN THIS INTRICATE ISSUE- I
THINK THAT THIS WAS A- A
PROCESS IN TERMS OF GOVERNMENT
ACTING ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST THAT WAS WORKING WELL
UNTIL. THE COURT IN THE WORST
CASE CAME UP WITH CISION WHICH
CREATED CONFUSION IN THE SPACE
WHAT INTRIGUED MY ATTENTION
WITH RESPECT TO BRINGING THIS
ACTION WITH SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
IN THE CASE WHETHER WHETHER
JUDGE INVITED. THE LEGISLATURE
TO PARTICIPATE TO CLARIFY WHAT
IT SAYS IS INDEED OUR
DIFFERENCE TO THE LEGISLATURE
US IS PARTICULARLY NECESSARY WE
ARE CALLED UPON TO INTERPRET
THE ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
DETERMINED THAT EVIDENCE SHE
PRIVILEGES SHALL BE AVAILABLE
ONLY AS DEFINED BY STATUTE WE
RIGHT STATUTES. SO THAT WAS
WHAT INFORMED THIS DECISION
NOW- I THOUGHT YOUR QUESTIONS
TO THE DEPARTMENT WERE QUITE
GOOD- I WANTED TO SHARE THAT
OUT YOU KNOW YOUR STAFF IS
WORKING REALLY HARD ON THIS OUR
STAFF WORKING HARD ON THIS. THE
GENIE HARRISON WHO- I HOLD IN
VERY HIGH REGARD BECAUSE SHE
USED TO WORK FOR ME SOME
DECADES AGO AT THE BEGINNING OF
HER CAREER AND SHE'S A VERY
GOOD LAWYER- YOU KNOW SHOULD I
TALK TO HER SOME TALK SOME
WEEKS AGO ABOUT SOME OF THESE
IDEAS BUT WE DIDN'T GET THIS
OPPOSITION LETTER UNTIL WE
THOUGHT WE HAD OVER THE WEEKEND
REACH AN AGREEMENT. AND THEN
THIS LETTER COMES IN- ON LATE
ON YESTERDAY ARM AND WE THOUGHT
WE HAD IT DONE SO LOOK THE
BOTTOM LINE IS TO THE EXTENT
THAT THERE'S A WAY TO FURTHER
CLARIFY THIS HAPPY TO DO SO
WE'RE GOING TO BE MEETING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT DURING THE
BREAK. TO SEE IF WE CAN MAKE
SOME FURTHER PROGRESS WITH
RESPECT TO THESE ISSUES HAPPY
TO DO THAT WE WANT TO GET IT
RIGHT WE WANT TO GET IT RIGHT
WE WANT TO GET IT RIGHT AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE TECH WAS NATURE
OF THIS BUT THE PUBLIC DOES
HAVE AN INTEREST IN STOPPING
THESE KINDS OF ABUSES AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ADULT PUBLIC DOES HAVE
AN INTEREST IN. IT IN ISSUES OF
CRIMINAL LAW AND THE LIKE AND
THEY DO HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
STANDING I UNDERSTAND THE WORDS
OF YOUR VICE CHAIR TURN THE
WORDS TURNING. FROM HOW THAT
WERE BUT I. THAT BEING COULD.
AS SOME LEVEL BY VIRTUE OF THE
WORDS VERSUS WHAT ACTUALLY IS
GOING ON HERE. THE BOTTOM LINE
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS I APPRECIATE
YOUR STAFF'S ENGAGEMENT
EXTENSIVELY ON THIS. WILL
CONTINUE TO SCRUB IT ANYWAY WE
CAN I JUST YOU KNOW FROM MY
POINT OF VIEW. I DO THE
HOMEWORK I GET OUT THERE AND DO
IT YOUR STEPS ON THE HOMEWORK
MY STEPS ON THE HOMEWORK. AND
NOW THESE ISSUES ARE BEING
BROUGHT UP AFTER WE THOUGHT WE
HAD A DEAL YESTERDAY LATE
YESTERDAY. IT IS WHAT IT IS
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT
BUT- HAD I HAD THESE THESE
ARGUMENTS WITH RENEWED US.
EARLIER I WOULD HAVE JUST
ANSWER AND I AGAIN APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO DETAIL ON
THIS NASTY RIVAL. THANK YOU I'M
LOOKING FOR A MOTION. THIRTY
THE MOVE BY MS GONZALEZ SECOND
BY MR HOLDEN THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE AYE STONE HI
GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER KNOWN CHAU
CHIU DAVIES DAVIES NO CONTROLS.
CONSULT I HOLDEN HOLDEN I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY NOTE
MAIENSCHEIN REYES. THE BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES WE NEED TO WAR SO I
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR STAVING MEMBERS
ENERGY YOUR ATTENTION TO DETAIL
ON THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU
RIGHT SENATOR GONZALEZ SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. YES THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO PROTECT ESSENTIAL
FRONT LINE TRUCK DRIVERS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS. I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING SO DILIGENTLY
WITH MY OFFICE AND ACROSS
AMENDMENTS THAT CLARIFY
PROCEDURES IN THE BILL AND MAKE
IT STRONGER. AND I'M ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED ON PAGE TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS. FOR TRUCK DRIVERS
HAVE BEEN A TORY ASLI EXPLOITED
BY BAD ACTORS IN THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY THESE BAD ACTORS
ROUTINELY MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
TO CUT COSTS. WRONGFULLY
EXCLUDE WORKERS FOR MINIMUM
WAGE WORKERS COMPENSATION AND
THE RIGHT TO JOIN A UNION. SB
THREE THIRTY ADDRESSES ITS
ONGOING PROBLEM BY ADDING
TRUCKING COMPANIES TO AN
EXISTING JOINT LIABILITY BAD
ACTOR LIST IF THOSE COMPANIES
ROUTINELY MISCLASSIFIED OR
FAILED TO ADDRESS SERIOUS CAL
OSHA VIOLATIONS. IT HOLDS THE
MOST EGREGIOUS BAD ACTORS
ACCOUNTABLE BY LOWERING THE
THRESHOLD TO GET PUT ON THE BAD
ACTOR LIST FOR PRIOR OFFENDERS.
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN FOUND TO
HAVE MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS
CURRENTLY HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I'VE WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON BOTH SIDES TO
ENSURE THAT THE LANGUAGE IS
TARGETED TO FOCUS ONLY ON TRULY
BAD ACTORS LEVELING THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR THE CONTRACT TRUCKING
COMPANIES- TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY HAVE SHANE
GUSMAN. THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL AND CAITLIN VEGA FROM
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF TEAMSTERS PORT DIVISION
THINKING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER I
DID HEAR A MOTION FROM. THIS
GONZALEZ IS THEIR SECOND. AND
THE SECOND FOR MISTER. THANK
YOU SO I DO HAVE THOSE TWO
WITNESSES LISTED SHANE GUSMAN
AND CAITLIN VEGA CHAIN GUSTON.
GOOD MORNING SHE DOES NOT
BEHALF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT AND
PRACTICAL SPONSOR THIS BILL.
PRESS THE POINT OF THIS BILL IS
TO ADDRESS THE LONG HISTORY OF
DRIVER MISS CLASSIFICATION THAT
HAS OCCURRED IN THE TRUCKING
INDUSTRY EVER SINCE IT WAS THE
REGULATED FOR DECADES AGO. NO
WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE OF THIS
PROBLEM GREATER THAN OUR
LARGEST PORTS. THERE
EXPLICATION OF THE DOMINANT
ECONOMIC MODEL TRUCKING
COMPANIES HIRE A WORKFORCE OF
MOSTLY IMMIGRANT DRIVERS. WHO
ARE FORCED TO ACT AS IF THEY
ARE IN BUSINESS FOR THEMSELVES.
RESPONSIBLE FOR PURCHASING OR
LEASING THEIR OWN TRUCKS PAYING
FOR ALL OF THE FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE AND ALL THE WHILE
ACCEPTING EXTREMELY LOW
NONNEGOTIABLE RIGHT. IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON TO HAVE MONTHS WHERE
THE COST OF MAINTAINING THE
TRUCK IS ACTUALLY MORE THAN THE
DRIVER MAKES. ON TOP OF THAT
SPEECH DRIVERS GET NO
HEALTHCARE NO MINIMUM WAGE NO
OVERTIME NO WORKERS COMP NO
PAID SICK DAYS AND ABSOLUTELY
NO HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS. LIKE THOSE THAT
WERE NEEDED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THIS IS NOT HYPERBOLE
THESE ARE THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND. HUNDREDS OF COMPLAINTS
LABOR COMMISSIONER.
INVESTIGATIONS AND LAWSUITS
HAVE UNIVERSALLY CONCLUDED WITH
FINDING THAT THE PORT DRAYAGE
DRIVERS ARE IN FACT
MISCLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES.
COUNTLESS NEWS ARTICLES HAVE
CHRONICLED THIS PROBLEM FOR
MANY YEARS NONETHELESS THE
PROBLEM PROCESS. THE TEAMSTERS
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND OTHERS
HAVE TRIED TO HELP THESE
DRIVERS UNFORTUNATELY. THE WAY
THEY ARE MISCLASSIFIED AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. HAS
MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO ACT COLLECTIVELY. FOUR YEARS
AGO WE REALIZE THAT THE REAL
WAY TO TACKLE THIS PROBLEM IS
TO GET AT THE ROOT OF IT. THE
GIANT COMPANIES THAT BENEFIT
FROM THE SYSTEM NEED TO TAKE
SOME RESPONSIBILITY HERE. WE
SPONSORED SB FORTINO TO THEM
WHICH PROVIDES FOR JOINT
LIABILITY OF A COMPANY HIRES
ONE OF THESE BAD AFTER TRUCKING
FIRMS TO SHIP IT'S GOOD.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SIMPLY TOO
MANY LOOPHOLES. THAT HAVE LEFT
THE LAW SOMEWHAT INEFFECTIVE IN
ACHIEVING SYSTEMATIC CHANGE WE
NEED SB THREE THREE EIGHT TO
FILL THOSE LOOPHOLES AND MAKE
SURE EXPLICATION AND ONCE AND
FOR ALL THANK. THANK YOU AND
THEN CAITLIN VEGA. NUMBER EIGHT
WHEN DATA ON BEHALF SUPPORT
DIVISION AT THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF TEAMSTERS HOUSE
CO SPONSORS OF SB THREE THREE
EIGHT. I THINK THE END SO MANY
INDUSTRIES THAT ARE RIPE WITH
LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS THE ONLY
WAY TO MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGE
IN WORKING CONDITION IF THE
HOLD COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
USING CONTRACTORS THAT ARE
KNOWN TO VIOLATE THE LAW.SB
FORTUNATE TO CREATED A
FRAMEWORK TO DO THAT BUT NOW
SEVERAL YEARS LATER WE CAN SEE
LOOPHOLES THAT HAVE ALLOWED
SOME OF THE INDUSTRY'S WORST
ACTORS TO UPDATE ENFORCEMENT
EFFORT. SB THREE THREE EIGHT
SIX THREE SMALL BUT IMPORTANT
CHANGES. AT VARIOUS AN UNABATED
CALLOUS EVALUATION. AS THE
PROVISION TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
CATCH REPEAT OFFENDERS. AND IT
REQUIRES THAT COMPANIES
DEMONSTRATE TO THE LABOR AGENCY
THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER MISS
CLASSIFYING DRIVERS. BEFORE
THEY ARE REMOVED FROM THE LIST.
EACH OF THESE PROVISIONS THE
CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED WITH THE
OPPOSITION. THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION WHOSE NON
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS FURTHER CLARIFY THE
PROCESS FOR EMPLOYERS TO COMPLY
AND TO BE REMOVED FROM THE LIST.
ADS ARE UP HAS NO A SOMEONE WHO
BEEN AT. OF MISCLASSIFIED PART
TRUCK DRIVERS FOR A LONG TIME
THIS IS A FIGHT THAT HAS GONE
ON FOR DECADES. IT IS LONG
OVERDUE THAT WE STOP WIDESPREAD
MIS CLASSIFICATION OF PORT
TRUCK DRIVERS. AND WITHOUT THE
RELIANCE ON THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
CHAMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE SUPPORT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAC CRIMMINS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS
SEEING NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE. WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO LIKED INDICATE
SUPPORT FOR SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT. TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE THIRTY EIGHT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL
FIRST GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
TWO GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI THIS IS
A PROBLEM THE CARAMEL WORKERS
CENTER- IS THE INITIAL
COMPARTMENT WORKER CENTER
SHOWING STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU. LINE FORTY
SEVEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS PLAYER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
EIGHTY. THANK YOU MISTER TURN
NUMBERS MAKITA KARATE WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT AND LIKE TO
THINK THE AUTHOR IN OUR LABOR
PARTNERS FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. THANK. ONE ONE SIXTY
THREE. HI MY NAME IS GOOD AT
THE END OF THE DAY IS- I
REPRESENT AND THE ON LINE FOR
YOU ECONOMY AND WE ARE IN
STOCKPORT AT THE BILL. LINE.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR EDUARDO MARTINEZ
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE. ONE SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS KRISTOFF
MAYOR WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THREE EIGHT THANK
YOU. LINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR.
JOHN GLOBALLY- FROM THE
NORTHEAST DEMOCRATIC CLUB OF
LOS ANGELES WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL STRONGLY. LINE. ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS SABRINA
BILL SIR- OTHER THAN IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COLLEGE OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
THE NEW YORK STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. NINE ONE SIXTY TWO.
HELLO THIS IS MERRY VIEW I AM
FROM CLERGY AND LAITY UNITED
FOR ECONOMIC JUSTICE HOW
DIFFICULT THIS BILL. WE HAVE
TWO MORE LINES IN Q. ONE MOBILE
WELL WE SEND THEM THERE BY
NUMBERS. WE'LL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY. DANIEL GOOD CARE OF ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNICATIONS
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT
NINE IN SUPPORT. ONE MORE LINE
JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE. ONE SIXTY FOUR. HI
REGINA THROUGHOUT THE HOUSE OF
EARTHJUSTICE IN SUPPORT. SURE
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE INTO THIS
TIME THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WOULDLIKE TO INDICATE
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE THIRTY
EIGHT. SEEING NONE ABOUT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINE FOR ANYONE WHO'D
LIKE TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE THIRTY EIGHT. TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE KNOWN CHEWING UP AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU HELLO YOU
MAY CLOSE THE LINES OPERATOR OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT
SEEING NONE. SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE THIS ONE I THINK ARE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR COMMENTS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MICHAEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
NO CHAU CHIU. DAVIES DAVIS NO
GONZALEZ CONTROLS AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
REYES BREEZE I. THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS FIVE VOTES IT NEEDS
ONE MORE SOIL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL. WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AGAIN- BEFORE I BEGIN
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE TEN
OF THE ANALYSIS AND WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL FOR THEIR DILIGENCE. I'M
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX WHICH WILL MAKE
VARIOUS STATUTORY CHANGES TO
ENHANCE THE STATE WATER BOARD
IN A ABILITY. TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
IMPLEMENT THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE. DRINKING WATER ACT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AND GOVERNOR
NEWSOM SIGN SB TWO HUNDRED
WHICH ANNUALLY DIRECTED ABOUT
THE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER EFFORTS. AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE OVER THE NEXT
TEN YEARS. THE STATE WATER
BOARD HAS WORKED HARD TO
IMPLEMENT THE LEGISLATURE'S
VISION FOR THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM BUT AS IDENTIFIED A
NUMBER OF CLARIFYING STATUTORY
CHANGES. THAT ARE NEEDED
QUICKLY EFFICIENTLY TO PROVIDE
FUNDING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THESE EFFICIENCIES
INCLUDE CLARIFYING DEFINITIONS
AUTHORIZING THE BOARD TO MAKE
ADVANCE PAYMENTS PROVIDING THE
AUTHORITY TO ACT EXPEDITIOUSLY
TO PURCHASE EMERGENCY BOTTLED
WATER. AND PROVIDING THE
ABILITY TO QUICKLY SEND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
INTO A FAILING SYSTEM. IF IS A
PROFICIENCY CHANGES ARE
BALANCED BY THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS THAT RECAST AND
CONSOLIDATE THE BOARD'S
ADMINISTRATIVE ENFORCEMENT AND
FINING AUTHORITY TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE'S FUNDS DO NOT FALL
VICTIM. TO FRAUD OR ABUSE IT'S
A VERY THOUGHTFUL AND MEASURED
APPROACH THAT PROVIDES
EFFICIENCIES THAT THE WATER
BOARD. NEEDS TO BE NIMBLE AND
EFFECTIVE IN ENSURING SB TWO
HUNDRED FUNDS ARE OUT THE DOOR
INTO COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT
THE MOST. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
TODAY I HAVE YOU ON THE WEST OF
THE DIRECTOR. THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF ENFORCEMENT AT
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR I DO HAVE THE ONE
WITNESS LISTED. YOU'VE ON WEST
ARE YOU WITH US ON THE PHONE.
OPERATED WE DO HAVE A LOT. GO
AHEAD DO NOT THE MESSAGE LEFT
ON THE LINE UP WITH WHAT IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME OPEN
UP YOUR LINE. WE DID HAVE
SOMEONE TO UP TO THIS MIGHT BE
HER. ONE MOMENT PLEASE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU. WHAT'S YOUR LINE
THAT WE HAVE OPEN NOW. YES IT
IS GREAT THANK YOU. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GO AHEAD THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS YVONNE ALAS
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE
OF ENFORCEMENT AT THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AN EMPLOYEE FLETCHER PASSED IN
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED SB TWO
HUNDRED TO SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER ACT. THE STATE
WATER BOARD HAS IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL TECHNICAL CHANGES THAT
ARE NEEDED TO HELP COMMUNITIES
MORE QUICKLY. SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX WILL ALLOW THE WATER BOARD
TO ADOPT EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
TO ENSURE THAT DRINKING WATER
QUALITY DATA IS READILY
AVAILABLE. YOU'LL DO THIS BY
SENDING THE WATER BOARD'S
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE TECHNICAL
REPORTS FROM STATE SMALL WATER
SYSTEM. IS REQUIREMENTS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE BOARD'S
CURRENT AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE.
THE SAME INFORMATION FROM THE
LARGER PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS. IN
ADDITION SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
ALLOW THE WATER BOARD TO
ADDRESS EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
THAT OCCUR AT A FAILING WATER
SYSTEM. BY PROVIDING UP TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN EIGHT
WITHOUT A WRITTEN AGREEMENT FOR
EXAMPLE BY PROVIDING. FOR BEING
ABLE I HAVE TO PROVIDE BOTTLED
WATER. THE BILL ALSO AUTHORED
THE BOARD TO MAKE IT PAYMENTS
SMALL. MORE QUICKLY ACCESS SAFE
DRINKING WATER. A LOT OF WORK
AND GENERALLY MAKE PAYMENTS ON
A REIMBURSEMENT BASIS HOWEVER
THIS PROCESS CAN BE FINANCIALLY
BURDENSOME UNDER FINANCIAL
COMMUNITIES THAT DO NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT CASH FLOW FOR UP
FRONT PAYMENT. SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX WILL ALSO INCLUDE AN
EXEMPTION FROM CERTAIN STATE
CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS WHICH
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED. IN THE PAST
IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT WHICH WERE
NOT INCLUDED IN SB TWO HUNDRED.
THIS PROVISION WILL ALIGN OF
THE DOUBLE LINE THE LEGISLATURE
CONTENT AND ALLOW THE WATER
BOARD'S MORE QUICKLY ACCESS.
DRINKING WATER. MORE QUICKLY
ADDRESS THE TRACKING WATER
EMERGENCIES. AND FINALLY SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX WILL PREVENT.
AND ADDRESS POTENTIAL FRAUD IN
THE SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM FUN BY
NEARING EXISTING AUTHORITIES
CURRENTLY EXERCISED BY THE
WATER BOARD IN OTHER FUNDS
ADMINISTERED THAT WE MINISTER.
HE'S A PRIORITIES ARE IMPORTANT
TO HELP PREVENT MISUSE OF
PUBLIC MONEY. PROTECTION EIGHTY
AND HELP ACHIEVE OUR SHARED
DRINKING WATER GOAL. THANK YOU
FOR CONSIDERING THAT. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX. SEEING NONE ABOUT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY SITE.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
APPLIED FOR ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO ONE TO
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION I DO NOT HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX. SEEING NONE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO INDICATE OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE OPPOSING THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU YOU MAY
CLOSE THE LINES OPERATOR OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING NONE
SENATOR AMY CLOSED THINKING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU I AM LOOKING FOR A MOTION
THAT MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. HE WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MOTION BY MS REYES SECOND BY
MISTER KALRA. CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE HI STONE AYE
GALLAGHER. CHAU CHIU DAVIES
DAVIS NOW GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI KALRA. KALRA
AYE KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN YES
RAYSIDE THAT BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES IT NEEDS ONE MORE SO
WE'LL PLACE IT ON CALL. THANK
YOU SENATOR NOW MOVES TO ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN SB SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK YOU
I THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- FOR THE CHANCE TO
PRESENT. THEIR THE MOTION IS
THEIR SECOND AND THE SECOND
THANK YOU SORRY CENTER GO AHEAD
PLEASE THANK YOU AT- THIS BILL
IS A MODEST STEP TOWARD
IMPROVING FOR THE STATE'S
COLLECTION AND HANDLING OF DATA
INVOLVING INFECTIOUS DISEASE. I
AM PLEASED TO ACCEPTED THE
MOMENT SUGGESTED BY YOUR STAFF
THANK YOU I BASICALLY THE BILL
PROPOSES TO SMALL STEPS TO
BEGIN CLOSING THE DATA GAP.
THAT HAS KEPT US FROM FULLY
UNDERSTANDING THE SPREAD OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE METHODS WE
USE TO CONTROL IT. MORE THAN A
YEAR AFTER COVERT NINETEEN TOOK
THE FIRST OF MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND LIVES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE STILL HAVE VERY LITTLE
SCIENCE. TO EXPLAIN WHAT
CONDITIONS MADE THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS MORE OR LESS LIKELY.
AND WE HAVE LITTLE DATA TO SHOW
WHICH OF THE STEPS WE TOOK TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
WORKED. AND WHICH DID NOT. A
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS AND WE
AS POLICY MAKERS HAVE BEEN
RELYING. LARGELY BLIND. EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST NOTED THAT OUR COVERT
RESPONSE. SEPARATE FROM
OUTDATED DATA COLLECTION
ANALYSIS AND REPORTING SYSTEMS.
THREE ANALYSTS RECOMMENDED THAT
WE UNDERTAKE A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF THE SYSTEMS AS A PART
OF A SWEEPING AFTER ACTION LOOK
AT HOW OUR STATE DEALT WITH
THIS UNPRECEDENTED THREAT. WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO. BUT
THIS BILL DOES ONLY TWO SIMPLE
THINGS FIRST IT WOULD AD
DETAIL TO THREE OF THE MANY
QUESTIONS HEALTH PROVIDERS ASK
THOSE WHO TEST POSITIVE ABOUT
WHERE THEY MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN
INFECTED. IF WE KNOW MORE ABOUT
HOW I DISEASE MIGHT BE
SPREADING WE CAN TAKE SMARTER
STEPS TO STOP ITS SPREAD.
SECOND THE BILL MAKES CHANGES
TO AN EXISTING SYSTEM FOR
SHARING DATA WITH BONA FIDE
RESEARCHERS. SO THAT OUR BEST
SCIENTISTS CAN STUDY THE SPREAD
OF INFECTIOUS DISEASE IN REAL
TIME. AND PROVIDE US WITH THE
INFORMATION WE NEED TO MAKE
INTELLIGENT DECISIONS. ARE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE TO
CREATE A SPECIAL PANEL DURING
EMERGENCIES. TO EVALUATE
RESEARCH REQUESTS AND EITHER
APPROVE OR DENY THEM IN FIFTEEN
DAYS. THE BILL REQUIRES THIS
EXPEDITED PROCESS OF AYE BY ALL
OF THE EXISTING PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS IN LAW. AND WE EVEN
ADD SOME NEW ONES. THIS CAN BE
DONE WHILE STILL BEING MINDFUL
THAT IN A PANDEMIC. EVERY DAY
THAT GOES BY IT'S COSTING
CALIFORNIANS THEIR LIVES.
MEMBERS IT'S TOO LATE TO SAVE
THE LIVES OF THOSE WHO HAVE
DIED DURING THIS TERRIBLE
PANDEMIC BUT IT'S NEVER TOO
EARLY TO PREPARE. FOR THE NEXT
ONE THIS BILL WILL HELP US DO
JUST THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR NIGHT OF. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND I DO HAVE A WITNESS
LISTED DR GEOFF LEE. JEFFREY
KLAUSNER. OF UNIVERSITY
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. DR COSTNER
YOU ON THE LINE. YES MY NAME IS
DR JEFFREY KLAUSNER I'M A
PRACTICING INTERNIST INFECTIOUS
DISEASE SPECIALIST MEDICAL
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND PROFESSOR OF
POPULATION AND PUBLIC HEALTH
SCIENCES UNIVERSITY SELLING
CALIFORNIA TECHNICAL MEDICINE
ALSO FORMER SAN FRANCISCO
DEPUTY HEALTH OFFICER AND CHIEF
MEDICAL OFFICER AS BIG AND
STRONG SUPPORTED SENATE BILL
SEVEN FOUR FOUR WHICH WOULD ADD
NEW DATA ELEMENTS TO
COMMUNICABLE RESPIRATORY
DISEASE REPORTING. AND REQUIRE
THE STATE TO SECURELY SHARE
YEAH THAT THE IDENTIFIED DATA
TO ENABLE CALIFORNIA BASED
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS TO
PERFORM EPIDEMIOLOGIC ANALYSIS
THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE THE CORVETTE
NINETEEN HAS BEEN AN ABJECT
FAILURE WITH OVER SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND- THINK COUNTING NEARLY
70% WERE IN DISADVANTAGED
POPULATIONS OF COLOR. YOU CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT FAILURE HAS
BEEN THE POOR USE OF THAT THE
LOGIC DATA AND THE INABILITY OF
THE STATE TO USE AVAILABLE DATA
TO CREATE A TARGET RESPONSE TO
FOCUSED INTERVENTIONS TO LIMIT
THE COLLATERAL DAMAGE CAUSED BY
BROAD BASED STATEWIDE POLITICS.
BECAUSE THE DECADE THE FUNDING
CUTS TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THE STATE HAS
LIMITED CAPACITY TO ANALYZE
DATA THAT IT DOES COLLECT
FURTHERMORE THE DATA COLLECTED
ARE INCOMPLETE AND INSUFFICIENT
TO SUPPORT OF SCIENCE BASED
RESPONSE. THE LACK OF GOOD DATA
RESULTED IN THE NEGLECT OF
POTENTIAL WORKERS THE FAILURE
TO IMPLEMENT TESTING IN THE
WORK FORCE AND THE FAILURE TO
IDENTIFY AND CONTROL THE SPREAD
OF INFECTION. ON THE FLIP SIDE
THE CLOSURE OF SCHOOLS
PLAYGROUNDS AND OUTDOOR SPACES
RECOMMENDATIONS OF UNFOUNDED
INTERVENTIONS LIKE DEEP
CLEANING ACTIVITIES AND
TEMPERATURE SCREENING WE'RE NOT
BASED ON GOOD DATA BECAUSE WE
SIMPLY DID NOT HAVE ANY SENATE
BILL SEVEN FOUR FOUR WOULD BE A
STEP TOWARD RIGHTING THE
STATE'S FELL PUBLIC ON SYSTEM
BY ADDING RELEVANT. RESPIRATORY
DISEASE EXPOSURE ELEMENTS
DESPITE WHAT YOU MIGHT HEAR
SOON COLLECTING THE ADDED. DATA
ELEMENTS ARE NOT COVERED IT
INTO PRACTICE THINK WHEN IT
LIKE MY- YOUR UNDERMINE REAL.
BETWEEN THE AND THE TO. DOCTORS
ARE TO COLLECT THOSE X. ARE.
WORK PLAYED OUT TYPE DENSITY
TRAVEL. IN THAT SCHOOL AS PART
OF A ROUTINE MEDICAL HISTORY
FURTHERMORE SUCH DATA OFTEN
SELF REPORTED BY PATIENTS AMONG
REGISTRATION AND ENTERED INTO
ELECTRONIC MEDICAL RECORD BY
ANCILLARY STAFF MEMBERS- SUCH
AS WHEN THEY RECORDED SHARON'S
INFORMATION OR HOME ADDRESS. IN
RESPONSE THE COVE IN NINETEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS HAVE
BEEN WORKING IN THE DARK
THERE'S NO WONDER THE DAMAGE
HAS BEEN SEVERE WITH BETTER
DATA SHARED IN ACCESS TO WE CAN
LEVERAGE OUR EXISTING RESOURCES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BOB DOLE
PRESERVING INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY
AND PROTECT THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ALL. THANK YOU. RIGHT
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN CHAMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT FOR SB.
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN FORTY FOUR.
SENAD REMOTE TESTIMONY SAY
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE.
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE IN Q. OPEN MIKE MIKE
WHAT EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CENTER BROWN BOOK
CALLING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND WE
SHOW NO ONE ELSE SHOWING
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OPERATOR WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION I HAVE
NO OPPOSITION. LISTED SO IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SEVEN FORTY FOUR.
SEEING NONE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. SEEING NONE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO EDUCATE
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR. GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND WE DO CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE IN Q. OKAY HAVE TAKEN CARE
OF THAT ONE FIFTEEN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO. HAVE YOUR LINE OPENED.
PRESS. ONE ZERO. IN ONE MOMENT
PLEASE ARE CURRENTLY WITH AN
OPERATOR. IT WILL OPEN LINE
FORTY SEVEN LINE FORTY SEVEN-
LIGHTED UP AT. MISTER MEMBERS A
LITTLE LATE TO THE SUPPORT
PARTY'S PAUL YOUR ON THE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FIND ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. WHAT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING HEARING MEMBERS
BERROCAL FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA YOU SEE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THIS BILL GOAL BUT
THE JUNE TWENTIETH MARCH SEVEN
MEN'S RACE PRIVACY AND
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY CONCERNS
FOR UC RESEARCHERS. THE AUTHOR
OF AWARE OF THESE ISSUES AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH SENATOR GLAZER AND
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU MAY CLOSE THE LINES WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MR GALLAGHER.
YEAH THANKS THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR BRING IN THIS- MEASURE FOR
AND I AND I THINK IT TOUCHES ON
SOMETHING. REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT I THAT WE- SAW DURING THIS
PANDEMIC WHICH IS. THAT YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THE DECISIONS.
SEEM TO BE MADE AT THE COUNTY
HEALTH- OFFICIAL LEVEL LEVEL
AND THE STATE PUBLIC HEALTH-
LEVEL- AND NO DOUBT VERY SMART
AND- GREAT PEOPLE WORKING IN
THOSE FIELDS AND ON THE FRONT
LINES OF THIS- BUT- IT SEEM
LIKE WE DID NOT GET A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND IT DIDN'T SEEM
LIKE THERE AS A LOT OF
SHARING. GOING ON WITH OUR
ACADEMIC COMMUNITY WHICH I
THINK IS VERY CRITICAL WE HAVE
SOME GREAT PUBLIC HEALTH
PROGRAMS IN ACADEMIA HERE IN
THE STATE- AND I THINK THIS
GETS SAID HEY WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THIS DATA IS BEING SHARED.
AND EVEN TIMES WHEN. WE WOULD
INQUIRE OF WHERE ARE YOU
GETTING THE DATA THAT SUPPORTS
THE DECISION THAT IS COMING OUT
OF THIS AND WE'D BE TOLD WELL
WE CAN'T SHARE THAT. DATA WITH
YOU TO BE TO BE SOMEONE WHO IS
IN ELECTED OFFICE AND WHO.
CONSTITUENTS LOOK TO FOR
ANSWERS AS TO WHY THINGS ARE
HAPPENING WHY DECISIONS ARE
COMING OUT OF THE STATE. AND
THEN TO INQUIRE ME TOLD WELL WE
CAN'T GIVE YOU THAT DATA WE
CAN'T SHARE THAT DATA- IS
EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC SO I
THINK THIS BILL IS A GOOD FIRST
STEP OF ENSURING THAT WE- FIRST
OF ALL SHARE THIS INFORMATION
WITH OUR RESEARCHERS AND- AND
SOME REALLY. BRIGHT PEOPLE IN
ACADEMIA DR CLUSTER IS ONE OF
THOSE WHEN YOU'RE WITNESSES AND
DID WAS VERY HELPFUL TO ME. IN
EXPLAINING SOME OF THE YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT. NUANCES OF- OF THIS
PANDEMIC AND HOW TO HOW TO
RESPOND. BUT WHEN THOSE
DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE IN A
VACUUM. AND WITH SORT OF A
GROUP THINK MENTALITY. I DON'T
THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AND UTILIZE. OUR
ACADEMIC NON PROFIT- YOU KNOW
THAT IT IS NOT JUST STATE OR
COUNTY EMPLOYEE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS- YOU HAVE THE ONLY
KNOWLEDGE- TO MAKE THE BEST
RESPONSES AND BEST DECISIONS
REGARDING PANDEMIC I DID WE
REALLY NEED TO BE UTILIZING-
ALL OF OUR RESOURCES ARE GREAT
ACADEMIC RESOURCES IN MAKING
THOSE DECISIONS SO- THIS. TO ME
IS A GREAT FIRST STEP AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU THE THREATS.
SENATOR THIS IS YOU MAY NOTE
LAST YEAR I INTRODUCED EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE THE REPORTING BY
EMPLOYERS WHEN SOMEBODY WAS.
THOSE AFFECTED WITH COVERT. I
LOVE WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE AND
I HOPE THAT IN THE END WE GET
THAT INFORMATION I'M VERY
CONCERNED THAT THAT'S NOT
REALLY WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
BUT I ABSOLUTELY WILL SUPPORT
THIS AND HOPE THAT. THERE ARE.
THE SAFEGUARDS ARE PUT THERE TO
MAKE SURE THAT INDEED WHAT YOU
WANT DONE AND THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU WANT DONE AND
EVERYBODY WHO SHOULD BE
REPORTING- FROM WILL BE DONE.
SO THAT WE REALLY DO GET THE
INFORMATION TO EVALUATE THIS
SO- I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD
TO FINALLY GETTING THESE
REPORTS THAT PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN
BETTER TRACK. HOW PEOPLE ARE
GETTING. THESE COMMUNICABLE
RESPIRATORY DISEASES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SAYING NONE
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS HERE- KIND COMMENTS
TODAY. YEAH ONE OF THE MOST
STUNNING FACTS ABOUT WHAT WE
HAVE JUST GONE THROUGH IS THIS
THAT. ADMITS THAT THAT THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE INFECTED THE
COLLECTION OF. HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS IN DATA. DURING A
PANDEMIC OF THIS INCREDIBLE
MAGNITUDE. THAT THERE WAS NOT A
SINGLE APPROVED REQUESTS FOR
RESEARCH. AND THAT FOR THAT
DATA NOW WE HAVE A PROCESS IN
PLACE IT'S CUMBERSOME AND SLOW
BUT EVEN GIVEN THAT ISN'T IT
AMAZING THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE OUR
OUR BEST MINDS IN THE STATE
HAVE ACCESS TO USABLE DATA TO
HELP US MAKE GOOD DECISIONS.
ALL THE WAY DOWN THE LINE IT
WAS A VERY DIFFICULT THING THAT
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH AND WE'RE
STILL GONG THROUGH. I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THIS CAN HELP
IMPROVE OUR RESPONSE GOING
FORWARD HOPEFULLY WILL NEVER
HAPPEN IN OUR LIVES- BUT WE
NEED TO DO THINGS BETTER WE ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND THIS BILL
WILL HELP THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
CONSIDERATION TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER
I CHAO. TROOP DAVIES DAVIES I
GONZALEZ AND SALAS I HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
REYES REYES AYE THAT BILLS OUT
THANK YOU SENATE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. REYES WE HAVE TWO BILLS
SENATORS DORADO AND ALAN. SO IN
THE MEANTIME. WHAT WE GO
THROUGH THE ROLE AGAIN.
STARTING WITH THE CONSIDER THE-
CALL ANY OF THE MEMBERS. FOR
CONSENT CHAO HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY KILEY
AYE MAIENSCHEIN. THANK YOU
LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER ONE S.
B. FORTY ONE NUMBER CALL THE OF
THE MEMBERS. HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
KILEY KILEY I MENTION. QUEUE
ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. TWO
ELEVEN NUMBER CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
TWO FORTY ONE UMBERG PROBABLY
UP TO MEMBERS HOLDEN. HOLDEN
AYE KILEY. KELLY I MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER FOR SB
THREE FORTY NINE NUMBER CALL
THE S. R. NUMBER CHAU. HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE KILEY. KILEY I
MAIENSCHEIN. THANK YOU- ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
PAN IS ON CALL A LITTLE LIFT
THE CALL VOLUMES OF MEMBERS.
CHAO HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO NOT VOTING MAIENSCHEIN.
OKAY. THANK YOU THE BILL IS NOW
OUT. MOVED ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE IS ON CALL IN
THE LIFT THE CALL. GALLAGHER
CHAO. HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE KALRA
KALRA AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
MAIENSCHEIN IN CHENNAI THE BILL
IS OUT AT NUMBER EIGHT SB SEVEN
A TO THE MON IS ON CALL A
LITTLE BIT THE CALL. GALLAGHER
GALLAGHER NO CHAO HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE KALRA KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I THE
BILL IS OUT I REMEMBER NINE SB
THREE SIXTY THREE LEYVA IS ON
CALL AND LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER NO CHAO
CHIU. KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE OKAY THE NEEDS
OF STILL WON MORE VOTES FROM
GOING TO REPLACE THE CALL ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
HUESO IS ON CALL MIDDLE IF THE
CALL. GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER R.
CHAO CHIU. GONZALEZ KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN MENTION I
THINK YOU THE BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN SB SIX FORTY SIX
HERTZBERG IS ON CALL AND LIFT
THE CALL. GALLAGHER. CHAO TO
AND SALAS. MAIENSCHEIN MAIN
CHENNAI OKAY THE BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR HERTZBERG ON CALL
I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL.
CHAO CHAO I TO. MAIENSCHEIN
MENTION I AGREE THIS YES I THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU FOR
REMEMBER THIRTEEN SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT GONZALEZ IS ON
CALL AND LIFT THE CALL. CHAO
CHAO AYE CHIU MAIENSCHEIN MAIN
CHENNAI THAT BILL IS OUT THEN
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX GONZALEZ IS ON
CALL IF THE CALL CHAO CHAO BY
TWO. MAIENSCHEIN MAIN CHENNAI
CAPABILITY OUT MEN SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR IS ALREADY OUT BUT
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU MAIENSCHEIN MENTION
ACT THANK YOU AND THEN SENATOR
REID SO. I'VE NEVER SIXTEEN SB
TWO SEVENTY WELCOME. THANK YOU
GOOD ACTORS BECAUSE IT
AFTERNOON NOT YET ALMOST
MORNING- CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB
TWO SEVENTY WILL ENSURE PUBLIC
EMPLOYER GOING TO STATIONS
RECEIVE ACCURATE AND TIMELY
BARGAINING UNIT INFORMATIO
WHICH THEY ARE ALREADY ENTITLED
TO BY LAW SO THAT THEY MAY
FULFILL THEIR LEGAL
REPRESENTATIONAL DUTIES AND
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
BARGAINING UNIT AS A WHOLE- I'D
OF SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES. TWO
HUNDRED FORTY TWO HAVE NOT
SUBMITTED THE MONTHLY NEW HIRE
LIST AS REQUIRED BY CURRENT LAW.
SINCE THE START OF THE CALENDAR
YEAR WITH NO CONSEQUENCES WE
MERELY WANT TO ESTABLISH
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES WITH
PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO CURE THE PROBLEM
RESPOND AND AVOID ANY
INVOLVEMENT FROM PER. THIS
MEASURE CREATES NO NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS IT'S SIMPLY A CENTER
VISES COMPLIANCE WITH EXISTING
LAW AND PROVIDE SPEC
FLEXIBILITY TO EMPLOYERS SO
THAT THEY MAY MEET THE CURRENT
LEGAL OBLIGATIONS. AND
EMPLOYEES COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
REPRESENTATIVE HAS A MORAL AND
LEGAL DUTY TO WATCH OUT FOR THE
WELFARE OF THEIR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. WHO IN TURN WATCH
OUT FOR THE PUBLIC'S WELLBEING.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
ORGANIZATION- EMPLOYER
ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVE THE
INFORMATION AS REQUIRED BY LAW
ON A TIMELY BASIS- THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE BILL THAT
RESTRICTS THE ABILITY OF UNIONS
AND EMPLOYERS TO RESOLVE
VIOLATIONS WITHOUT INVOLVING
PER OR PENALTIES. FOR THESE
REASONS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY BRING SB TWO
SEVENTY BEFORE YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES LISTED SANDRA
FERRERO FROM THE C. S. C. A.
WHO IS HERE IN PERSON GOOD AND
THEN LEVY SANCHEZ ON THE
TELEPHONE. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
GOOD ALMOST AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SANDRA
BARRERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE CO SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL AS SENATOR DRAWS
OF STATED THIS BILL INTENDS TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC EMPLOYERS WHO
ROUTINELY VIOLATE THE LAW AND
MAKE NO EFFORT TO COMPLY THE
INFORMATION EMPLOYERS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDEIS TIME
SENSITIVE AND RESOLVING
VIOLATIONS DIRECTLY WITH
EMPLOYERS IS THE FASTEST WAY TO
RECEIVE IT. THE PER PROCESS CAN
TAKE AROUND ONE YEAR. SINCE WE
NEED THE INFORMATION AT
SPECIFIC INTERVALS IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO GO THROUGH PER
UNLESS THE PLAN PLAYER HAS A
HISTORY OF EGREGIOUS VIOLATIONS.
A BORDER AGENT CANNOT ASSESS A
PENALTY AT THE INITIAL INFORMAL
LEVELS WITHIN PER. A PENALTY
CAN ONLY BE ASSESSED BY AN ALJ
AFTER A FORMAL HEARING. THE
ATTORNEYS FEES PROVISION
DISINCENTIVE ISIS FRIVOLOUS
APPEALS THAT WASTES TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND ATTORNEY'S FEES
WOULD ONLY ACCRUE. IF A PARTY
APPEALS AN ALJ DECISION AND THE
DECISION IS ULTIMATELY UP HELD.
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS FOR
EMPLOYERS IN THE BILL. ONE IS
THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT A UNION
IS REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THE
EMPLOYER WITH NOTICE BEFORE
FILING A PER CHARGE INCLUDING
THE SPECIFIC VIOLATIONS. AND IF
THE VIOLATION IS MISSING OR
INACCURATE DATA A UNION IS
REQUIRED TO WAIT TEN DAYS
BEFORE FILING UP CURB. UNLESS
THE UNION HAS ALREADY PROVIDED
THE TEN DAYS MORE THAN THREE
TIMES IN TWELVE MONTHS. THE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT AND CURE
PERIOD ARE NOT IN EXISTING LAW.
MUST ALSO CONSIDER THE SEVERITY
OF THE VIOLATION BEFORE
ASSESSING A PENALTY. AND SINCE
THERE IS NO MINIMUM PENALTY
AMOUNT INCLUDED IN THE BILL AND
L. J. COULD ASSESS A PENALTY OF
ONE CENT. IT'S AGAINST THE
UNION'S BEST INTEREST TO
PENALIZE THE SAME ENTITIES WE
NEGOTIATE WITH ON COMPENSATION
PROPOSALS OUR GOAL IS TO GET
THE INFORMATION WE NEED TO
REPRESENT OUR MEMBERS. SB TWO
SEVENTY WILL MOTIVATE EMPLOYERS
WHO WILLFULLY VIOLATE THE LAW
TO REACH COMPLIANCE BY THE
BILL'S ENACTMENT DATE OF JULY
TWENTY TO. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
THEN THE B. SANCHEZ WITH US ON
THE TELEPHONE. GOOD MORNING MR
CARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LUÍT SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE SEIU CALIFORNIA
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. IT IS OUR
SINCEREST HOPE BUT THE RESULT
OF THAT FEE TO SEVENTY WILL BE
THAT UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE
CHARGES ARISING OUT OF
VIOLATIONS OF GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION THIRTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT. NO LONGER HAVE TO BE
FILED AND THAT THE ATTORNEY
FEES AND COSTS PROVISIONS THAT
THE MEASURE WILL NEVER HAVE TO
BE RELIED UPON. THIS BILL DOES
NOTHING TO CHANGE AN EMPLOYER'S
OBLIGATIONS UNDER EXISTING LAW
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE MAJORITY
OF EMPLOYERS HAVE FOUND IT EASY
TO COMPLY. AND ARE IN FACT IN
FULL COMPLIANCE SO WHY IS THIS
BILL NECESSARY. BECAUSE IN THE
SHORT PINE GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION THIRTY FIVE FIFTY EIGHT
HAVE BEEN ON THE BOOKS. SOME
EMPLOYERS HAVE SIMPLY BEEN
UNWILLING TO COMPLY WITH THE
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND NOT UNDULY
BURDENSOME OBLIGATIONS
CONTAINED THEREIN. IT IS
UNFORTUNATELY BECOME ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR THAT THE LACK OF
COMPLIANCE. ONLY TO AN
EMPLOYER'S ABILITY TO SCORE
COMPLIANCE WITH IMPUNITY IN
OTHER WORDS EMPLOYERS AREN'T
AFRAID OF THE REPERCUSSIONS OF
VIOLATION BECAUSE THERE REALLY
ARE NOT. EXCEPT OF COURSE THE
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES AND
THEIR UNIONS WHO ARE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED IN NUMEROUS WAYS BY
THE VIOLATIONS. IF THE INTENT
OF LABOR LAWS ARE TO LEVEL AND
ON LEVEL PLAYING FIELD THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THE GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION THIRTY FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT ACT IN THE EQUALISING
MANNER. THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED GIVING SCOFFLAW
EMPLOYERS STATUTORY KNOWLEDGE
THEY NEED TO COMPLY AND IN NO
WAY DILATORY ASLI. AFFECTING
GOOD ACTORS. SO IT'S PROBABLY%
IS A THOUGHTFUL AND- BOUND
APPROACH TO RUN THE PROBLEM.
FIRST BILL TO BE IN THE LAST
QUARTER COMPLY WITH THE LAW AND
NOT HAPPENED NO YOU ARE. NO FOR
A THIRTY AND- EFFECTIVE THE
BILL ENCOURAGES LOCAL BY
PROVIDING THE TO CARE AND IF. A
CALL A FOR DEEP YOU STRUCTURE
AGAIN THIS IS A BILL ARE
HOPEFUL OPTIMA WILL IF EVER
HAVE TO BE BUT WITHOUT IT THE
PROTECTION THE LEGISLATURE
THOUGHT THEY WERE IMPARTING TO
PUBLIC SECTOR WORKERS UNDER
GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION THIRTY
FIVE FIFTY EIGHT WILL CONTINUE
TO BE ALL BUT ILLUSORY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE WILL MOVE
TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF SB TWO SEVENTY GO AHEAD
PLEASE THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAC CRIMMINS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS. HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND WOULD ENCOURAGE DR
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS. SEEING
NONE ANYONE OF THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SITE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO LIKED
INDICATES SUPPORT FOR S. B. TWO
SEVENTY. I'D BE GLAD TO LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
PICK UP THE PART OF SB TWO
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS. ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY
HAVE FIVE IN Q. WILL START WITH
LINE NUMBER ONE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MONOMYTH
STRUCTURE- MEMBERS SEPTEMBER
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE AND SUPPORT. ONE ONE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU COULD STOP MAYOR WITH
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR OUR SPONSORS AND TO THIS
COMMITTEE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. TWO SEVENTY SIX.
ONE ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN BURE'S HUNG IN THE ON
BEHALF OF UNITED AUTO WORKERS
WHAT THEIR STATE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER MEMBERS
PAUL YOUR CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ONE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE COMMITTEE CHAIRED
EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION-
PLEASE BIGGER IT'S COSPONSORED
STRONG SUPPORT. AND BEFORE YOU
OPEN LINE SEVENTY AS A REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PART OF SB
TWO SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO NINE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DANIEL GOOD CARE OF A
HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF INTERPRETERS AND
ON BEHALF OF UNITED PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES BOTH IN SUPPORT. AND
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE ON SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE
WILL THEN MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
DO NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LISTED SO IS THERE
ANYONE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AT JASON SCHMELZER HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF PRISM PUBLIC RISK
INNOVATION SOLUTIONS IN
MANAGEMENT FIRST I JUST WANNA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR SPENDING SO MUCH
TIME TALKING TO US ABOUT THIS
BILL BUT ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
CO SPONSORS AFTER THREE
MEETINGS THAT THEY'VE HAD WITH
US AYE AND THE SENATOR- THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF CONVERSATION I
THINK EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO GET
TO A GOOD PLACE SELL. AT SECOND
I JUST WANT TO SAY YOU KNOW IT
SAID THIS CLEARLY BEFORE I'LL
SAY IT AGAIN WE'RE NOT HERE- I
THINK TO OPPOSE THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
SIMPLY NOT PROVIDING THE
REQUIRED LISTS TO THEIR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE UNIONS THAT IS NOT WHY
WE'RE HERE- WE UNDERSTAND WHY
THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS
WOULD WANT TO IMPOSE PENALTIES
AND PROTECT THEMSELVES I WITH
ATTORNEYS FEES AND COURT COSTS
IN THAT SCENARIO. WHAT WE ARE
CONCERNED WITH IS THE WAY THAT
YOU SEVENTY STRUCTURES ITSELF
AS IT PERTAINS TO INACCURATE OR
INCOMPLETE LIST SO HERE'S WHAT
THE BILL DOES IT HOLD PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO STANDARD THE
CAMPING MAT- ONE OF PERFECTION
ANY SINGLE VIOLATION ANY SINGLE
INCORRECT DATA FIELD. IN THE
LIST PROVIDED TO EMPLOYERS IS
GROUNDS FOR A VIOLATION OF THE
UNION CAN. CHOOSE TO. PURSUE
THAT VIOLATION. AT TELLS
EMPLOYERS WHO FILE SEVERAL
HUNDRED OF THESE LISTS IN THE
YEAR THEY CAN ONLY FIX THEIR
ERRORS THREE TIMES IN THE
CALENDAR YEAR BEFORE BEING
SUBJECT TO AN UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICE CHARGE OF THE UNION'S
DISCRETION. AND IT ALLOWS PROBE
TO LEVY PENALTIES THE GO TO THE
GENERAL FUND AN ATTORNEY'S FEES
AND COURT COSTS FOR THE UNION.
WE SUGGESTED THAT THE BILL BE
AMENDED TO ALLOW PUBLIC
EMPLOYERS TO UTILIZE THE CURE
PROVISION. ANY TIME THAT
THEY'RE NOTIFIED OF AN
INACCURATE OR INCOMPLETE LIST.
OF BY THE UNION. UNDER THE
PROVISION OF THE UNION WOULD
HAVE THE CORRECT INFORMATION IN
TEN DAYS OR- EVERY REMEDY UNDER
THE BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY
DRAFTED WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
THEM SO THEY WOULD EITHER GET
TIMELY DATA WHICH WE HEARD JUST
NOW WAS THE PURPOSE FOR THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO ENFORCE. AS
INDICATED IN THE BILL. THIS
WOULD PRODUCE THE ACCURATE DATA
DESIRED IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
ALSO PLAYS THE BAD ACTORS BUT
WHAT IT WOULDN'T DO IS HOLD
EMPLOYERS TO AN IMPOSSIBLE
STANDARD. AB SO WITH THAT I DO
WANT TO REPLY- SPECIFICALLY TO
PAGE FIVE THE ANALYSIS WHERE
IT'S KIND OF ASSERTED THAT PER
WILL BE THE LAST RESORT FOR THE
UNIONS AND THEN YOU JUST HEARD
THIS FROM THE SPONSORS AS WELL.
AB THAT MAY BE THE CASE THAT
THE UNIONS MAY NOT PURSUE- WHAT
WHAT THEY COULD WHICH IS A
VIOLATION ON EVERY REPORT. BUT
IF THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
OUTCOME MAYBE THE BILL SHOULD
REFLECT THAT AT THE STANDARD IN
THE BILL THE WORDS ON THE PAGE.
OUR OUR PERFECTION AND
POSSIBILITY OF VIOLATION FOR
ANY TIME YOU'RE NOT PERFECT WE
THINK THAT THAT SHOULD BE
CHANGED. AND I WOULD LOVE TO
WORK OUT AMENDMENTS IN THAT
REGARD AND REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. HELLO MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS STATE FOR JUST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY WHO RESPECTFULLY
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF MR SMELTER. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN
THE CHAMBERS SEEING NONE OF THE
WROTE TESTIMONY SIDE. SEEING
NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU OPEN
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO SEVEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
TAKE NUMBER FOR THEIR LAST
MONEY BUT NAME AFFILIATION AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND TO
RECURRENTLY HAVE FOREIGN Q. WAS
THAT WITH MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIRTY
CAN ONLY HAPPEN THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION. ONE ONE EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DILLON
GIVEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION. ONE EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
AMBER CAME WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHARE
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REGION'S PREVIOUSLY STATED YEAH.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RYAN COOGLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION PARTY.
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS JOHNNY PINI WITH THE
BIG OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
RESPECT OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AT ZERO. WE HAVE NOT ONE NOT
ONE OF SUPPORTING THE BILL.
RIGHT THANK YOU ARE PRETTY MAY
CLOSE THE LINES OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISS
DAVIES. HE CENTER JUST
QUESTION OF IF YOU COULD ANSWER
REALLY WHAT THE OPPOSITION-
WITH STATING IS WHY IS IT THAT
YOU LIMITED TO THREE TIMES IN
TWELVE MONTHS- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE. AND MY
WENT WHITE WIDE LIMB OF THREE
MONTHS I'M SORRY THREE TIMES.
WELL- IT WASN'T ANY WE ADDED
THAT- OPPORTUNITY TO CURE-
SEVERAL TIMES WHICH IS NOT IN
OUR PREVIOUS A PREVIOUS BILL-
AND IT'S- INTENDED TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY THERE WILL ALWAYS
BE AN OPPORTUNITY IN ADDITION
TO THAT TO DO IT INFORMALLY.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT WE CUT YOU
YOU KNOW IT'S ABOUT GETTING
EMPLOYERS TO DO WHAT IS ALREADY
THE LAW SO THERE IS A INFORMAL
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE THERE'S A
FORMAL OPPORTUNITY TO CARE- AND
WE THINK THAT THAT REALLY
ADDRESSES- ANY CONCERNS. OKAY
JUST- YEAH I JUST YOU DON'T
WITH WITH THE NUMBER THREE AND
I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE GOING
WITH THIS I JUST- IS THE
OPPOSITION STATED I THINK I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE WERE YOU DO
HAVE DIFFERENT SIZES OF-
NUMBERS OF ARGUED INCIDENT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE GETTING A
LIST OF PEOPLE COME IN- SO THEY
MAY NEED TO GO MORE THANTHREE
TIMES COULD BE FIVE OR SIX. YOU
KNOW WHAT WILL WHY IS THERE ANY
WAY OF JUST LEAST PULLING OUT
THEIR THREE. I'M SORRY WHAT WAS
THE LAST PART YOU SAID. I MEAN
IT'S YOU KNOW IT IT ANY
THOUGHTS ON AMENDING AND
PULLING OUT THE JUST THE NUMBER
THAT YOU WENT WITH THREE. WELL
LIKE I SAID THIS WAS ADDED- THE
TEN DAY CARE WAS ADDED TO. WHAT
HAD. BEEN THE VERSION OF THE
LAW BEFORE SO. WE THINK WE'RE-
WE'VE RESPONDED TO. TO THE
ISSUE. THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU. A FEW OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU I'M LOOKING FOR
A MOTION OF MOTIONS TO PASS.
THANK YOU DO PASSED THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER. CHAU
CHARGE TO DAVIES DAVIS NO
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY. I'M SORRY KILEY CARINO
MAIENSCHEIN INTERN I REYES YES
I THANK YOU SENATOR THAT BILLS
OUT THANK YOU MEMBERS. WE HAVE
ONE MORE BILL SENATOR ALLEN'S
BILL. OKAY WHILE WE WAIT FOR
LET'S GO THROUGH THE AGENDA
AGAIN AND. GET ADD ONS STARTING
WITH THE CONSENT AGENDA. ANY
MISSING MEMBERS. CONSENT CHAO
CHOW I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I THANK YOU ADAM NUMBER ONE SB
FORTY ONE CALL IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I. THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
TWO ELEVEN NUMBER COLLAPSE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I. DO I HAVE NUMBER
THREE SB TWO FORTY ONE NUMBER
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I.
REMEMBER FOR SB THREE FORTY
NINE NUMBER CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS CHOW CHOW I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN II. THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
PAN PAUL IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAO. OUR AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAJOR
AND I. ADAM NUMBER SEVEN SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE MCGUIRE ALL ANY
OF THE MEMBERS CHAO. CHAO I. I
HAVE NEVER EIGHT SB SEVEN OH
TWO LIMON CALL ANY OF THE
MEMBERS CHOW. CHOW I. THE
BOTTOM NUMBER NINE SB THREE
SIXTY THREE LEYVA IS ON CALL
I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL. CHAO
CHAO I CHIU. KILEY. THE BILL IS
NOW OUT ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN HUESO QUALITY OF
THE MEMBERS CHAO. CHAO AYE CHIU.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I RIGHT I
REMEMBER ELEVEN SB SIX FORTY
SIX HERTZBERG CALLING HIM TO
MEMBERS GALLAGHER CHAO CHARGE
YOU GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I. THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB SEVEN
SEVEN FOUR HERTZBERG CALLING
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIU. THANK
YOU OUT OF OVER THIRTEEN SB
THREE THIRTY EIGHT AND SALAS
CALLING THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO.
I REMEMBER FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX GONZALEZ- ANY OF THE
MEMBERS TO. K. ADAM NUMBER
FIFTEEN SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR
GLAZER CALLING UP THE MEMBERS
TO. AND ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN SB
TWO SEVENTY THE RISE OF QUALITY
OF THE MEMBERS GALLAGHER CHIEF.
THANK YOU FOR THE TEXAS SIDE OF
OVER SEVENTEEN SB SIX TWO SB
FORTY FOUR SENATOR ALAN WELCOME.
I APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT FROM
MY COLLEAGUES HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IS A BILL THAT WE
PASSED LAST YEAR BUT IT GOT. HE
WAS TIED TO ANOTHER BILL DIDN'T
PASS SO- WE'RE WE'RE BACK BUT I
DO APPRECIATE THE- THE- THE-
THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF WORKING
WITH US TO GET THIS TO PLACE
HER WITH HIS MUTE MUTUALLY
AGREEABLE- LITTLE RECEIVED BY
PARK BROAD BI PARTISAN SUPPORT
NOT A SINGLE NO VOTE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR IT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ASSUMING THAT TO
RESOURCES. HE WOULD BE THE
TESTIFIED SUPPORTER MICHAEL
TURNER WITH ALI METRO AND
MICHAEL PIMENTEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSITION THANK YOU
CENTER YOUR TAKING S. SENATE AS
AUTHORS OF EVENTS THE EVENT
THAT'S WHAT I I. EXCEPT EXCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS- PUBLIC ABSOLUTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OKAY SO WE
DO HAVE. THIS FOR WITNESS
LISTED MICHAEL TURNER FROM LA
METRO AND THEN MICHAEL PIMENTEL
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION MICHAEL TURNER.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS MICHAEL TURNER
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY BOARD
OF DIRECTORS AND I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR ALAN AFTER
HEARING THE BILL AND TAKE THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US-
TO IMPROVE THIS BILL. A METROS
WORKING AGGRESSIVELY TO DELIVER
TRANSIT INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
THROUGH OUR AMBITIOUS TWENTY
EIGHT BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
PLAN TO HELP L. A. COUNTY MEET
THE TRANSPORTATION NEEDS. OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TEN MILLION
RESIDENTS BUT ALSO TO MEET THE
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS OF THE
OLYMPICS SB FORTY FOUR WOULD
APPLY STREAMLINED JUDICIAL
REVIEW PROCESS TO KEY TRANSIT
PROJECTS THAT SERVICE CLEAN
TRANSIT ALTERNATIVES AND
CONNECTORS TO REGIONAL MOBILITY
FOR COMMUTERS THROUGHOUT LA
COUNTY. WHICH IS THE MOST
CONGESTED REGION IN THE NATION.
SB FORTY FOUR WILL HELP US TO
ACCELERATE THE PROJECT REVIEW
BY APPLYING THE SHORTENED
LITIGATION PICK UP PROCESS. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT ENSURING EQUITY
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY PROVIDING
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATIONS AND
ROBUST PUBLIC OUTREACH ARE
ESSENTIAL TOOLS TO SUCCESSFUL
TRANSIT PROJECT DELIVERY. WITH
PRIORITIZE THESE PROJECTS WITH
THAT IN MIND. WHAT WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THESE PROJECTS ARE NOT
REQUIRES PART OF THE BID TO
SECURE THE GAMES THEY WILL HELP
TO IMPROVE CONGESTION. IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY THE LASTING
LEGACY IN OUR COUNTY. BUT THE
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND APPRECIATE
ANY SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THEN MICHAEL PIMENTEL.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING- GOOD AFTERNOON
RATHER MICHAEL PIMENTEL EXACT
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSISTORS EACH REPRESENTING.
EIGHTY FIVE TRAINS AND RAIL
AGENCIES STATEWIDE. PLEASED TO
JOIN YOU TODAY TO VOICE TO
TRANSIT INDUSTRY SUPPORT FOR.
CENTER ALLEN JUST BE FORTY FOUR
AND DIDN'T CURSE THE COMMITTEE
TO PASS. THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD MISTER
TURNER NOTED THIS BILL WOULD
ESTABLISH EXPEDITED
ADMINISTRATIVE AND JUDICIAL
FOR A NARROW BAND OF ZERO
EMISSION SIX GUIDEWAY TRANSIT
PROJECTS. AND AS AMENDED IN THE
COMMITTEE- IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES. NOW THIS BILL SUPPORT
THE EXPEDITE DELIVERY OF LARGE
SCALE TRANSIT PROJECT THE KIRBY
EMPTY AND THAT REDUCE.
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR EMISSIONS.
ROGER TAP THE POWER TO. REGION
CREATE GOOD PAYING JOBS IN
CONSTRUCTION ENTRANCE
OPERATIONS. I IN THE CATALYZED
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY NOW THAN A
THIRTY THREE HAVE AN EXTENDED
HISTORY OF SUPPORTING EFFORTS.
TO STREAMLINE THE INVITE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS
THAT TYPICALLY FOR TRANSIT
PROJECTS INCLUDING IN LAST
YEAR'S NEARLY IDENTICAL SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN- AND WITH THAT
WE ARE PLEASED TO AGAIN VOICE
OUR SUPPORT FOR SB FORTY FOUR
TODAY. AND- TRIED NOT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OTHERS AND SUPPORTERS ANYONE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO. OFFER SUPPORT SB TWO SB
FORTY FOUR THIS GUIDE GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MAC CRIMMINS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HERE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN THE CHAMBERS
SEEING NONE ANYONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION.
SEEING NONE OPERATOR WOULD YOU
OPEN THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT
FOR SB FORTY FOUR AND AGAIN
WE'RE TAKING. NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO APPETITE. AND RIGHT
NOW WE CURRENTLY HAVE FOUR IN
Q. WITHOUT WITH MY NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AGAIN THREE ACTUALLY
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF. LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI. IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL RAIL AUTHORITY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS MAX. ONE ONE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOSHUA
SHAW WITH FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES LOOKING FORWARD TO A
SUCCESSFUL L. A. COUNTY
DEMONSTRATION THEY ARE MONTEREY
SALINAS SALINAS TRANSIT
DISTRICT THE SOLANO
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT AND CALTRAIN IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR THANK
YOU. ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OAKLAND SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MADELINE COOPER WITH NIELSEN
MARC MARON THE HALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA WE
REMAIN IN A PART OF AMENDED
POSITION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU ALL. ONE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRIS WILSON
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB FORTY FOUR
THANK YOU. AND ONE NINETY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JUST TO HER WITH THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE ON SUPPORT. THANK YOU
OPERATOR WE'LL NOW MOVED
OPPOSITION AND ONE OPPOSITION
WITNESS LISTED KATE NITTA OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL. ARE YOU
WITH US. S. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND GOOD AFTERNOON ON
TERROR NUMBER YOU KNOW WHAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
AND IF YOU DON'T COUNCIL IS
OPPOSED BY THREE THIRTY FOUR A
MONTH FOR THE MANAGERS MOOSE
ACT BUT IF YOU DO SOME OF YOU
CONVENTION I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE
THAT THE COUNCIL OPPOSITION
LIMITED TO THEMSELVES IMPACT ON
THE COURTS AND DOES NOT SPENT
THE OTHER PROVISIONS BILL. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXPAND THE
COMPANY THANKS THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE SOCCER WORKING
DILIGENTLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
COURT ON THAT NO WE APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY THE
COMMITTEE TO NARROW THE SCOPE
OF THE BILL AND THE GIVE THE
COURT INCREASE HI AND THE
QUESTION AT HAND IN HANDLING A
PARTICULAR WHAT HE SAYS. NEVER
LAST WEEK HEALTH REMAINS
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE
PEOPLE CASES ARE ARE ALREADY
ENTITLED TO CONFERENCE OVER
OTHER CIVIL ACTIONS AND THE
BILL UNDULY INTERFERES WITH THE
COURT'S ABILITY TO MANAGE THEIR
OWN CALENDARS AND THE RIPPLE
AND OTHER IMPORTANT KEY TYPES
BEING DELAYED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO
TO. AND IS THERE ANY HERE AND-
WITH TO INTO OPPOSITE TO SB.
FOUR SEEING NONE THE REMOTE TO.
STATION C. NONE OPERATOR YOU
OPALEYE TO ANY WHO WOULD LIKE
INDICATE OPPOSITE TO ASK. FORTY
FOUR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FORTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE TO ZERO FOR
SB FORTY FOUR. AND THERE'S NO
ONE OPPOSING THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU I WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT SIGNALED
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE. WE
SHOULD ALL SUPPORT PURSUE THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE RAV THIS
IS ONLY SEVEN PROJECTS IN LOS
ANGELES. IT'S GOING TO HELP
EXPEDITE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THESE PROJECTS THAT WILL HELP
ANGELINA'S GET AROUND GET
AROUND MORE QUICKLY AND WITHOUT
A RESPECT YES RIVAL THANK YOU
SENATOR WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE AYE
STONE AYE GALLAGHER. CHAU CHOI
CHU DAVIES DAVIES I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE KILEY EARLY
I'VE MENTIONED MENTION I RAISE
REYES AYE THANK YOU THE BILL'S
ADVOCATES. THANK YOU SENATOR-
EVEN THOUGH EVERYBODY'S LEAVING
I WOULD LIKE TO OFFICIALLY
THANK THIS IS OUR LAST
SCHEDULED HEARING FOR THIS YEAR
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR
INCREDIBLE STAFF FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK. UP TO THIS POINT OUR
CHIEF COUNSEL ALISON MERRILEES
DEPUTY CHIEF COUNSEL ORDERS AND
SEND OUR STAFF COUNSEL TOM
CLARK JEFF MEGADETH AND IN NYC
LICKEY END OF COURSE THE
INCREDIBLE CITY MARATHI AND
GRANTS SILVA WITH WHOM NOTHING
WOULD EVER GET DONE AROUND
HERE. THANK YOU FOR A GREAT
YEAR AND THANK YOU TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR A LITTLE BIT I
THINK WE HAVE. AT LEAST ONE
OTHER MEMBER TO COME AND VOTE
SO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
A FEW MINUTES TO ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN.
RIGHT WERE. YOU CALLED
MR TO AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THE GOOD- COMMITTEE WAS BLESSED
THIS YEAR TO HAVE AN ABSOLUTELY
AMAZING SCIENCE FELLOW. VERY
SOLOMON AND YOU HEARD HER
PRAISES BEING SUNG BY SEVERAL
OF THE SENATORS FOR THE
INCREDIBLE WORK. DONE ON BILLS.
THIS YEAR HAVING A SCIENCE
FELLOW IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
SHE WAS A- JUST AN AMAZING
MEMBER OF THE TEAM. BOTH FOR
PERSONAL STAFF AND THREW
COMMITTEE STAFF SO MERRY THANK
YOU. YOU ARE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
RIGHT SO LET'S SEE
IF WE CAN WRAP UP OUR BUSINESS
SPENDING STARTING WITH ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB THREE SIX SIXTY
THREE LEYVA. TWO FIVE TWO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN HUESO CHIP. JULY SB SIX
FORTY SIX HERTZBERG. CHU CHU I
REMEMBER TWELVE SB SEVEN SEVEN
FOUR HERTZBERG CHU CHU I
REMEMBER THIRTEEN SB THREE
THIRTY EIGHT AND SALAS CHU. CHU
I REMEMBER FOURTEEN SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX GONZALEZ TO. CHU HI
ITEM NUMBERS FIFTEEN SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR GLAZER CHU CHU I.
ADAM NUMBER SIXTEEN S. B. TWO
SEVENTY TO RAZA GALLAGHER CHIU.
TWO I HAVE NEVER SEVENTEEN SB
FORTY FOUR HOURS GALLAGHER JUNE
JULY. I THINK THAT'S EVERYTHING
FOR YOU. I THINK WE HAVE YOU
THROUGH EIGHT ALREADY- THE.
LOCAL.
ALL RIGHT I THINK WE'VE
GOT EVERYBODY WHO CARE TO VOTE
ON ALL OF OUR ITEMS THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH AND WE ARE THE
GERMANS.